IS THIS.
.
STAYS HONORING.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CALLING THE
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
I DO NOT SEE.
QUORUM YET.
SO WHY DON'T WE START.
AS.
.
BUT WE DON'T WANT.
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE ARM AFTER THE
COURT IS ESTABLISH WE WILL.
.
YOU'LL VOTE SO PRIOR TO THAT WE
WILL NOT ACTUALLY THE COMMITTEE
WILL NOT ACTUALLY VOTE BUT THEY
WILL IN FACT YOUR BILLS.
I WE HAVE THIRTY SIX BILLS ON
FILE TODAY AND TWELVE ARE ON
CONSENT THAT'S THIRTY SIX BILLS
TWELVE ON CONSENT.
THAT'S FORTY EIGHT BILLS THAT'S
A LOT OF BILLS AND THE LAST TIME
I CHECKED THE AT CODE IS PRETTY
HIGH ALREADY IN A LOT OF PEOPLE
WANT TO MAKE IT EVEN TALLER.
WHEN YOU STACK IT UP AND I THINK
WHEN YOU REALLY NEED TO BE
CAREFUL WITH THAT BECAUSE I
THINK.
SUCCESS IN THE EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENT COMES THROUGH
INNOVATION AND HARD WORK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHAT WE CAN DO BEST
UP HERE IS PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
LAWYER SOME BILLS ABOUT THAT
TODAY. FOR SURE.
AND ALSO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR
LOCAL CONTROL AND ALSO FOR
DISTRICT INNOVATE THAT'S HOW
BEST WE OPERATE FROM SACRAMENTO.
NOT BY PUTTING THROUGH A LOT OF
THINGS A MICRO MANAGE EDUCATION
FROM SACRAMENTO.
BUT AGAIN THERE ARE THIRTY SIX
ODD BILLS ON FILED STAGE WALDRON
CONSENT THE CONSENT ITEMS ON
FILE ON A.
CONSENT ITEMS ARE GOING.
IN ISRAEL.
OKAY OF THE CONSENT ITEMS ARE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY FOUR MISTER
MCCARTY. FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN MY
MR MEDINA.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY NINE BY MISTER
GARCIA FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
AB TWENTY TWO NINETY ONE BY
MISTER CHIU FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN EIGHTY TO TWENTY FOUR
FORTY NINE BY MISTER ARAMBULA
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE TO
MISTER GARCIA. FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN BY MR MCCARTY FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWO BY MISTER DALI. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR BONUS
REYES FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
TWO AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT BY MISTER CHAVEZ FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY THREE EIGHTY TWO
NINE SIX ZERO. BY MR THURMAN
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SIX.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY
MISTER THURMOND THOSE ARE BILLS
ARE CONSENT THAT WILL NOT BE
HEARD IT WILL BE VOTED ON IN
COMMITTEE TODAY WHEN WE DO HAVE.
A QUORUM.
WE DO NOT YET.
ALL THAT LEAVES TWENTY FOUR
BILLS TO BE HEARD WE WILL TAKE
TESTIMONY LISTEN TO THIS PLACE.
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ONLY.
TO EACH MEASURE UNLESS YOU WORK
IT OUT WITH THE WITH THE WITH
WITH WITH ME EARLIER THE CHAIR.
EACH WITNESS WILL WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
ALL OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSITION ARE WELCOME TO
COME UP TO THEM I CAN GIVE THEIR
NAME.
AFFILIATION OTHER AFFILIATED
WITH A GROUP AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY AND IS NOT A TIME FOR
FURTHER CONVERSATION OTHER THAN
STATE YOUR POSITION WE WANT TO
HEAR YOUR POSITION WE WELCOME
THAT. JUST IS NOT OF A TIME FOR
FOR THE DIATRIBE.
IN ORDER TO ACCOMMODATE THE
SCHEDULES OF WITNESSES WE HAVE
THREE WILL SET FOR A SPECIAL
ORDER BUSINESS AT ONE THIRTY WE
WILL TAKE THEM UP IN THE
FOLLOWING ORDER ACTUALLY SORT IS
GOING TO CHANGE. BUT FIRST WILL
BE AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE.
SECOND WILL BE A. B. TO STE
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE BY DOCTOR
WEBER. THAT OF A SECOND AND THE
THIRD OF LEAH MISTER KYLIE'S
BILL AND THEN WILL JUMP TO A. B.
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE FOURTH THOSE
BILLS ARE HEARD IN THE THE FIRST
BILLS THAT WE HEARD IN IN THE
ORDER. I JUST I SHARED A WITH
THAT AGAIN WE DON'T.
WE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM OKAY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
HERE O'DONNELL HERE.
I THINK KILEY HERE KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE THURMOND WEBER.
WEBER HERE.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM FORM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO WELCOME MISTER
STEINORTH I DID NOT SEE HIM
SITTING OVER THERE. AND WONDERED
WHAT HE WAS DOING HERE HE IS OUR
NEW CONTINUOUS COMMANDER HE'S
REALLY HAPPY TO BE ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE LOOK AT THAT
SMILE. HE LOVES WORK.
AND A WE APPRECIATE HIS
PRESENCE ON OUR COMMITTEE TODAY
SO THANK YOU MISTER STEINORTH
FOR BEING HERE. IN MISTER KILEY
MINUTES RUNS OVER YOU AS YOU ARE
THE VICE CHAIR I'M GOING TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE.
WHICH IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE I
BELIEVE.
IS IT.
THAT.
I DON'T.
YOU
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
ONE OH NINE WHICH WILL IMPROVE
THE EDUCATION OF SERIOUSLY ILL
STUDENTS.
WHO REQUIRE INSTRUCTION AT HOME?
OR IN THE HOSPITAL.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT STUDENTS
ATTENDING HOSPITAL SCHOOL
PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO RETURN TO
THEIR HOME SCHOOLS IN A TIMELY
MANNER. BY CLARIFYING THAT THE
STUDENTS HOME DISTRICT
DOES NOT NEED TO DO THIS AND
ROLL THE STUDENTS.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT A
STUDENT WHO IS ENROLLED IN A
HOSPITAL PROGRAM FOR FEWER THAN
FIVE DAYS PER WEEK IS ELIGIBLE.
TO ATTEND THEIR HOME SCHOOL ON
THE OTHER DAYS OF THE WEEK.
THIS BILL ALSO REQUIRE SCHOOLS
TO EXCUSE THE ABSENCES ABSENCES
FOR STUDENTS RECEIVING HOME OR
HOSPITAL INSTRUCTION SO THAT THE
FAMILY DOES NOT RECEIVE TRUANCY
NOTICES SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
THIS BILL FURTHER REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PROVIDE HOME
INSTRUCTION.
WITHIN FIVE WORKING DAYS OF A
DETERMINATION THAT THE
INSTRUCTION IS IN FACT REQUIRED.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES DISTRICTS
TOURED HONORARY DIPLOMAS TO
STUDENTS WHO ARE TERMINALLY.
ILL.
THESE ARE SMALL CHANGES TO
CURRENT LAW.
THAT WILL MAKE A LARGE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF
SERIOUSLY ILL CHILDREN.
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL ARE KATHY รณ A TEACHER AT
PACKARD'S CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL.
AND ANGELA RAMIREZ HOMES
APPARENT.
MISATO.
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS KATHY AND
I'M A TEACHER AT THE LUCILLE
PACKARD CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AT
STANFORD. AND EVEN THOUGH I AM
EMPLOYED BY PAUL TO UNIFIED I
HAVE WORKED WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FROM ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA SO I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TWENTY ONE OH
NINE IS FOR CHILDREN WHO ARE
FACING.
MEDICAL CHALLENGES.
UNTIL NOW HOSPITALS SCHOOLS
HAVE ALWAYS WORKED TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS
A OUT ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS TO
SIX A DETERMINE RULES AND SET
POLICY AND THIS DOESN'T ALWAYS
RESULT IN THE MOST ACADEMICALLY.
ADVANTAGEOUS SOLUTIONS FOR THE
STUDENT OR THE MOST
COMPASSIONATE POLICY FOR
FAMILIES.
SELECT IS HOW YOU ABOUT ONE OF
MY STUDENTS STATED YA KNOW WHO
CAME TO US AFTER HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH LEUKEMIA. HIS
JUNIOR YEAR.
HE WAS FROM A LOCAL SCHOOL BUT
IT WAS A DIFFERENT DISTRICT FROM
WHERE THE HOSPITAL WAS.
SO EVEN THOUGH.
YOU KNOW WHEN HE WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL HE WAS NOT BEING SERVED
BY HIS.
HOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
HE HAD SEVERAL MEDICAL SETBACKS
AND WAS BY REQUIRING FREQUENT
ADMISSIONS AND WHEN HE WAS IN
THE HOSPITAL.
HIS SCHOOL WAS NOT WILLING TO
PROVIDE THE WORK OR TO PUT MY
INDEPENDENT STUDY BECAUSE HE WAS
TECHNICALLY SLEEPING IN A
DIFFERENT CITY. SO EVENTUALLY HE
WAS DROPPED BY HIS HOME SCHOOL
AND WE PICKED HIM UP IMPALA
TELL.
AND EVEN WHEN HE WAS FEELING
BETTER AND WHEN HE WENT HOME HE
WAS NOT ALLOWED ON TO BACK TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE IT WAS A CLOSED
CAMPUS.
SO THIS IS A MOTIVATED AND
GREGARIOUS AND.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR HIM TO BE WITH HIS
FRIENDS.
SO I THINK WE AS EDUCATORS HAVE
AN OBLIGATION TO EDUCATE
CHILDREN BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY I
THINK WE NEED TO TEACH.
EMPATHY AND COMPASSION AND WE
NEED TO PRACTICE WHAT WE PREACH.
I THINK WE NEED TO FOSTER THAT
BELIEF THAT EDUCATION IS
IMPORTANT BUT THAT WE CARE ABOUT
EACH INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS.
.
SO I THINK EDIE TWENTY ONE OH
NINE IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE A
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
US STRUCTURE SO THAT THEY KNOW
WHAT STICKS BACKS WHEN ONE OF
THEIR STUDENTS FALLS ILL OR IS
INJURED.
WE NEED TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO PROTECT CHILDREN WHO ARE
IN A WHO ARE HOSPITALIZED AND WE
NEED TO BE THERE ADVOCATE
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS DON'T HAVE
THE TIME OR ENERGY TO BE
BATTLING SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
FOR THE BASIC EDUCATIONAL RIGHTS
THAT EVERY STUDENT DESERVES
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M THE PARENTS OF A CHILD
DIAGNOSED WITH A RARE LIFE
THREATENING BRING CONDITION SAYS
ANDREW.
I HOPE HE WAS DIAGNOSED FIVE
YEARS AGO AT AGE EIGHT IN SECOND
GRADE. WE STARTED THEN TO
NAVIGATE OUR WAY THROUGH TRYING
TO ADD TRYING TO. ACCESS
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHILE ALSO
PUTTING ALL OF OUR ENERGY INTO
BATTLING A.
LIFE THREATENING.
ILLNESS MY SON HAS RECEIVED
HOME HOSPITAL SERVICES TWO
DIFFERENT TIMES WE'VE DONE
INDEPENDENT STUDY WE'VE DONE
MODIFY DAY WE'VE DONE PRETTY
MUCH ALL OF THE THINGS OVER THIS
FIVE YEAR JOURNEY. I'M AS
WE HOPEFULLY WAIT FOR MY SON TO
BECOME AN ABM FREE.
THERE ARE MANY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
CAN MEAN MADE FOR SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WHO ARE BATTLING
SERIOUS ILLNESSES CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES ARE USING ALL OF THEIR
STRENGTH TO FIGHT THESE
ILLNESSES. AND SHOULDN'T BE
BURDENED WITH WHAT I SEE IS
BUREAUCRATIC FEELINGS OF A
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE'VE HAD A
MEANT SUPPORT FROM OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
.
AND PART OF THAT IS BECAUSE I
WAS A VOLUNTEER BUT WHAT I
WASN'T WHAT IF I COULDN'T CALL
AND GET A RESPONSE FROM THE
SUPERINTENDENT. THAT MATTERS IT
SHOULDN'T MATTER THAT I
VOLUNTEERED A LOT IN NEW THE
SUPERINTENDENT IN ORDER TO GET
SERVICES FOR MY CHILD NEED.
WE CAN DO BETTER ON A LOT OF
FRONTS.
I.
CAN'T BEGIN TO DESCRIBE THE
HEARTBREAK.
THE HEARTBREAK IT IS TO GET A
TRUANCY NOTICE FOR YOUR CHILD
WHEN YOU WANT NOTHING MORE FOR
THEM TO KEEP THE IN SCHOOL FULL
TIME. LIKE A REGULAR KID PARENTS
OF OF.
CHILDREN WITH SERIOUS ILLNESSES
OFTEN USE SCHOOL AS THE
BAROMETER TO GET BACK TO NORMAL
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE YOUR SCHOOL
YOUR CHILD SUPPOSED TO BE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
SCHOOL.
AND IT IS ONE OF.
THE MOST DIFFICULT THINGS
TO.
TRY TO DO BECAUSE THEY. IF YOU
HAVE A SERIOUSLY ILL CHILD THEY
DO NEED SPECIAL HELP AND AND
AND.
.
SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES BECAUSE
SOMETIMES ARE THE HOSPITAL'S
INTO CAN'T GO TO SCHOOL IF THERE
BE IN DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENTS.
AND.
WHEN I GET THE TRUANCY NOTICE
IT JUST BREAKS MY HEART I SHOULD
LAUGH BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST
COMICAL BECAUSE OF MY CREATE LET
ME GO BEFORE THE TURN SUPPORT
BUT. THAT'S ALL ROLLING ALL OUT
FOR THEM.
BUT I CRIED BECAUSE YOU WANT
NOTHING MORE THAN YOUR KID TO BE
IN SCHOOL AND THE LANGUAGE IN
THOSE NOTICES ARE SUCH THAT THEY
SAY.
WHO WE WOULD LIKE TO REMIND YOU
MISS HOMES HAS REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT YOUR CHILD ATTEND EVERYDAY?
YEAH I KNOW I WISH THAT WERE
POSSIBLE.
SO I FEEL LIKE.
THIS IS A REALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN HELPING TO MEET
SOME OF THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF
SERIOUSLY ILL CHILDREN.
IT IS MAKES A FEW MINOR CHANGES
THAT ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO
FAMILIES AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE OH NINE.
.
SERIOUSLY ALL STUDENTS SHOULD BE
ABLE TO ACCESS ALL OF THE
EDUCATION SERVICES THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO IN A TIMELY MANNER.
AND YOUR ACTIONS REALLY TODAY
WHILE SEEMINGLY INCONSEQUENTIAL
CAN TRULY MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
THE LIVES OF SERIOUSLY ILL
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
TESTIMONY OTHER OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
WAS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON AARON HENDERSON TOUGH
LIFE TEACHER UCSF BENIOFF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HERE MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY MCBRIDE WITH THE
ASSOCIATED. SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
EVELYN ABU HASSEN WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION AND I WILL BE
REALLY BRIEF. WE'VE JUST WANT
SOME CLARIFICATION ON WHAT WE
THINK IS REALLY ABOUT WATSON
CLARIFICATION BETWEEN THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE A CHILD HAS AN
IEP THAT ALSO. THN GETS A
TEMPORARY DISABILITY THAT'S NOT
PART OF THE IP SO THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN
WHAT SPECIAL EDUCATION LAWS
REQUIRE.
RELATIVE TO THOSE KIDS
TRIGGERING THE IP REQUIREMENT
AND AND SHAPE AND THEN IN THOSE
INSTANCES WHERE YOU HAVE A CHILD
WITH A TEMPORARY DISABILITY THAT
ACTUALLY TRIGGERS. THE CHILD
FIND REQUIREMENTS AND THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
IN THAT REGARD SO.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THOSE TWO.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS IS
ABOUT GARCIA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SEMI AND A HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL TO CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
LEAVE ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
KATARIA PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR DOT OBJECT BECAUSE. I JUST
LIKE TO I THINK MR MARIS HOME
FOR ADVOCATING FOR HER FAMILY.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY AND I TOOK A LOT OF
ENERGY.
AND ADVOCATING FOR ALL FAMILIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA MIGHT FIND
YOURSELF YOUR SITUATION TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMON WITH
THAT I JUST ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
I THINK YOU AYE MR DOT I THINK
THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL TO UP
PROVIDE SOME HELP TO KIDS AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN NEED AND
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT.
DEMOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS ABOUT OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL TYPE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE.
THURMOND WEBER. WEBER ON.
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU
MISTER
YOU'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO A BE
TWENTY.
SIX TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVEBY
DOCTOR WEBER TWENTY SIX THIRTY
FIVE THAT IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE.
BY THE NUMBER TWENTY THREE MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY OF THE CONSIDERATION
TO GO EARLY SINCE WE HAVE SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THAT PRESENT YOU A ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE THE
BILL THE TACKLES THE FLAW THAT
HAS BEEN DISCOVERED. IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
SINCE IT WAS INSTITUTED IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AN EFFORT TO
TARGET RESOURCES TO THE HIGHEST
NEED STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
AS THE COMMITTEE IS AWARE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMICA
SYSTEM BASED GRANT CONCENTRATION
GRANTS AND SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE WOULD
CREATE A NEW SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT
GOING FORWARD FOR THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUB GROUP. OF
STUDENTS OUTSIDE OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES WHICH IS
CURRENTLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN S.
EFFECTIVE SCORES CONFIRM A
DISTURBING.
BACK THAT HAS BEEN DOCUMENTED
FOR YEARS AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENTS IRRESPECTIVE OF INCOME
ARE PERFORMING BELOW THE STATE
AVERAGE IN BOTH ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH.
ONLY THIRTY ONE PERCENT MET THE
STATE ENGLISH ARTS STANDARDS AND
ONLY NINETEEN PERCENT MET THE
MATH STANDARDS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN THE STATE.
TWENTY SIXTY THOUSAND RECEIVING
A SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT BECAUSE
THEY ARE LOW INCOME.
YEAH WELL ELL OR HOMELESS OR
FOSTER YOU HOWEVER THERE IS A
SUBGROUP OF ABOUT NINETY
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO HAVE NOT
WHY WOULD NOT RECEIVING A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. AND NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF SUPPORT
NOT TO IMPROVE THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE THIS IS THE ONLY
GROUP OF STUDENTS PERFORMING
BELOW THE STATE AVERAGE THAT ARE
NOT ALREADY RECEIVING. A
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT. IN ADDITION
AFRICAN AMERICANS HAVE THE
LOWEST HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATE OF ANY STUDENT GROUP OF
SEVENTY TWO POINT NINE PERCENT
AND ALSO HAVE THE HIGHEST
SUSPENSION RATE OF NINE POINT
EIGHT PERCENT.
WE BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY THAT
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
BASICALLY ENHANCE INCORRECT THIS
ISSUE.
WITH THREE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN NEW PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING THIS YEAR NOW'S THE TIME
TO FIX THIS EDUCATIONAL
INEQUITY.
AND FULFILL THE PROMISE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO
TARGET RESOURCES TO STUDENTS
THAT ARE MOST IN NEED.
THAT'S WHAT OTHER LCF A FUNDS
DISTRICT IN CHARTER SCHOOLS WAS
STATE WHAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
AND SERVICES THEY WILL BE
OFFERING HIGH NEED STUDENTS IN
THE LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN. THIS WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ASSURANCE THAT THE
NEW FUNDING WILL BE TARGETED FOR
LOCALLY DETERMINED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO BEST ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE IS THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE CAUCUSES
PRIORITY BILL FOR THE YEAR. IT
IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY A BROAD
COALITION OF COMMUNITY EDUCATION
AND BUSINESS GROUPS INCLUDING
THE SACRAMENTO AND THE LOS
ANGELES URBAN LEAGUE. THE UNITED
NEGRO COLLEGE FUND BLACK
PARALLEL SCHOOL BOARD THE
NATIONAL COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK WOMEN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF A
BLACK SCHOOL EDUCATORS. CHILDREN
NOW IT TRUSTS WEST THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION IT
VOICE IN THE STATE IN THE PLACE
THE PEAK AND A HOST OF OTHERS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR
MARKET FORTUNE PRESIDENCIAL
FORTUNE SCHOOLS A NETWORK OF
SEVEN CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
SACRAMENTO AND SAN MEDINA. AND
FORMER EDUCATION ADVISER TO TO
CALIFORNIA GOVERNORS AS WELL AS
MISTER DENNIS MYERS WHO'S THE
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE GOVERNOR FAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
MARGARET FORTUNE ON THE CTO
FORTUNE SCHOOL AND I'M ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE BOARD THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION.
I AM JOINED HERE BY MY STUDENTS
WITH A FORTUNE SCHOOL SCHOLARS
PLEASE STAND.
THEY ARE NINTH GRADERS WHO ARE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ENROLLED IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FELL ON THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND THEIR
ASSOCIATES DEGREE AT THE SAME
TIME.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT AN
ISSUE THAT IS CRITICAL TO THAT
US AND THAT IS CLOSING THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT
GAP.
AS DOCTOR WEBER HAS STATED THIS
IS THE LOWEST PERFORMING
SUBGROUP OUTSIDE OF STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
THIS ISSUE IS SO IMPORTANT TO US
IN SACRAMENTO THAT THE
SACRAMENTO COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION APPROVED A NETWORK OF
TUITION FREE. PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS AS A PART OF A REGIONAL
INITIATIVE TO CLOSE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AS A RESULT.
WE'RE ONE OF TWELVE SCHOOLS.
OF THAT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE A MAJORITY
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENT
POPULATION THAT PERFORM IN THE
TOP HALF OF ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
IN THE STATE. I AM IN THE TOP
TEN PERCENT OF SIMILAR SCHOOLS
THERE ARE OTHER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
ON THE LIST THAT HAVE JOINED US
TODAY.
THIS IS HARD WORK AND IT TAKES
RESOURCES AND IT TAKES FOCUS.
BUT THE ISSUE OF THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS NOT
JUST ABOUT INCOME.
THERE'S SOMETHING MORE AT PLAY
HERE THERE ARE NINETY THOUSAND
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS WHO
BELOW WHO PERFORM BELOW AVERAGE.
WHO ARE NOT LOW INCOME AND YET
THEY STILL NEED OUR SUPPORT I'M
VERY PROUD TO BE SITTING HERE
NEXT TO? A A COLLEAGUE.
FROM AN ASSOCIATION THAT ARE MY
ASSOCIATION TYPICALLY SPARS WITH
AND THAT IS THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE PUTTING OUR DIFFERENCES
ASIDE TO SUPPORT AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS AND ALL
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUP TODAY IT'S%
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
TOMORROW COULD BE NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS IN THE NEXT
DAY COULD BE BETTINO STUDENTS.
THIS IS ABOUT EQUITY WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND AS A SACRAMENTAL
CLOSE BY SAYING WE ARE A
COMMUNITY THAT IS REALLY A HAS
BEEN SCARRED.
BY OF THE KILLING OF STEFAN
CLARK.
AND PLEASE SUMMARIZE FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OUR STUDENTS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO US THAT THEY
NOT JUST NOT BE TARGETED JUST BY
THE POLICE. WE WANT THEM TO BE
TARGETED.
MY SCHOOL FUNDING THANK YOU YOUR
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DENNIS MYERS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION ONE OF
THE STRENGTHS OF THE BIGGEST
TRANSIT LCF DEFICIT ALLOW SCHOOL
BOARDS WORKING WITH LOW
HUMIDITY.
TO LOOK AT DATA TO FIND OUT
WHERE THINGS NEED TO BE TARGETED
WHERE RESOURCES NEED TO BE.
SHIFTED BETWEEN TO HELP THINGS
THAT AREN'T WORKING MOVING OVER
TO FILL GAPS THINGS LIKE THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE THINK THIS
BILL DOES IT USES DATA.
THAT SHOWS THAT THERE IS A SUB
GROUP THAT I'M NOT THE ENTIRE
SUBGROUP IS QUALIFIED FOR THE
FOCUS THAT IS INTENDED UNDER LC
FF AND SO WE LOOK AT THE DATA.
SAY THERE'S A US POTENTIAL
SHORTCOMING OF LCF F. THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IT LOOKS AT THE.
WHOLE PORTION OF THE LOWEST
SUBGROUP AND SAYS NOT ALL OF
THAT SUBGROUP.
QUALIFIES FEELS FF FUNDING AND
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE SURE THAT
THE ENTIRE SUB GROUP DOES.
AND SO THAT FOR US IS WHY WE'RE
SUPPORTING IT BECAUSE IT DOES AT
THE STATE LEVEL WHAT OUR SCHOOL
BOARD YOU TRYING TO DO AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO REALLY ACHIEVE.
HIGH ACHIEVING LEVELS FOR ALSO
GROUPS AND TO CLOSE GAPS.
FASHION THAT WE'RE DOING NOW SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME TO THE MIKE FROM AND
STATE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND POSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE
WERE ORIGINAL SUPPORTERS OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
AND IN THE HEART GOAL AND
STRENGTH OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA WE BELIEVE AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FIVE ADDRESSES
THE NEEDS OF ALL USE AND WILL
NOT LEAVE YOU BEHIND.
PARTICULARLY THE LOWEST
PERFORMING STUDENTS OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS DR
DEBORAH EDUARDO AND OUR BOARD
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
WE URGE ITS PASSAGE THANK YOU.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
LEILANI I CAN OUT ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
FOR ANY SILVA BEHALF OF SCIENCE
TECH IN SUPPORT.
CAROLINE MULLINS ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL COALITION OF ONE
HUNDRED BLACK.
BLACK WOMEN THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I COULD SANDRA JENNINGS
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE AND ALSO
REPRESENTING THE SAME DIEGO OR
MENTALLY AND THE LOS ANGELES
URBAN LEAGUE ALL THE URBAN
LEASING WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE ARE
AND SUPPORT AT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
NO HIM READ ASSOCIATE EXECUTIVE
VICE CHANCELLOR AT UC DAVIS. ARE
HERE REPRESENTING THOUGH THE GUY
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE
AS A BOARD MEMBER TO SACRAMENTO
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AS A
BOARD MEMBER. AND THE URBAN
ADVOCATES ACHIEVERS AS A BOARD
MEMBER AND IN SUPPORT OF
CREATING EQUITABLE EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE LAST GUY FOR CALIFORNIA
POLICY SOLUTIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RAMONA WILDER WITH WILDER'S
PREPARATORY ACADEMY CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN INGLEWOOD AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
TUNISIA BARNETT OF NEW S.
CHARTER AND WE AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DOCTORS SHOULD NOT GRATTON
PARKER OF TODAY'S FRESH START
CHARTER SCHOOL FOR IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TO STOP THE REVOLVING
DOOR. OF OUR CHILDREN GO ON INTO
PRISON.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR MANNY A
SERVICE ON BEHALF OF KIP LA
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ERIC PREMATURE TO SCHOOLS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENDAN TOOLING ON BEHALF OF AND
VOICE IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARLOS CARTER OF
STE REPRESENTING THE UC SYSTEM
AS A ONE WHO OPERATIONALIZED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LCF AT.
AND ALSO THE NEWLY APPOINTED
VICE PRESIDENT THE SECOND NO
COUNTY AFTER AMERICAN COALITION
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SEAN MILLER BARACK OBAMA CHARTER
SCHOOL COME TEN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
DOCTOR KIANA LEERING LOS ANGELES
PROMISED CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
AFONSO PAUSE IN BEHALF OF APEX
ACADEMY IN MATRIX ACADEMY FOR
SUCCESS SUPPORTING OF THE BILL.
KEVIN FROM AROUND THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF BLACK
SCHOOL EDUCATORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I MET TAYLOR TRUSTEE YOLO COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DAVID CALVO.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
ACADEMIC A CALIFORNIA FULL
SUPPORT.
VERONICA TOLEDO UNITED PARENTS
AND STUDENTS WERE AN AFFILIATE
OF GREEN DOT PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
FULLY SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHANDRA DANIEL
REPRESENTING FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE FAMILIES AT MAGNOLIA SCIENCE
ACADEMY THREE IN CARSON. FULLY
SUPPORT.
ANALYTICAL AND REPRESENTING CITY
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND FOUNDING
PRINCIPLE OF CITY LANGUAGE
IMMERSION CHARTER LOS ANGELES
STRONG SUPPORT.
DOCTOR COLLETTE HARRIS MATTHEWS
DEAN OF COMMUNICATION VISUAL
PERFORMING ARTS SIX NUMBERS THE
RIVER COLLEGE HYMAN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A CITIZEN AND AN
EDUCATOR.
PATRICIA JACKSON REPRESENTING
AYE SELF PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN SOUTH
LOS ANGELES AND INGLEWOOD WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT A BEAST.
SIX THREE FIVE.
CARPING STEM FROM THE SACRAMENTO
BLACK PARA LAW SCHOOL BOARD WHO
STRONGLY SUPPORTED VIA.
KENDRA LUIS PARENT IN THE OAK
GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
ROSS MYERS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THEIR DISTRICT PTA. OF VICE
PRESIDENT OF FAMILY ENGAGEMENT.
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK?
BUT TO GET THE GOVERNMENT MOTHER
AND GRANDMOTHER OF BLACK
CHILDREN I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IN OPPOSITION.
THERE NOTICES IN OPPOSITION.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS MR
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU I I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL KRISTOL.
BILLS GOOD NEWS OKAY LIKE TO
MOVE. I LIKE TO MOVE IT AGAIN.
YEAH.
WELL I WOULD LIKE TO SECOND THE.
THE.
THE MOTION I GOT HERE LATE.
.
YES AYE I MEAN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. I'M A CO AUTHOR I DON'T
BELIEVE I'M LISTED BUT I AND THE
CO AUTHOR AND. WE SPOKE ABOUT
THIS ISSUE NOT THE BILL PER SE
YESTERDAY OUR BUDGET. COMMITTEE
AT SOMETHING THAT WE ARE.
CONSIDERING FOR.
IMPLEMENT FOR.
FOR INSERTION IN THE IN OUR
ANNUAL BUDGET ACT LATER THIS
THAT THIS YEAR. I I MISS THE.
THERE EARLIER TESTIMONY BUT
CERTAINLY HEARD THE PRESENTATION
YESTERDAY AND.
SOME OF THE WITNESSES I THINK
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT SON
MISSING IN THE LC FF ON FUNDING.
FORMULA.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THERE IS
THAT AN IMPORTANT CHO WORKS AT
STUDENTS THAT ARE SUCCEEDING IN
OUR CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS AND.
REALLY INSPIRED TO SEE OUR OUR
ADVOCATES FURTHER CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL
ADVOCATES ON THE SAME SIDE THIS
ISSUE.
I SAW SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE.
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND OTHERS AND SO I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
ALL GET BEHIND.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE
AND NOT ONLY AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP
AN OPPORTUNITY GAP BUT I THINK
THIS IS. A GLARING.
WEAKNESS AND OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WOULD LEAVE. A TO MAKE IS BEHIND
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT.
SUBGROUP THAT.
WE OUGHT TO BE.
DOING MORE WE'RE SEEING WHAT
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE DOING
WITH THEIR LCF FAST.
SUPPLEMENTAL.
CONCENTRATION ON AND THEIR ACT
AND HOW TO ADD ONS AND SOME
SCHOOLS ARE NOT IN THIS IS THAT
CERTAINLY IS AN ISSUE.
AND AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
INVEST IN OUR NEEDIEST ON.
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA THERE
IS ONE ISSUE THAT I WANTED TO
RACE ARE IN.
THERE IS ONE ISSUE THAT I WANTED
TO.
TO REYES AYE PRODUCT. IN
YESTERDAY'S HEARING TO SET A
NUANCED ISSUE.
THAT'S I I KNOW WHEN THE WHEN
THE EXAMPLES THAT YOU YOU MAKE
DOCTOR WEBER IS THAT.
IF FOR EXAMPLE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN.
.
SUBGROUP CHO WORKS.
YOU KNOW RISES ABOVE THE MEDIAN
AND THERE'S ANOTHER LET'S SAY
ETHNIC GROUP WHETHER IT'S.
LATINO I THINK THE EXAMPLE USES
NATIVE AMERICAN THAT THAT FALLS.
BELOW THE MEDIAN THAT NAY WOOD
AGAIN.
THE CREDIT.
THE THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THAT THAT
SUBGROUP.
THERE THERE ISN'T IT ANY ISSUE
WITH THE EP I POPULATION IN IN
CALIFORNIA I KNOW SCHOOLS AS IN
MY COUNSEL MY FORMER COUNCIL
DISTRICT AND WRITE. IN MY
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHERE. YOU
KNOW THE TRADITIONALLY IF YOU
LOOK AT THE API SCORES VERY
STRONG YOU LOOK AT THE SUBGROUPS
OF THAT SUBGROUP SO HE JUST
AGGREGATE. THE COMMUNITY FOR
EXAMPLE SOUTHEAST ASIAN AMONG
THE AND THE.
SOUTH LAOTIAN COMMUNITY.
THERE ARE SOME OF THE HIGH
CONCENTRATION SCHOOLS. ARE
AREN'T THE SAME AS ASIAN AS A
WHOLE SIGH I WANNA ASK A DOCTOR
WEBER. IF A AS POLICY GOES
FORWARD WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT ISSUE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THERE ARE.
THE GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MAKE SURE THAT ALL CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE NOTION THAT YOU'RE
PUTTING FOR HERE WHICH IS WE
SHOULD LEAVE ANY. A SUBGROUP
BEHIND WITH OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
FUNDING.
ALL YOUR ANSWER THAT OKAY Y.
NOT.
YOU IS KIND OF RHETORICAL BUT.
.
SURE THIS BILL TALKS ABOUT THE
LOWEST PERFORMING SUBGROUP.
IT DOESN'T TALK ABOUT AFRICAN
AMERICANS.
WHO HAPPENED TO BE THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SUBGROUP SHOULD GET
SUPPORT SHOULD BE INCLUDED IF
THEY DON'T FALL INTO THE
CATEGORIES? WHEN WE BEGAN LCF
AFTER MOST OF YOU WEREN'T HERE
AT THE TIME I WAS HERE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHEN WHEN THE GOVERNOR
WAS PUSHING THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORM IT. WE HEAR YOU
HAVE NO YOU ARE HERE OKAY I WAS
THE ONLY ONE HERE.
THAT WAS AT THAT TIME A PART OF
THE EFFORTS AND THE EFFORT WAS
TO REALLY CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. AND WE THOUGHT BY ADDING
CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF THAT WOULD
COVER EVERYONE.
IT PROBABLY WOULD HAVE IF WE
LEFT TO THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE
READS THE REGIONAL LANGUAGES NOT
BI LINGUAL A SECOND LANGUAGE
INSTRUCTION IT WAS ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY.
WHICH WOULD HAVE COVERED MORE
STUDENTS WHO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE
OF BECOME PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH
BUT THAT WAS TAKEN OUT AND SO AS
A RESULT WE ENDED UP WITH THESE
CATEGORIES.
WE HAVE DISCOVERED NOW THAT IF
WE LOOK AT THOSE THREE
CATEGORIES OF INCOME OF FOSTER
KIDS AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS THAT WOULD HAVE A GOOD
NUMBER SUB GROUP IT IS
PERSISTENTLY AT THE BOTTOM. AND
THAT DD THAT ARE NOT POOR THAT
ARE NOT ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND SO THEREFORE AND
NOT IN FOSTER CARE SO THEREFORE
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING ELSE
AT WORK HERE.
AND IT'S A PERSISTENTLY LOW
CATEGORY THAT IS THERE THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE WILL NEVER CLOSE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IF WE'D KNOW
WHAT'S ON THE BOTTOM. SO IN A
GROUP THAT BECOMES THE LOWEST
ACHIEVING GROUP THAT HAS THIS
GAP WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THAT
RIGHT NOW IT'S LOOKING AT
AFRICAN AMERICANS OUR GOAL WAS
NEVER TO BE ON THE BOTTOM ALWAYS
TO BE ON THE TOP. SO AS WE MOVE
UP THERE MAY BE OTHER GROUPS TO
COME INTO EXISTENCE.
SOME OF YOU PROBABLY WERE HERE
WHEN WE TRY TO DO SOME THINGS
WITH THE API COMMUNITY AND I WAS
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER BONTA FOR THE OPEN AREA.
WHEN HE WANTED TO DESEGREGATE
THE POPULATIONS IN IN IN THE API
COMMUNITY. AND.
AND I WAS VERY UNFAVORABLE
SPOKE IN FAVOR OF IT VOTED IN
FAVOR BECAUSE I'VE DONE THAT
WHEN I WAS ON THE SCHOOL BOARD
IN SAN DIEGO AND WE HAD LOTS OF
MEMBERS OF THE API COMMUNITY IN
LUMPING THEM ALL TOGETHER. JULIE
DOES NOT DO JUSTICE TO THOSE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING AND.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE NUMBERS
WOULD LOOK LIKE MATTHEW
DISAGGREGATED IT BUT IT MAY SHOW
THAT BUT THEY ARE STILL
CATEGORIES THAT ARE NOT LIKE THE
OTHER API. AND I THINK MOST OF
US VOTED FOR BOTH WHATEVER
HAPPENED VIA API THAT DIDN'T
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS
OF THIS OBVIOUSLY LCF F. SHOULD
BE A LIVING DOCUMENT THE
CONSTANTLY LOOK AT ITSELF
EVALUATES ITSELF AND THIS POINT.
THE LOWEST ACHIEVING GROUP THAT
WE HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF IN TERMS OF
OUR BREAK OUT IS AFRICAN
AMERICAN BUT IT COULD BE SOMEONE
ELSE AT THINK AS. AS THE
MISFORTUNE MENTIONED EARLIER IT
COULD BE ANOTHER GROUP IN
ANOTHER COUPLE YEARS AS WE
PROGRESS INTO THE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO. OUR
GOAL IS TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT.
AND THAT AND AND FACING THIS
ISSUE THAT'S HERE AND MAKING
THIS RECOMMENDATION FOR THIS
BILL IS THE FIRST STEP OF US
TRULY BEING.
EIGHT A STATE THAT LOOKS AND
TRIES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF ALL
CHILDREN AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T LEAVE ANYONE BEHIND.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
DOCTOR WEBER. I WAS DIRECTLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MATTER
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUSLY IMPORTANT A LOT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
I THINK CALIFORNIA WILL DO
JUSTICE ABOUT EVERY GROUP WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AND EVALUATE
AND ASSESS AND USE DATA TO
BASICALLY PROBABLE IT FORWARD WE
KNOW EDUCATION IS THE AMERICAN
EQUALIZER EQUALIZE THE WORLD FOR
MOST OF US IN THIS ROOM. AND SO
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OPPORTUNITIES AVAILABLE TO EVERY
CHILD IN CALIFORNIA SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER FOR
BEING A RELENTLESS IN FEARLESS
CHAMPION FOR EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE MANY OF OUR
STATE'S HIGHEST IMPACT EDUCATION
LEADERS I IN THIS ROOM TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND I THANK
YOU TO ALL THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
HERE AFTER BEING HERE TODAY FOR
STEPPING UP AND MAKING YOUR
VOICE HEARD.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSEDTO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY BY MCCARTY ICE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH OR AYE AYE A THURMOND.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH
.
NO THESE
I DO
.
MANAGED CARE.
BUT YOU'RE FROM OVER HERE NEXT
MIXING UP LIKE A LED BY US.
OKAY WE'LL RECONVENE MISTER
KILEY PLEASE I PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING.
THE CHAIR WILL NOT YOU THE
OTHER CHAIR.
.
AND YOU.
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
HELPFUL INSIGHT.
AND COLLABORATIONS ON THIS BILL
AND I AM ACCEPTING OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AT THE
LEGISLATURE UPDATED THE PROCESS
FOR DISMISSAL OF THE PERMANENT
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB TWO FIFTEEN.
THAT BILL AMONG OTHER THINGS
CREATED AN EXPEDITED PROCESS FOR
REMOVAL OF SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
WHO'VE COMMITTED EGREGIOUS
MISCONDUCT AND ADDED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH REGARD TO DISCLOSING
REPORTING EGREGIOUS MISCONDUCT
AND MAINTAINING EVIDENCE IN
EMPLOYEES FILE.
AB TO FIFTEEN PROVIDED THE
FRAMEWORK NEEDED TO PROTECT
STUDENTS FROM SERIOUS FORMS OF
MISCONDUCT BY GIVING LOCAL
SCHOOL OFFICIALS A MECHANISM TO
ASSURE AN OFFENDING EMPLOYEES
PROMPT REMOVAL FROM THE
CLASSROOM.
SINCE THE PASSAGE OF AB TWO
FIFTEEN HOWEVER SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN GOVERNING
BOARDS HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN
THAT THE LAW DOES NOT ALLOW THEM
TO ADEQUATELY ADDRESS MISCONDUCT
INVOLVING SEXUAL HARASSMENT. AND
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR WITH
STUDENTS.
AS A RESULT THERE'S SOME SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES WERE STAYING IN THE
CLASSROOM EVEN AFTER NUMEROUS
ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
TODAY'S BILL ADDRESSES THIS
ISSUE AND FURTHERS THE PURPOSE
OF AB TWO FIFTEEN. INTO S..
FIRST
IT MODEL IT IT THAT IT MODIFIES
THE DEFINITION OF AGREE JUST
MISCONDUCT IN EDUCATION CODE
SECTION FOUR FOUR NINE THREE
TWO.
TO INCLUDE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THIS ALLOWS THE EXPEDITED
DISMISSAL PROCESS CREATED BY AB
TWO FIFTEEN.
TRIGGERED IN CASES WHERE
EMPLOYEES ACCUSED OF SEXUALLY
HARASSING
STUDENT.
SECOND FOR AN EMPLOYEE CHARGED
WITH MISCONDUCT THE BILL ALLOWS
LOCAL SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO
CONSIDER THEIR HISTORY OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR OTHER
INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR. WITH THE
SUIT STUDENT.
EXISTING LAW ONLY ALLOWS
EVIDENCE AND TESTIMONY THAT
DATES BACK FOR YEARS EXCEPT IN
THE MOST SERIOUS INSTANCES OF
ALLEGED SEXUAL ASSAULT OR CHILD
ABUSE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO ALLOW
EVIDENCE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT OR
OTHER INAPPROPRIATE BEHAVIOR
EVEN IS OLD IS ORDER AYE THAN
FOR YEARS IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH
A PATTERN. OF MISCONDUCT.
TODAY'S BILL IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN MEETING TO PRESSING
SOCIAL CHALLENGES.
MAKING OUR SCHOOLS SAFER AND
ROOTING OUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY EIGHT MAKES
COMMON SENSE CHANGES TO
STRENGTHEN THE EXISTING JUST
MITCHELL STATUTE AND BETTER
PROTECT KIDS FROM PREDATORY
BEHAVIORS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY IS JULIE
HARADA TRUSTEE ON THE ROADS BILL
JOINT UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND STEVE
WILLIAMS THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OPERAS WILL JOIN
UNITED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MY NAME
IS JULIE HAVE RHODA AND I'M IN A
UNIQUE ROLE AS A SCHOOL TRUSTEE
AND A MOTHER OF TWO SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN.
I'VE LEARN MORE ABOUT TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS AND I CAN IMAGINE
IN THIS ROLE.
AND I'VE BEEN DISAPPOINTED TO
LEARN THE LIMITS THAT I HAVE
WHEN IT COMES TO TEACHER
MISCONDUCT.
TODAY WE NEED YOUR HELP
ADDRESSING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
THE CLASSROOM THESE DAYS PARENTS
LIKE ME. ASSUME THAT THE SAFEST
PLACE FOR THEIR CHILDREN WHEN AT
SCHOOL IS WITH THEIR TEACHER.
THIS IS USUALLY TRUE BUT AS THE
TRUSTEE I'VE LEARNED THAT IN
SOME INSTANCES IT IS NOT.
IT'S UNSAFE WHEN A TEACHER AND
ADULTS.
SEXUALLY HARASSES STUDENTS ARE
CHILDREN.
THE HARASSMENT IMPAIRS THE
RELATIONSHIP DISRUPTS THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS
AND TEACHERS ARE KIDS THAT IT'S
OKAY TO BE THREATENED.
THIS IS A LESSON THAT WILL BE
IMPRINTED ON THEM FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT CAN BE VERY
SUBTLE.
SO MUCH THE KIDS MIGHT QUESTION
THE REALITY AND THEIR ROLE IN
IT.
IN FACT IN RECENT HEADLINES
WE'VE SEEN THAT MANY ADULTS HAVE
HAD DIFFICULTY REPORTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN COMING FORWARD.
AND WHEN A STUDENT FEELS
UNCOMFORTABLE THEY DON'T ALWAYS
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY AS
ADULTS TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO PROTECT STUDENTS AND
CHILDREN.
I'M ASKING YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TO INCLUDE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE AGREE JUST MISCONDUCT
AND TO REMOVE THE FOR YOUR
HISTORICAL LIMITATION OF
PRESENTATION OF EVIDENCE.
THE PROPOSED CHANGE PUTS OUR
KIDS FIRST AND IMPROVES THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS AT
SCHOOL.
AS A MOTHER OF TWO CHILDREN ALL
THEN KNOW THAT SCHOOLS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO ASSURE
THEIR SAFETY.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST THAT
WE CAN CONFIDENTLY SAY SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN OUR SCHOOLS WILL
NOT BE TOLERATED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STEVE
WILLIAMS I'M THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF PERSONNEL FROM
THE ROSEVILLE HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I'M ALSO A FATHER OF FIVE
CHILDREN AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN.
SO THIS ISSUE IS VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME.
AS IT IS WITH MANY IN THE ROOM
TODAY.
WE'RE HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR HELP
AND FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
TO BETTER HOLD EMPLOYEES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR SEXUALLY
HARASSING STUDENTS
AND OTHER EMPLOYEES.
WE'RE ASKING YOU TO GRANT SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THE ABILITY TO
INCLUDE ALL INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
BUT AN EMPLOYEE FOUND HAVE
MERIT.
NO MATTER HOW LONG IT OCCURRED
AS EVIDENCE IN EMPLOYEE
DISCIPLINE MATTERS.
WE FEEL FRUSTRATED. IN OUR HANDS
FEEL TIED BECAUSE WE CAN ONLY
NOW GO BACK FOUR YEARS WHEN
DETERMINING DISCIPLINE. FOR
EMPLOYEE WHO HAS DEMONSTRATED A
PATTERN OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
MISCONDUCT IN THIS BEHAVIOR.
FOR EXAMPLE IF AN EMPLOYEE
SEXUALLY HARASSES STAFFERS
STUDENTS
BUT THEN DOESN'T ENGAGE IN SUCH
BEHAVIOR FOR FOUR PLUS YEARS. WE
ARE NOW UNABLE TO USE THE
INITIAL ACTS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT. AS EVIDENCE IN A
DISCIPLINARY HEARING.
ADDITIONALLY.
WHEN FACED WITH SUCH
CIRCUMSTANCES WE HAVE REPEATEDLY
BEEN REMINDED TYPICALLY BY THE
EMPLOYEES LEGAL REPRESENTATIVE.
THAT WE ARE UNABLE TO INCLUDE
INCIDENTS BEYOND. THE FOUR YEAR
MARK AS PART OF THE RECORD.
THAT IS A VERY HARD PILL FOR US
TO SWALLOW.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE MEAT TO
MOVEMENT.
AND ARE ASKING YOU TO HELP US
SEND A VERY LOUD.
CLEAR AND FIRM MESSAGE THAT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN OUR SCHOOLS
WILL NOT BE TOLERATED.
AND IN PARTICULAR REPEAT
OFFENDERS.
WHO CANNOT REFRAIN FROM SUCH
BEHAVIOR WILL BE APPROPRIATELY
DISCIPLINE?
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS REQUEST
AND GIVE SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
THE ABILITY TO INCLUDE. ALL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INCIDENTS OF
AN EMPLOYEE REGARDLESS OF THE
TIMELINE AND NOT LIMIT THEM TO
ONLY THE FOR MOST RECENT YEARS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY
ANY OTHER IS IN SUPPORT PLEASE
SAY YOUR NAME AFFILIATION
IMPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
DEREK LACKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN THE SCHOOL
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
FLOOR PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
THE MIND OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WELL. WE'RE LOOKING FOR A DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO DITCH IT.
TO BE REFERRED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
MOTION BY SOMEONE WEBER SECOND
BY MISTER STEINORTH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
CARTY.
I MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN WEBER AYE
WEBER AYE.
FOR.
FOUR VOTES THE BILL IS OUT.
SHIP BUILT.
OKAY
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M RE-ATTEMPT.
I WANT TO. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
I ACCEPT ALL OF THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
I DON'T KNOW FOR THEIR HERE OR
AT.
PREGNANCY AND PARENTING
CONTRIBUTE SIGNIFICANTLY TO HIGH
SCHOOL DROPOUT RATES AMONG TEEN
GIRLS.
THIS RATE IS EVEN HIGHER FOR
TEENS OF COLOR AT NEARLY FORTY
PERCENT.
PREGNANT AND PARENTING STUDENTS
CONTINUE TO FACE OVERWHELMING
SYSTEM ENFORCE OBSTACLES TO
GRADUATING AND RECEIVING AN
EDUCATION OF EQUITY EQUAL
QUALITY TO THAT OF THEIR PEERS.
OBSTACLES DIFFER FROM ACROSS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OBSTACLES LIKE VARYING LEVELS OF
SUPPORT AND ENGAGEMENT FROM THE
SCHOOLS WHILE ABSENT.
pALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS THAT MADE
UP
OF FILL THE EIGHTH G.
REQUIREMENTS NEEDED FOR COLLEGE
ENTRANCE.
SOMETIMES A LACK OF AWARENESS OF
PARENTING STUDENTS RIGHTS UNDER
TITLE NINE IN CALIFORNIA LAW.
AND INCONSISTENT ACCESS TO
EXCUSE FAMILY LEAVE ABSENCES
WITH MALE WITH A MALE PARENTS
OFTEN HAVE NO ACCESS TO BONDING
TIME.
THE PURPOSE OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY NINE WOULD CREATE A
CONSISTENT POLICY ACROSS THE
STATE TO PROVIDE A MINIMUM OF
SIX WEEKS A PROTECTED. LEAVE FOR
BIRDS WITHOUT COMPLICATIONS OR
EIGHT WEEKS WHO BIRTH WITH
COMPLICATIONS AND TO PROVIDE FOR
WEEKS FOR THE PANTS NOT GIVING
BIRTH TO CRAFT TO CARE FOR AND
BOND WITH THEIR INFANTS.
THIS BILL IS ALSO ESTABLISH IS A
MINIMUM OF FOUR DAYS OF EXCUSE
ABSENCES NOT REQUIRING NOT
REQUIRING A DOCTOR'S NOTE THIS
RELATED TO THIS.
THE BILL IS SPONSORED BY ACTUAL
WOMEN GIRLS BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS CALIFORNIA LATINOS FOR
ROUTE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE AND
ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH JUSTICE
AND SUPPORT OF OVER THIRTY
ADVOCACY GROUPS.
UP I'M NOT SURE IF WINDY CAL MAG
HERE.
AND JULIA BROWN.
THEY'RE HERE TODAY.
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU TWO WITNESSES BLAZE
TWO MINUTES APIECE.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING ACT FOR
WOMEN GIRLS MANY MISTER
HUTCHINSON AND OUR.
JULIA BROWN IS ACTUALLY
SUPPOSED TO BE WALKING THROUGH
THE DOOR ANY MINUTE BECAUSE HERE
SHE GOES I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY. SOBRE PUSHED OF THAT
SOMEONE GOT LOCKED OUTSIDE.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS JULIA
BROWN AND. HELLO EVERYONE MY
NAME IS JULIA BROWN I'M
SEVENTEEN YEARS OLD AND I'M A
SENIOR AT BY SELENA. CHARTER
INDEPENDENT STUDIES WHICH IS AN
INDEPENDENT STUDIES PROGRAM OF I
SAW UNIFIED. TIME HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE FOR AYE FOR WOMEN
AND GIRLS.
I AM A YOUNG PARA MY SON JORDAN
IS ABOUT SIX WEEKS OLD BEFORE
ATTENDED VC I S. I WANT TO SO
KOREA HIGH SCHOOL OF AYE SO
USED.
UNIFIED MY TEACHERS AND ADMIT AT
SOME POINT I KNEW I WAS
PREGNANT.
AND I WAS AROUND EIGHT MONTHS
PREGNANT I BEGAN HAVE YOU START
PAINS OF MY UTERUS WHILE AT
SCHOOL.
AS THE PAIN GOT WORSE I FINALLY
WENT TO THE OFFICE TO TELL THE
MINISTRATION WHAT I WAS FEELING.
I'M.
IT WAS SO INTENSE THAT THE
PRINCIPAL DECIDED TO CALL THE
AMBULANCE.
ONCE I WAS AT THE HOSPITAL I
FOUND OUT I WAS EXPERIENCING
EARLY CONTRACTIONS MY DOCTOR
OFFICIALLY PUT ME ON BED REST
AND WROTE A NOTE FOR MY. SCHOOL
TO AND THAT I NEEDED TO BE
EXCUSE FOR MATERNITY LEAVE US
APART I WOULDN'T ACCEPT IT.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE HIGH AT
MY HIGH SCHOOL.
TOLD ME WE DON'T DO MATERNITY
LEAVE SO I HAD TO COME TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY TO MY WATER BROKE.
MY MOTHER WAS VERY LIVID SO SHE
CALLED VESSEL UNIFIED IN THE
ADVICE SUPPORT HIGH THAT I
NEEDED TO BE. PUT ON THE BUS SO
QUIET STILL RESISTED. THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT EVENTUALLY CURSE ME TO
ENROLL AT THE CI US FOR
INDEPENDENT STUDIES.
WHEN I DID FINALLY GIVE WORTH BY
SO YOU.
FEW CIS ONLY GAVE ME ONE WEEK A
MATERNITY LEAVE AND. EXPECTED ME
TO BE REPORTED BACK TO SCHOOL
THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
AND ROLLING OUT VC IDEAS WHEN I
NEED TO BE OFF ADDRESS FOUGHT
LIKE THE EASIEST DECISION FOR
ME.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S ARGUE WAS SO
QUIET ABOUT LETTING ME. TAKE
MATERNITY LEAVE BUT I WANT TO GO
BACK TO REGULAR HIGH SCHOOL
BECAUSE MY PEERS ARE THEN I DO
BETTER. IN A REGULAR CLASSROOM
STRUCTURE I'M TRYING TO MAKE
AFTER INTO GOING BUT.
A LOT OF YOUNG MOTHERS WHO HAVE.
ME AND I DON'T WANT THAT TO HAVE
TO HAPPEN TO ANYONE ELSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
HE MEMBERS MY NAME IS WENDY
COOLEY MIND AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR OASIS FOR
GIRLS AND SAN FRANCISCO. NEVER
WORKED FOR OVER THIRTEEN YEARS
OF PREGNANCY PREVENTION AND
INITIATIVES. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO EIGHT
BECAUSE IS A TANGIBLE WAY THAT
WE CAN SUPPORT YOUNG PARENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. LEVELS
POLICIES OFF ACROSS THE STATE
AND ENSURES THAT CREDITING
STUDENTS HAVE THE TIME TO BE
ABLE TO BOND WITH THEIR CHILDREN
AND GO TO SCHOOL. SO STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT PREGNANCY CAN
MOTIVATE YOUNG PARENTS TO DO
WELL IN SCHOOL BUT YET DEPENDING
ON WHERE THEY LIVE IN CALIFORNIA
THERE EITHER PUSHED OUT. TO
INDEPENDENT STUDY THAT DOES NOT
MEET COLLEGE REQUIREMENTS OR
THEY DROPPED OUT ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF TIME TO.
BE PRETTY PREPARE THEMSELVES FOR
THE NEW RESPONSIBILITY IS A
PARENTING IN SCHOOL. SO WE ARE
ESTIMATING IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
THERE ARE CLOSE TO TEN THOUSAND
PET PREGNANT APPARENTLY STUDENTS
THAT DROPPED OUT IN CALIFORNIA.
INTERFERENCE TURNING STUDENTS
DON'T RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THAT
ANY PARENT WOULD REGARDLESS OF
AGE THEY'LL HAVE AN ECONOMIC
UPHILL BATTLE.
WITH THEY WILL EARN ELEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS A YEAR
THAN THEIR STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND TWENTY
THOUSAND LAST YEAR THAN THOSE
WHO HAVE SOME COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE.
AND THIS WILL ACTUALLY IMPACT
THEIR IMMUNE NOT ONLY PACKED
THEIR IMMEDIATE NEEDS BUT IT
WILL IMPACT THE NEEDS OF THEIR
YOUNG CHILDREN.
CHILDREN WHO HAVE.
CHILDREN WHO HAVE EARLY BONDING
TIME WITH THEIR PARENTS EXHIBIT
BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES LIKE
BETTER PROBLEM SOLVING COPING IN
DECISION MAKING SKILLS AND THESE
ARE THE FUTURE OF STUDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WITH MY YEARS OF WORKING TO
SUPPORT YOUNG WOMEN I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH THE
CAL STATE PROGRAM. IN THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THE YOUNG PARENTS
HAD VITAL RESOURCES THEY NEED
IT'S A BOND AND CARE FOR SICK
CHILDREN THEY COMPLETED HIGH
SCHOOL OR RETURNED TO THEIR
ORIGINAL SCHOOL REGULAR SCHOOL.
SO THIS PROGRAM SIDE GRADUATION
RATES HIGHER THAN THAT OF SOME
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS.
AND UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
THEY'VE WAS DO FUNDED WITH THE
CREATION OF THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING CAP A LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
AND THE NUMBER COUNTY SIDES
DECREASED FROM HUNDRED THIRTY
SEVEN SO ONLY FIFTY TWO.
SO ONE OF THE THIS IS ONE OF THE
FEW.
THIS IS ONE OF THE FEW PROGRAMS
THAT THEY THAT.
.
AND NOW WE HAVE TO PIECE MEAL
THESE PROGRAMS SO WE ARE URGING
YOU TO SUPPORT AB TWO TWO EIGHT
NINE.
SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PARENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
YEAH WITNESSES SUPPORTING
PERTAINING.
THE LEASH AND FOR
SURE THIS IS HOPE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANDREA BALL
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION THANK
DOCTOR WEBER FOR LEADERSHIP.
ENSURING STATEWIDE POLICIES
THANK YOU.
HI MY SON FRANCO CALIFORNIA AT
THE US REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
WHERE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL. AND ARE IN A VERY STRONG
SUPPORT THINK
TO.
RACHEL CHO ACCESS WOMEN'S HEALTH
JUSTICE PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
INSTRUCT SUPPORT.
HE WON REPRESENTING AMERICAN
KENNY PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION AS WELL AS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL NURSES WHO ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA KAISER ON BEHALF
OF COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS AT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
KRISTIN POWER WITH THE ONES FOR
CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN SUPPORT FOR
PREGNANT PARENTING TEENS.
DIANA MAC DONALD PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO EIGHT
NINE. I'M ALSO FROM CINEMA
COUNTY THANK YOU SO MUCH WE ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
LEAH DEREK DIRECTOR OF
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA CPT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR SECOND
DISTRICT PTA SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN CHULA VISTA AND SAN
DIEGO PETA'S IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY PAN GO PRESIDENT OF THE
NINETEEN ST PTA SERVING SAN
DIEGO. AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THE NEED ADEQUATE DONDE BEACH
PTA WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MORGAN DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION FOR THEIR THIRD
DISTRICT PTA IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HAVE TO THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT.
CATHY RAYBURN FROM THIRTY SECOND
DISTRICT PTA WHICH IS CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CATHY SHARE FOR THE ACLU
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ROSA MARRIED I KNOW FROM ACT
FROM THE GIRLS AND I SUPPORT.
AARON CARTER FORD WITH ACTUAL
WOMEN AND GIRLS WHO WERE A PROUD
CO SPONSOR.
WHAT IT ARE LOPEZ AND HERE WITH
ACT WOMAN ENGROSSED IN STRONG
SUPPORT?
YOUR BASS A FLAT BLACK LOOK
ALANIS CO SPONSOR AND COURSE
THE DOG SUPPORT.
ADDRESS AND MAIL PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR.
DISBARRED LA WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
HI GOVERNOR TOMORROW HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF UPS
WAS A GYNECOLOGIST ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NOT ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING OPPOSITION ANY COME UP IN
THE COMMITTEE SINGLE COME UP
FROM THE COMMITTEE WE ARE ALL
MOVED WE HAVE SECOND.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
AB TWENTY TO EIGHTY NINE THE
YOUNG PARENTS RIGHTS TO
EDUCATION ACT PROTECTS STUDENTS
WERE BEING PUSHED OUT OF SCHOOL
BECAUSE OF THE PARENTAL STATUS.
ALL YOUNG PEOPLE IN PARENTS THE
TEAM SHOULD BE ABLE TO PRESENT
TO TO PARENT THEIR CHILD WITHOUT
SACRIFICING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS REGARDLESS OF THE SCHOOL
THEY ATTEND. OF THIS BOOK BILL
WILL ENSURE BOTH OF THOSE W
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN EYE
BOLTS AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY NINE.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THAT THE MOTION IS.
.
SUPPORT AS AMENDED.
TO APPROACH.
O'DONNELL.
I AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE KALRA MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMOND WEBER AYE AYE.
WEBER AYE.
THE BILL AS OUT THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I ONLY SEE MISTER.
CHIU HERE.
SO MISTER CHIU YOU MAY. COME
FORWARD AND PRESENT VIOLENT OR
TWO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT SEVENTEEN NINETY.
FILE NUMBER TWO.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ALL WORK
SORROW WOULD SAYATV SEVENTEEN
NINETY EIGHT THAT OKAY.
THE BUS SAFETY BILL ARE YOU WANT
ME TO START OF BLOOM D..
.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
DIAMOND AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO.
DON'T KNOW SOME OF THE NIGHT YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR SOME MEMBERS AB SEVEN
SEVENTEEN NINETY EIGHT SET A
DATE BY WHICH ALL SCHOOL BUSES.
IN COLLEGE WHEN YOU'RE
TRANSPORTING STUDENTS MUST HAVE
SEE BILL.
CURRENTLY NEARLY HALF OF ALL
SCHOOL BUSES SING CALIFORNIA DO
NOT HAVE SI BILL THIS BILL CAME
TO CLOSE THAT GAP. BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE.
WILLOW DESI BILL SAVE LIVES
WHILE COLORFUL NEON HAS.
OF FORESIGHT TO REQUIRED THAT
ALL SCHOOL BUSES MANUFACTURED
AFTER TWO THOUSAND FIVE HAVE
SEATBELT.
BUT AS WE SPEAK CAN TODAY LAST A
HOW FAULT DIVORCES AND HOW TO
SEE BILL. AND PUTTING STUDENT AT
POTENTIAL OF RISK.
WHEN WHEN WINTERSON ACCIDENT
JUST JUST RECENTLY LAST MONTH'S.
THERE WAS A SCHOOL BUS
COALITION IN ALSO GRANTED.
CITY YOUNG CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WHERE TWELFTH THE STUDENTS OR
YOUNG YOUNGSTERS WAS SENT TO THE
HOSPITAL WITH INJURIES. THE
DISCO ENJOYING US SUPPORT FROM.
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF THE PIECE
IT PEDIATRICS AND MANY OTHER OF
THE BOOK.
THOSE EARLY ORGANIZATION
INCLUDING THE CMA AND HAVE NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I WILL THANK YOU ANY
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE GIVENS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
MANY OF WATER REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION IN SUPPORT.
A ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
SAYING OPPOSITION. I DO WE HAVE
A MOTION. SUMMER MOVED I GUESS
YOU SECOND THEN THE OTHER HAND
MEANS NAY DOES OR A SECOND OKAY
DOCTOR WEBER YOU SECOND LOCATED
IN SECOND MOVEMENT SECOND TAKE A
BEHIND THE RAIL HERE. GO AHEAD
MR PARA I THINK YOU MISTER JUDE
IS HERE ANYONE THAT HERE IS A
WITNESS WHOSE.
AN EXPERT IN SCHOOL BUS SAFETY.
OR WOULD HAVE SOME INSIGHT INTO.
WHAT THAT THE SAFETY
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS MIGHT BE?
GOOD DARREN DARREN DEFINITELY I
THINK POSTED NATIONAL HIGHWAY
TRAFFIC SAFETY ADMINISTRATION.
AND H. T. ESSAY AND THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY.
ALFA PITCHER OUT SICK AGREED
THAT THE SEATBELT.
IN THE SCHOOL BUSES SAFE FLIGHT.
I'M LOOKING AT THE ITEMS
STUDY FROM NH TSA AND THAT THE
EVIDENCE SEEMS PRETTY MIXED DUH
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN PRETTY HARD
TO PROVE THAT THERE ACTUALLY ARE
INCREASED.
SAFETY BENEFITS FROM HAVING AS
YEAH SEAT BELTS IN SCHOOL BUSES
AND THERE'S EVEN SOME SUGGESTION
THAT.
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH DOING
SO MIGHT FOR SOME DISTRICTS TO
SCALE BACK THEIR SCHOOL BUS
TRANSPORTATION UP FORCING
STUDENTS INTO ALTERNATIVE.
MODES OF TRANSPORT THAT ARE.
LESS SAFE WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S A SEATBELT INVOLVED.
.
YOU KNOW ON THE OTHER HAND I
THINK MAYBE I WANT TO GET
STUDENTS THE HABIT OF WEARING
SEATBELTS EVEN IF IT'S NOT A.
A SAFETY BOOST IN THE SCHOOL
BUS ITSELF OUR BAND IS KIND OF
SPECULATE AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT IT ACTUALLY HAS THAT EFFECT
SO.
I'D YEAH I'M I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED THAT WERE CUT A MOVING
FLOOR WITH SOME AND IT SOUNDS
INTUITIVELY SENSIBLE YEAH SCHOOL
BUSES SHOULD HAVE SEAT BELTS BUT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE. AYE
THE DEBT DATA BEHIND IT WE MIGHT
LIKE FOR POLICY MAKING ON THIS
LEVEL RIGHT.
THAT'S WHY ARE YOU.
WILL GIVE HIM A CO TWENTY
THIRTY TWO CULPRIT MAKE SURE
THAT ALL. OF SCHOOL BUSES SASSY
BUILT.
YOU KNOW I ACTUALLY MISTER
JENNINGS I'M AN EXPERT ON SCHOOL
BUS SAFETY.
I HAVE A TO RECORDS AND OTHER ON
A SCHOOL BUS I WANT TO HAVE
SAFETY BELTS.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
I.
USE YOU SEE BILL. ONE WHO HAVE
SERVICE AVAILABLE.
ON A SCHOOL BUS ORDER A
PASSENGER VEHICLE WONDERS OF.
SIBEL AVAILABLE OUR USE OF.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS SING A FOR
THE COMEDY MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT CREE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND OTHER MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
MCCARTY GUY MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I THURMOND WEBER.
WEBER I.
FOR. THOSE OUT AS FOR VOTES
ACADIA GOING TO MOVE ON YOUR
SECOND HOMES RICHARD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOUR AB TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JUST FILE ITEM JUST FOR THE
COMMITTEES PURPOSE IT'S FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX.
GIVE THEM TIME TO FLIP OVER TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN YOU MAY
PROCEED NOW. QUICKER VERY MUCH
SO PARTS OF MY PURSE ALL BARMAN
THING THE D..
TO COMMITTEE THE STAFF AND
THEIR CHAIR WHO IS WORKING WITH
US. OF PHOTOS FILE ON ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
STATE THAT I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE OF AMENDMENTS MOVING
FOR. A. B. TWENTY TWENTY TWO
REQUIRED ONE OR MORE MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ALL ALL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND SECONDARY
SCHOOL.
AND ESTABLISH A RATIO OF ONE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. FOR
EVERY SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THIS BILL AND TO IMPROVE TO
MENTAL HEALTH* FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
BETWEEN EACH FOUR AND ELEVEN
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND RESEARCH TELL US EARLIER
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
SERVICES ARE CRITICAL.
HOWEVER OVER SEVENTY PERCENT OF
THOSE CHILDREN NEVER NEVER
RECEIVED ANY TREATMENT.
EMPLOYEES FOR USING THEIR
PROPERTY OR WAS NINE ENGLISH
SPEAKING PARENTS JUST NUMBER
JUMPED TO OVER EIGHTY PERCENT.
THAT MEANS ONLY ONE FITS OF
THOSE CHILDREN RECEIVING HEALTH
DATE WE NEED.
SCHOOL HAVE BEING.
IDENTIFY ESTA BASS SETTING TO
PROVIDE SERVICES.
ESPECIALLY MY A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
AND BE ABLE TO REACHING STUDENT
OF COLOR AND ON UNDERSERVED TO
COMMUNITIES.
THE TEACHER OF WHO ARE OFTEN THE
FIRST CONTACT FOR THE STUDENTS.
FEEL ILL EQUIPED TO COMMUNICATE
WAS STUNNED ABOUT THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
WE NEED TO DO BETTER FOR OUR
CHILDREN.
THE IDEA CAME DIRECTLY FROM THE
USE THE USE ADVOCATE OF FULL
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT ON ON VERA
CAMPUSES
SO WITH ME TODAY. OF THEM
LOOKING FOR THE USE HERE WE HAVE
A FULL VEIL MORTON.
SOFT SOPHOMORE AS CHINA DOLL
HIGH SCHOOL
TO SHARE HIS HOOKS EXPERIENCE
AND AND ADRIAN BUT THAT*
SHILTON.
OF TO STEINBERG INSTITUTE.
THE INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF TO
SPILL SO.
ALL ASKED TO USE TO.
TAKE IT OR.
GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
I COMPLETED MY FRESHMAN YEAR OF
HIGH SCHOOL AT HOME IN MY BED ON
HOPE HOSPITALIZATION FOR
DEPRESSION SEVERE ANXIETY AND
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
MY NAME IS COOL MORTON.
I AM SIXTEEN YEARS OLD AND A
SOPHOMORE IN THE ELDORADO UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IMPOSSIBLE.
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO FOR NOT ONLY MYSELF
BUT ALSO THE MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS LIKE ME AT ALL ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY TWENTY TO REQUIRE A
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON
ALL K. THROUGH TWELVE CAMPUSES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL CAME FROM
YOUTH HAVE PARTICIPATE AND
MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM. THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH EMPOWERMENT
NETWORK OR COUNTY AND. THIS
PROGRAM HAS A ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT USE BOARD OF THE AGES
SIXTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE.
HAD THERE BEEN A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL ON MY CAMPUS I
WOULD NOT BE SITTING BEFORE YOU
HERE TODAY.
INSTEAD I WOULD HAVE JUST
COMPLETED MY SECOND YEAR OF
FOOTBALL. I WOULD BE IMMERSED IN
MY SECOND YEAR SHOT PUT.
I'D BE RELAXED WITH MY GREAT
GRADES AND I WOULD BE ENJOYING
ALL THE FRIVOLITY IS THE HIGH
SCHOOL HAS TO OFFER.
BECAUSE YOU SEE IF THERE HAD
BEEN A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL ON MY CAMPUS I
WOULD HAVE SIMPLY WALKED ACROSS
THE QUAD WHEN THEY BEGIN
STRUGGLE AND I WOULD HAVE GOTTEN
HELP.
BUT HELP WASN'T THERE FOR ME SO
INSTEAD I STRUGGLED AND
STRUGGLED AND STRUGGLED.
THERE WAS NO ONE TO TALK TO ON
CAMPUS NO ONE ON CAMPUS TO
WILLING TO LEND SUPPORT. AND THE
TEACHERS AND STAFF WERE DEFTLY
REPEATED PLEASE.
SO I CONTINUED TO SING UNTIL I
COULD SINK NO MORE.
SO NOW I ASK YOU TO VOTE I ON AB
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SOME OTHER
STUDENTS SUFFERS AND FALL AS I
DID.
PLEASE GIVE MY GENERATION AND
THE GENERATIONS TO FOLLOW THEM
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT THEY NEED.
TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND WELLNESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THAT
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ADRIN SHELTON WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE OUR MISSION
IS TO ADVANCE SOUND PUBLIC
POLICY INSPIRED LEADERSHIP ON
THE ISSUES OF BRAIN HEALTH.
I'M FIRST WE'D LIKE TO I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I'M FOR HELPING
US WITH THIS BILL. WE'RE PROUD
TO BRING THIS PROPOSAL FORWARD
TO YOU TODAY.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THIS GENERATION'S YOUTH
WITH THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED
TO BECOME HEALTHY ADULTS AND
CONTRIBUTE FULLY. TO OUR
SOCIETY.
CURLY EIGHTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN WHO NEED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE NOT
BEING SERVED.
SUICIDE IS THE THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOUTH AGES
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR.
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE AGED TEN TO
FOURTEEN YEARS OF A AT AGE
SUICIDE RATES HAVE DOUBLED.
IN THE LAST TWO DECADES.
WE CAN DO BETTER.
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO RECOGNIZES
THE IMPERATIVE ROLE THAT SCHOOLS
CAN PLAY IN ADDRESSING THE
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF ARE YOU.
REDUCING STIGMA. AND
FACILITATING BETTER REFERRAL AND
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
SCHOOL DAYS MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ARE A TREMENDOUS
VEHICLE FOR OVERCOMING BARRIERS
TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE AND
MEANINGFULLY EXPANDING THE REACH
OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS FOR SO
MANY CHILDREN IN NEED.
TREATING CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS CAN
POWERFULLY OVERCOME ISSUES OF
COST
OF STIGMA.
TRANSPORTATION AND THAT
TYPICALLY RESTRICT THE BROAD
UTILIZATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
CARE.
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS THE
BRAINCHILD OF THE YOUTH.
WHO ARE ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE
AND THEY ARE RAISING THE BAR?
ABOUT WHAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES IT'S TIME TO
LISTEN TO THEM.
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO REQUIRES
THAT THERE BE AT LEAST ONE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL ON
CAMPUS
TO PROVIDE TIMELY AND EQUITABLE.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND REALLY INCREASING ACCESS IN
PARTICULAR FOR THOSE COMMITTEES
THAT ARE UNDERSERVED.
THIS IS THIS I SIGNIFICANT
INEQUITIES AND THAT WOULD BE
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
IN ADDITION UNDER AB TWENTY
TWENTY TWO MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WILL CONNECT
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES.
OUT WITH WAS SERVICES AS NEDED.
WE MUST DO BETTER THE SUMMARIES.
WE MUST DO BETTER FOR OUR
CHILDREN WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME ALIVE FROM SO YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY PLEASE WE HONOR
QUICK HURRY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RICHARD VAN ONE PRESIDENT
EMERITUS OF MUDDLE UP AMERICA OF
LOS ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NASA TELLIS PARA ORGANIZER
FOR COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION AND
WITH METAL HEALTH AMERICA OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AND KEN GRIFFEY ANYA AND ELEVEN
YEARS OLD AND I SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWENTIETH.
DOCTOR JENNIFER SMITH MARTIN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS IRIS WITH MARTIN AND
I SUPPORT.
CURTIS POLLENS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND I ALSO
PERSONALLY STRONGLY SUPPORTED
THANK YOU.
JORGE MESTER MATCHUP
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
MEGAN O'BRIEN ON BEHALF OF
MENTAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'M INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT.
I MITZI MERRYWEATHER AND THEM IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
PATRICK SCHIRMER MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN WITH LINK AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JOE DIVIDE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON
MENTAL ILLNESS IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
DANNY CANDLE BECAUSE ARE ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN WITH CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THREE QUICK AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AYE.
LEAVE ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION WE ALSO HAD A.
REPORTER FOR MEN THANK YOU WANT
TO.
KATHY SHARON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARK MCKINNEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WERE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS IS A
PUBLIC LESS THAN A MINUTE PER
THANK YOU THAT THE THANK YOU
NOTES WERE NOT OKAY OPPOSITION
NEW TRACK YOU.
LISTEN IF YOU WANTED AMENDED
THIS IS THE PERSON TO TALK TO
RIGHT HERE EVERY LOOK SHE DOES A
GREAT JOB YOU'LL RETURN YOUR
CALL YOUR EMAIL. THAT IS WHERE
YOU GO FOR AMENDMENTS NOT NOW.
I COULDN'T HEAR YOU BUT IT SURE
IS A FINE COMMENT.
SHE JUST PASSED HIM.
SO LIAM THREE OF THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL COUNSELOR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL MOVING
FORWARD I'M APPRECIATE THE
MINUTES INCLUDING COUNSELORS.
SORRY HOME SHARE O'DONNELL AYE
WE ACTUALLY ARE IN SUPPORT WE
DID GET THE AMOUNT IS SO WE ASK
FOR. THANK YOU.
WE GOT OUR AMENDMENTS WERE HAPPY
PEOPLE.
MEDICARE AS BECAUSE A DEMI
RIGHT HERE DID A FINE JOB ON THE
SPOT.
ARE THERE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION OUT THERE.
OKAY SEEING OPPOSITIONAL GRAY
BEHIND THE RAIL MY ONLY QUESTION
THROUGH YOU MISTER CHIU WERE
MAYBE THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AN
INSTITUTE THAT I WAS VERY.
FAMILIAR WITH HOW SACRAMENTO THE
CAPITAL WORKS.
AND HOW WE GONNA PAY FOR THIS.
WE JUST GONNA TAKE IT OUT LCF
HAVE OR DO YOU HAVE A GUN THE
RULES LAWYERS ARE TRYING TO
STILL WORKING ON TOO.
NEW NAIL DOWN SOME SUPPORTING
AND.
ONE THOUGHT WAS USING THEIR
MARIJUANA.
MONEY.
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE.
FIX YOUR FOR A DOZEN NUMBER
HUSNA.
CAN GRAY THERE IS ANOTHER BILL
THAT DOES SPEAK TO THIS EXACT
TOPIC.
THAT ACTUALLY TODAY AND WHAT'S
IN WE GO THROUGH THE PROCESS
MIGHT STAFF IS PRETTY GOOD AT
REACHING OUT TO YOU.
TO DIFFERENT AUTHORS OF BILLS
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD.
ACTUALLY THERE IS A BILL THAT MR
THERE IN THAT ACTUALLY DOZENS
DE.
S. TALKED ABOUT TOOLS Y. COURAGE
I LOOK AT HIS BILL OR AND
POTENTIALLY CO AUTHOR THAT.
OKAY ALSO GOVERNMENT BEING
GALGIANI MISTER THURMOND ALTER
MY DALE.
AND THOUGH WE CAN HOPEFULLY
NUMBERS THAT MATTER ONE BILL
THAT PASSES THEN THAT RIGHT UP
ON THOSE. WHO WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK HIM SO THESE GUYS KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WHEN THEY TALK TO
YOUR STAFF ABOUT THESE KINDS
ARE?
I'M WITHOUT ANY OTHER GOOD TO
THE STEINBERG INCIDENT WANT TO
COMMENT ON THE FUNDING ON.
NOW JUST AT ECHO COMMENTS OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AND I'M ALL OF THE BILL
WILL FUNDING SOURCES FEDERAL AND
STATE.
TO GREAT WAY TO THAT'S A LOOK
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ADVOCATING
THIS BUILDING FOR THAT I THINK
ARE AWARE THAT I HAND IT OVER TO
MISTER.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHIU FRIEDMAN
INTO THIS ISSUE AND.
AND THANK YOU TO ALL THE
WITNESSES IN PARTICULAR THE
STUDENTS WHO CAME TO SHARE YOUR
STORIES I KNOW THAT THEY COULD
BE.
VERY CHALLENGING THING I
APPRECIATE YOU YOU BEING HERE.
AND AS THE CHAIR JUST ALLUDED
TO WE DO HAVE A HANDFUL OF OTHER
BILLS THAT ARE.
SEEKING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
AND THIS IS.
HONESTLY WITH ONE OF MY TOP
PRIORITIES IS ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE THE CHALLENGES OF
ADOLESCENT MENTAL HEALTH.
AND I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE A
TOP PRIORITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
AND I THINK THE FACT THAT YOU DO
SEE DIFFERENT APPROACHES OUT
THERE JUST OF THIS HEARING WE
HAVE.
THE BILLS THAT THE BILL THE
MISTER.
CHAIR OF THE CHAIR ALLUDED TO.
WE'VE BILL DEALING WITH
TRAINING AFTER TEACHERS WE HAVE
A BILL PILOTING A SOCIAL WORKER
AT SCHOOLS PROGRAM AND ALL OF
THOSE. BILLS IT'S GOOD THAT WE
HAVE THEM TO SORT OF.
MOVE THIS ISSUE TO THE TOP OF
THE AGENDA.
I GUESS MY MY CONCERN IS THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS AS
TO WHAT ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
INTERVENTIONS AND.
AND SORT OF THAT DIVERSITY OF
APPROACHES WE HAVE SOME OF WHICH
ARE NOT NECESSARILY CONSISTENT
WITH EACH OTHER SPEAKS TO BACK
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE. A GOOD
ANSWERS AT YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE
OUT WHAT ARE THE IDEAL RATIOS
OFFER STUDENTS TO ADD TO THAT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
WATER THE RIGHT TYPES OF
PROFESSIONALS TO HAVE ON YOUR
CAMPUS IS WHAT SORT OF TRAINING
AND LICENSES ARE. TODAY NEED
WHAT SORT OF INTERACTION SHOULD
THEY BE HAVING.
WITH STUDENTS SO.
IDEA AND THIS IS A CONVERSATION
I NEED TO HAVE THE CHAIRMAN IDEA
I WANT TO PUT OUT IS.
IS TO HAVE AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING.
WITH THIS COMMITTEE OUGHT TO
LOOK AT WHAT DIFFERENT SCHOOLS
AND DISTRICTS ARE DOING ACROSS
THE STATE.
TO SEE WHAT APPROACHES ARE
WORKING WHILE AND WHAT
APPROACHES ARE.
AND AND THEN WE TO THINK OF
WAYS TO SCALE UP TO DATE
APPROACHES YOU KNOW SO THAT WE
CAN I REACH AS MANY STUDENTS AS
POSSIBLE SO.
I THINK I'M GOING TO ABSTAIN ON
TODAY'S BILL NOT BECAUSE I I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE DOING THE
RIGHT THING EITHER BECAUSE I
JUST THINK WE HAPPY.
TO PARTICIPATE LISTA ANY
FUTURES.
HEARINGS OPPORTUNITIES
SO.
BAKER VERY MUCH.
I HAVE MORE PEOPLE KNOW.
YOU DID NOT. KNOW I MEAN YOU GO
OUT OF. IS DONE AND ANSWERING
THE A AS A MEMBER CAL KILEY SO
QUESTIONS GOT GREAT THANK YOU
ANY OTHER CONCERT BEHIND THE.
FROM THE COMMITTEE KNOW YOU MAY
CLOSE THAT'LL SECOND VERY MUCH I
WILL ALSO WHILE THAT THROUGH. A
AGAIN SO THE REDUCE OUR
INCARCERATION
RATE.
IF YOU EVER GOT THE CHANCE TO
VISIT WITH JUVENILE HALL YOU
WILL SEE DOES DO A LOT OF THANK
YOU.
BONE PRO SECULAR VERY MUCH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU MISTER CHIU.
THE MOTION IS TO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
MOST BY DOCTOR WEBER. SECOND BY.
KALRA BOTH THE DOORS FOR VOTES
IT IS
OUT NEXT WHERE HATCH THANK YOU
VERY WELL DONE. AND AGAIN I
COULD YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
OTHER BILLS ACTUALLY DO HAVE A
FUNDING SOURCE THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
AND YOUR SUPPORTERS.
I WITH THAT WILL MOVE TEMAS
QUIRK SILVA WHICH IS.
BOB FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
IT'S TWENTY THREE FIFTEEN FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN.
AND IF YOU COULD BE AS EFFICIENT
AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU. I WILL BE
SWIFT AND FAST BECAUSE I AM
QUIRK SILVA. OR QUICKSILVER IF
YOU WANT TO SAY THAT BUT HE
THAT.
HE ALRIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON.
AND MEMBERS AYE I THINK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB TWO
THREE. ONE FIVE AND THIS BILL IT
JUST BEGINS THE PROCESS TO TALK
ABOUT HOW A K. TWELVE MIGHT
BEGAN TO USE TELL IT HEALTH IN A
THEIR SCHOOLS. AS WE KNOW WE
ALREADY DO HAVE.
SCHOOL NURSES AND COUNSELORS SO
THIS IS NOT IN ANY WAY TO
SUPPLANT THEM IT'S TO START
UTILIZING THE NEWEST TECHNOLOGY
HA UNDER THE UMBRELLA OF
CONVERSATION RELATED. BUT TO
SOME OF THE BILLS THAT YOU'VE
JUST HEARD REGARDING OF THE NEED
FOR COUNSELING AND SO FORTH OUT
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A MIGHT BE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET IMMEDIATE
FEEDBACK.
IN INTERACTION FOR STUDENTS SO
THIS BILL IT WOULD BE A PILOT
PROGRAM AND IT WOULD BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF TELE.
TELEHEALTH.
THAT COULD BE USED THROUGH KATE
TWELFTH.
THANK YOU I JUST WANNA CONFIRM
THE YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
YES.
SO YOU DO ACCEPT EMINENCE THANK
YOU WITH THAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT
MADE AND COVERING CHILDREN WITH
NINETY PERCENT OF CHILDREN
COVERED WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
COVERAGE IS NOT ALWAYS EQUAL
ACCESS TO CARE AND FOR CERTAIN
POPULATION CERTAIN REGIONS OF
THE STATE AND CERTAIN
CONDITIONS.
ACCESS IS MORE OF A CHALLENGE.
FOR KIDS THE SITUATION IS MORE
DIRE A MAY TWENTY SEVENTEEN
STUDY BY YOUNG MINDS I.
HE REPORTED THAT MORE THAN ONE
QUARTER OF A MILLION ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN WITH SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS FAILED TO
RECEIVE MENTAL HEALTH CARE. CARE
SERVICES UNDRAMATIC CAL. WE
RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
TELEHEALTH TO ADDRESS ACCESS
CHALLENGES FOR CHILDREN AND I'VE
HIGHLIGHTED OPPORTUNITIES AND
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS AND
PRACTICES THROUGH A SERIES OF
ISSUE AGREES POLICY BRIEFS. AND
EXPERT COME MEETINGS ON
TELEHEALTH SCHOOL BASED
TELEHEALTH AND TELL HELP FOR
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL HEALTHCARE
NEEDS WE BELIEVE THAT SCHOOLS
ARE SINGULARLY WELL POSITIONED
TO HELP FILL GAPS AND MENTAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. THAT SO
MANY OF OUR CHILDREN FACE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WITH KEY STAKEHOLDER
INPUT CAN TOGETHER DEVELOP
CRUCIAL GUIDELINES TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO MENTAL BEHAVIORAL CARE
FOR. CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M A COLUMN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR CONNECTED HEALTH POLICY
WHICH IS THE FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED NATIONAL TELL HEALTH
POLICY RESEARCH CENTER. I'M HERE
TODAY AS A TECHNICAL EXPERT TO
ANSWER ANYMORE QUESTIONS
REGARDING TAL HO FOR ANY SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS EXIST IN OTHER
STATES AND WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. HAS BEEN FUNDING IN
RELATION TO TELL HEALTH SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
LARA PART BEHALF OF THAT
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS THANK YOU.
ON A HAS ABOUT WITH UNITED WAYS.
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO WITH THE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH COVERAGE
COALITION WHICH.
HAS OF THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP A.
CALIFORNIA COVERAGE AND HEALTH
INITIATIVES AND CHILDREN NOW
THINK YOU'D SUPPORT.
MEDIEVAL AND REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE NOT TAKEN A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT AS. BECOMES MORE
SPECIFIC ON MORE VISUAL WE WILL
HAVE A POSITION THANK YOU.
SO MY AND HARD ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIAL TO CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SING OPPOSITION.
OUR I JUST WANNA CLARIFY WHAT
THE AMENDMENTS ARE IS STRAIGHT
THE CONTENTS OF THE BILL AND
REPLACE IT WITH LANGUAGE
DIRECTLY CD IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE H. CS.
AND APPROPRIATE STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING THOSE WITH EXPERIENCE
IN THE FIELD OF TELEHEALTH TO
DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR THE USE
OF TELEHEALTH TECHNOLOGY IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. TO WRITE MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH TO
STUDENTS BY A SPECIFIED DATE
THOSE ARE WHAT THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE NEW AMENDMENTS.
I DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
TO KALRA MOVES DOCTOR WEBER
SECONDS.
BILLS REMOVED.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
BUT JUST SO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE GREAT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO ASSEMBLY
HELP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN WEBER.
WEBER I.
NMLS OUT THANK YOU MEMBER THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT WE'LL GO TO.
.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ NOT HERE.
A VERY WELL OKAY YOUR TALLER. HE
NEED TO GET TALLER OKAY.
.
COME ON UP.
MISTER RODRIGUEZ HAS.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN FILING
WINNER FOR.
YOU MAY.
.
SEED ONE READY YOU IF YOU COULD
BE AS BRIEF AN OFFICIAL AS
POSSIBLE YOU DO HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL THANK HIM.
AND MOVED AND I'LL SECOND.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR MEMBERS GOING
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS
OF PROPOSED ANALYSIS I THINK THE
STUFF WHICH ARE FOR THE WORK.
IN CALIFORNIA TWENTY PERCENT
CHILDREN HAVE UNRELIABLE ACCESS
TO HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS MEALS. AB
TWENTY THREE SEEK TO HELP
FACILITATE PARTNERSHIP RETREAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND FOOD BY EX
BY REQUIRING DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. AND THE PARMA
EDUCATION TO ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES AND BEST PRACTICES
FORCE.
SUCH PARTNERSHIPS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY A SUPPORT.
RON RAPPAHANNOCK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
SAYING NO OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ARE COULD WE HAVE A MOTION MR
MCCARTY MOVES.
SCHOLAR SECONDS.
YOU A CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL BUT DONALD
MADONNA AYE KILEY.
KALRA.
CALLER I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMAN WEBER.
THURMOND I.
AND WEBER BY.
THAT WOULD.
OTHER.
OKAY GODZILLA'S OUT AS FOR VOTES
IT HAS.
IT IS SIX OF THE BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT TO A BILL IS A FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN TWENTY.
NUMBERED FILE ITEMS NUMBER TEN
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX WHEN
MISTER JONES SAWYER HE WAS HERE
THERE IS.
FOR WILL START A FIRE IN NUMBER
TEN.
WHICH IS.
.
FIVE I'M HONORED TEN.
TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR.
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU BOB
MEMBERS FOUR TO ONE OF THANKED
CHAIR. AND COMMITTEE FOR FOR
WORKING ON MY WORK WITH MY
OFFICE I WILL BE DECLARE YOU DO
HAVE A SUPPORT SUPPORT ON THIS
OKAY. I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
CHAIRMAN OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
SAY.
AB TWO TO THREE FOUR WILL
PROVIDE STUDENTS WHO ARE
TESTIFYING IN EMPLOYEE DISMISSAL
HEARINGS WAS SUMA PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO MINORS AND
OTHER LEGAL SETTINGS. ARE AB TWO
TO THREE FIVE WOULD PROVIDE
ADMINISTRATIVE JUDGES WITH THE
DISCRETION TO ALLOW THE USE OF A
TWO WAY CLOSED CIRCUIT
TELEVISION OR VIDEO TAPES
DISPERSED DEPOSITION. AS AN
ALTERNATIVE FORM OF TESTIMONY
FOR STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
VICTIMS OF THE EGREGIOUS ACTS BY
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRED A VICTIM ADVOCATE BE
APPOINTED TO EACH CHILD WITNESS
TO ACCOMPANY HIM THROUGHOUT A
PROCESS THAT CAN. BE EMOTIONALLY
AND PSYCHOLOGICALLY DRAMATIC
WITH ME TODAY RK CALLINGS AND
SHERRY MO ATTORNEY FOR THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THEY WILL SHARE TO SPECIFIC
CASES THAT INSPIRED HIS BILL.
AND ARE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
HOWEVER I BELIEVE THE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE IS TO MOVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY.
BOTH I KATE COLLINS FROM LAUSD
CORD.
IT'S AN ADMINISTRATIVE HEARING
BUT IT'S LIKE A COURTROOM
SETTING.
THE NEED TO. TREAT THE SICK JUST
FEET AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
ABUSE THEM ARE MISTREATED THEM.
ENGAGED IN MISCONDUCT. AND
THEY'VE TO TESTIFY AGAINST THEM.
AND AT THIS POINT THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN INTERROGATED BY A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
OFTENTIMES IF THEY HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A SITE INVESTIGATION. A
DISTRICT INVESTIGATION.
DISTRICT ATTORNEY INVESTIGATION.
AND THEN WE START THIS PROCESS
WHERE PRIVATE INVESTIGATORS GET
INVOLVED.
AND WHAT I'VE SEEN OVER THE
YEARS IS REALLY HARD TO TAKE.
SOME STUDENTS ARE SO FEARFUL BY
THE TIME THEY GET TO THIS
PROCESS.
I HAD TO LEAVE THE STATE.
OKAY EVER HAD SO MANY JUST NOT
SHOW UP.
AND THAT ARE OPTION IS OKAY
LET'S.
SUBPOENA THEM AND YOU KNOW.
MOVED TO GOOD HEALTH REQUIRE
THEM TO COME TO COURT THEY'RE
SCARED.
AND.
.
IF.
SO WE DO THIS FOR YEARS BUT WHAT
REALLY STRUCK ME WAS A CASE
ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND IT WASN'T
EVEN THE MOST EGREGIOUS.
IT WAS CASE INVOLVED AN
EDUCATOR.
WHO WOULD THROW THINGS AT A
STUDENT?
BUT THE STATE WAS VERY
VULNERABLE.
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENT AND
DUMB.
HE CAME AND HE SHOWED UP. AND
HE'D BEEN CONSISTENT ALL
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
BUT ONCE HE WAS INTERROGATED BY.
PRETTY AGGRESSIVE ATTORNEYS ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
HE JUST FELL PART.
HE STARTED SPINNING AROUND IN
HIS CHAIR AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
EVERYTHING THAT HE HAS BEEN
SAYING CONSISTENTLY OVER THE
YEARS.
HE WASN'T MAKING THINGS UP.
SO I WENT DOWN TO OUR MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL. AND I SAID
EXPLAIN WHAT'S GOING ON TO ME.
AND SHE SAID IF YOU COULD
SUMMARIZE PLEASE YES THIS IS
TRAUMA.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THEY'RE
TRAUMATIZED BEGINNING EVERYTIME
AFTER REPEAT THE STORY AND THEN
TRAUMATIZED. SO CRUELLY IN THE
AND.
WHAT WE HOPE TO TO DO WITH THIS
BILL IS PROVIDE THEM JUST THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE'VE ALREADY
AFFORD? YOUNG PEOPLE.
IN OTHER FORA THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MY NAME IS GERRY NO I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
SPECIFICALLY MY ROLE IS TO
LITIGATE THESE CASES BOTH
CERTIFICATED AND CLASSIFIED.
THAT INCLUDES THE EGREGIOUS ONLY
MATTERS.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TO THIRTY
FOUR SEEKS TO AFFORD LEGAL
PROTECTIONS TO MINOR WITNESSES
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE IN ANY
OTHER LEGAL PROCEEDING HOWEVER
BECAUSE THE CHILD'S ALLEGATIONS
ARE LITIGATED AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COURT. THEY ARE NOT PROVIDED
THESE RIGHTS.
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR DOES
NOT IMPLICATE THE DUE PROCESS
AND PORTS OF AB TWO FIFTEEN. AB
TWO FIFTEEN WAS PRIMARILY ABOUT
THE PROCEDURE LEADING UP TO THE
HEARING. WHERE IS THIS BILL IS
ABOUT THE HEARING ITSELF?
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR IS
EXTREMELY NECESSARY FOR REASONS
MY COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT. TO
NOTE EVEN THOUGH SOME OF OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES HOW
DISCRETION UNDER THE GOVERNMENT
CODE TO APPLY SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS TO MINORS.
pCONSISTENCY AND I SPEAK ABOUT
THIS FROM EXPERIENCE I WOULD
SUBMIT TO YOU ALL THAT THIS
INCONSISTENCY IS DUE TO THE LACK
OF STATUTORY GUIDELINES
AVAILABLE. FOR ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES TO CONSIDER. UNLIKE
EVERY OTHER LEGAL PROCEEDING
THAT DOES INVOLVE A MINOR
WITNESS.
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR IS
NARROWLY TAILORED.
TO ONLY AFFECT AGREE JUST
MISCONDUCT CASES AND EXPEDITE
THE PROCESS FOR ALL PARTIES IN
THREE DIFFERENT WAYS FIRST.
UNDER AGREE JUST ONLY PROCEDURES
THERE'S A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
DISCOVERY PROCESS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY GOVERNED BY THE
GOVERNMENT CODE IT'S NOT
GOVERNED BY THE EDUCATION CODE.
THERE ARE NO INITIAL DISCLOSURES
THERE'S ONLY A DEMAND FOR
DISCOVERY AND THAT DEMAND
TYPICALLY INCLUDE THE DEMAND FOR
CONTACT INFORMATION OF THE
MINOR.
UNDER FEDERAL LAW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CANNOT DISCLOSE THAT
INFORMATION CERTAIN. ABSENT
CERTAIN LEGAL REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO A SUBPOENA IS BY FAR THE
MOST EFFICIENT PROCESS TO
SATISFY THE LEGAL REQUIREMENT.
THE SECOND WAY AND MAYBE TWENTY
TO THIRTY FOUR WOULD STREAMLINED
THE DEPOSITION PROCESS AN
EGREGIOUS ONLY MATTERS THIRD AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE ANY COMMUNICATION BY THE
DISTRICT. OR BY THE EMPLOYEE TO
GO THROUGH A VICTIM ADVOCATE OR
AT ADULT ATTENDANT. PARENTS CAN
BE GREAT ADVOCATES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN BUT IT'S A REALITY THIS
MONTH FOR PARENTS HAVE MULTIPLE
JOBS THE MULTIPLE CHILDREN THEY
MAY HAVE IMMIGRATION CONCERNS
LANGUAGE BARRIERS IS A BIG ONE
IN LA UNIFIED. AND THEY MAY BE
UNAVAILABLE OR THEY JUST DON'T
KNOW THEIR RIGHTS IN A COURT
SETTING.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO DO ANYTHING
NEW ALL OF THESE PROTECTIONS
BEEN SOUGHT BY AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY FOUR ARE AFFORDED IN
EVERY OTHER LEGAL PROCEEDING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU HAVE HIS
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OR
PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
AND SUPPORT.
NO THIS IS SUPPORT OF ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR SETH
BRAMBLE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY. AND OPPOSITION TO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWO THREE
FOUR.
I WILL BE BRIEF.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES
ALREADY HAVE ALL KINDS OF
DISCRETION WHEN IT COMES TO
PROTECTING CHILDREN. IN THESE
KINDS OF PROCEEDINGS AND DO
REGULARLY EXERCISE THAT
DISCRETION. ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS.
.
THE SUBSTANCE OF THIS BILL WILL
MAKE THE PROCESS TAKE LONGER IT
WILL MAKE IT COST MORE AND IT
COMPROMISES THE DUE PROCESS OF
EDUCATORS. WEIRD YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
AYE IN SONG LAWYER WAIT THEY
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION.
WE SEE IF CA PASTRAMI BELIEVES
IN PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN AND
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE A SAFE.
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT TO BE AND.
WE HAVE TAKEN AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION AND WHERE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS
STAFF TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
รณ THINK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER FOR IT THAT.
WE ARE SEEKING AMENDMENTS HUH
TOO NARROWLY TAILOR THIS TWO WAY
CIRCUIT VIDEO TESTIMONY TO
EGREGIOUS MISCONDUCT CASES
SIMPLY.
BECAUSE WE WANT TO PROVIDE
CHILDREN A SAFE PLACE TO TESTIFY
BUT WE ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR MEMBERS.
THERE TO PROCESS RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED.
WE ESPECIALLY IN CASES IN WHICH
THERE MAY BE FALSE ACCUSATION SO
THEREFORE WE BELIEVE THAT HAVING
IN A EL CHE.
BEAT THE PRESIDING OFFICER AT
THE EVIDENTIARY HEARING WILL
ENSURE THAT THESE PROTECTIONS
ARE IN PLACE.
WE ALSO ARE.
SEEKING AMENDMENTS TO AND
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
TOGETHER TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION
I THINK.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO OTHER OPPOSITION WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY COMMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE WANT ONE QUESTION ONE QUICK
QUESTION DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
ON.
HOW OFF THE MOON ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGES DON'T GRANT THIS?
?
THE REQUESTED NOT HAVE THE
PERSON THERE TESTIFIED.
I THINK IT YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
IT'S I THINK AT SOME POINT. YOU
KNOW MY HEART IS ALWAYS WITH
STUDENTS CLEARLY.
BUT ALSO YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN.
INFLUENCED BY A JUDGE IN A
LAWYER WHO WAS A HUSBAND MY
AMBIVALENCE ABOUT IS THAT RIGHT
OR IS IT NOT RIGHT YOU KNOW
WHERE TO FIND THE FAIRNESS WOULD
WE FIND THE JUSTICE. AND I KNOW
WE'RE TALKING BY KIDS AND YOUNG
PEOPLE AND STUFF WHO WERE ALSO
TALK ABOUT ADULTS IN THEIR LIVES
TO SO. I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO
AT THE STATE LEVEL WOULD TAKE A
LOT OF AUTHORITY OFTENTIMES AWAY
FROM JUDGES AND THEN HAD TO GIVE
IT BACK.
SO I'M REALLY PARENTHOOD ABOUT
TAKING THE AUTHORITY AWAY FROM
JUDGES WHOSE TASK IS TO HEAR
BOTH SIDES THAT POINT ABOUT THE
JUDGE'S
AUTHORITIES AND LIKE I SAID
WE'VE. IN THIS HOUSE AT OVER THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS HAVE GONE BACK
TO RESTORING THE AUTHORITY OF
THE JUDGE BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO LOOK AT THE SITUATION.
AND MAKE SOME DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IN DIFFERENT
SETTINGS
SO DO WE HAVE ANY IDEA HOW. THAT
THIS IS BROKEN I GUESS OF WHAT
I'M SAYING.
IT AND I COULD JUST MISSED. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS FROM THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IS THAT THAT IS
THE PURPOSE OF BILLS TO CLARIFY
THAT A JUDGE DOES HAVE THIS
DISCRETION. OKAY.
OKAY WITH WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
UNLESS YOU PUSH A BUTTON. OKAY I
ONLY KNOW OF ONE CASE WHERE THE
JUDGE ACTUALLY AUTHORIZED CLOSED
CIRCUIT THAT ENHANCE OF.
ACTUALLY THERE BUT IT'S NOT
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT SUPPORTED
MISS MOST CAN ADDRESS THIS.
OKAY.
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND THE
CURRENT STATUTORY SCHEME IS JUST
UNCLEAR SO THIS IS SEEKING
GUIDANCE THE MOST OFTEN RESPOND
TO HEAR FROM THE MINISTER OF OUR
JUDGES IS. WHY NOW THAT YOU'RE
MOVING FOR THIS BUT DO I HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO IT THAT'S
ALSO AT THE GOVERNMENT CODE
BECAUSE IT'S ALL WE HAVE? WILL
SAY YOU KNOW I I JUST DON'T I
DON'T THEY DON'T FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR AUTHORITY
IS AND SO THIS IS JUST SEEKING
TO CLEAR THIS IS NOT CLEAR FIVE
A COAT YES OKAY SOUNDS GOOD
ALRIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SO LOW MOVED.
SECOND SET I MISTER KILEY MAKE
CLOTHES.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY.
THANK YOU BOB AND I WILL BE
WORKING WITH CSTA BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT HAVE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGES TO HAVE PARITY IS WITH
TEACHERS SO. I AM EXTREMELY
SEAFOOD PORTENT MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE SAME SYSTEM.
NOW LEAVE YOU WITH THIS WITH
THEM THE MCMARTIN TRIAL.
WHERE? INDIVIDUALS WERE FALSELY
ACCUSED AND FOUND OUT THAT
PEOPLE. INFLUENCE THEM NOW WE
SEXUAL RATION BUT.
PANIC THINGS OF THAT NATURE
RESULTING DEL THAT MOST
EXPENSIVE AND. THE LONGEST.
.
PORT TROUBLING HISTORY.
AS A RESULT OF THAT STATES
ACROSS THE NATION NOW HAVE BUMP
CLOSE CIRCUIT.
EVIDENCE TAKING FROM CHILDREN.
ALL BECAUSE OF THAT THAT'S THE
IRONY OF THIS RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE OF THE OF THE
MISINFORMATION AGAINST.
TEACHERS WE NOW GO TO THIS FORM
OF THE TESTIMONY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA MOTIONS TO PASS
SOME OF THE JUDICIARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
KALRA.
LARA I AM MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE
THURMOND.
THURMOND I WAVERED AYE WEBER
AYE.
SOME OF THE BILL IS OUT WHEN I
MOVED.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
TWENTY FIVE BY MISTER JONES
SAWYER. THAT'S AB TWO SIX EIGHT
SIX.
YES ARE GOOD AFTERNOON. OFFERS
FOR ONE THANK COMMITTEE AND
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON CLARIFYING THE ANNUAL
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS OF THIS
BILL AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE CHAIR OF
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE. COMMISSION STAFF
BOYS MINUTE COLOR I HAVE SEEN
FIRST HAND WHAT THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE LOOKS LIKE AND
FOR ME THIS REALITY IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
THERE ARE FAR TOO MANY KIDS
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN
CHILDREN BEING SWEPT INTO JUST
PIPELINE FOR REASONS DEREK. AKA
INCOMPREHENSIBLE
NO CHILD IS BROUGHT INTO THIS
WORLD WANTING TO GO TO SCHOOL
END UP BEHIND BARS GROWING UP
AWAY FROM THE PARENTS FAMILIES
AND FRIENDS BUT YET. THAT IS A
REALITY FOR TOO MANY OF THEM
ESPECIALLY AFRICAN AMERICAN AND
LATINO CHILDREN CHILDREN WHO AT
THE STATE WE BEAR RESPONSIBILITY
OF EDUCATING NOT INCARCERATING.
AND WHO SHOULD BE UP WE SHIP
THEM WHO WE SHOULD BE
APOLOGIZING TO FOR THEIR EVEN
BEING A SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
SIX IT'S A FORM OF APOLOGY FOR
NOT PROVIDING THE TOOLS TO TEACH
CHILDREN NEED PREVENT THEM FROM
BEING CAUGHT UP IN THIS NEGATIVE
SYSTEM.
BY PROVIDING ANNUAL TRAINING TO
OURS CERTIFIED SCHOOL PERSONNEL
TO HELP THEM RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
AND MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
UNDERSTAND POSSIBLE ACTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM IN ADDRESSING
STUDENT FAMILY NEEDS WILL HELP.
WITH EARLY DETECTION THE
DETECTION AND TREATMENT OF
MENTAL CONDITION THAT ARE SO
OFTEN MISDIAGNOSED AND STARTS.
KIDS ON THAT PERILOUS A JOURNEY
INTO THE PIPELINE.
ALRIGHT DOT THINK MISTER JOHN
SERVES ON A CLARIFY YOU WANT TO
HELP KIDS GET SERVICES YOU KNOW
WHAT THE TEAM.
TREAT MENTAL HEALTH IN THE
CLASSROOM. CORRECT ULTIMATELY
WHAT MARROW SECTIONALS GET.
NOW AGREE OUR THAT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THERE'S MORE US
AND ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
DIANA MAC DONALD PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND
SUPPORT.
THE NEED TO HAVE AVERAGE
EDUCATION ADVOCATES CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA WE SUPPORT.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR SECOND
DISTRICT PTA AND SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
EVELYN ABOLHASSAN DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA INSTRUCTS.
QUICKLY IF THERE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA AND SUPPORT.
KATHY RAVEN PARA CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA INCIDENT OR.
ERNIE SILVA FOR SAITEK IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MORGAN DIRECTIVE
EDUCATION THIRTY THIRD DISTRICT
PTA IN SUPPORT.
DURING PANGGIL NINTH DISTRICT
PTA PRESIDENT SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
I THINK YOU.
.
NO FOR THE SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION THE BOUNCING
OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
SEE NO COMMENTS FOR MANY THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
MISTER THURMOND YOU MODES. OF
AND SECOND MOST CAR.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HELP THOSE MAKE A
QUICK COMMENT THAT. TRAINS
IMPORTANCE OR PROTOCOLS OF THE
SITE OR EVEN A DISTRICT LEVEL SO
THAT.
YET FUTURE REFERS IT THEN WHAT
HAPPENS.
SOMETIMES IT'S
PROTOCOLS AND ESTABLISH SO EVEN
A COUNSELOR WON'T KNOW TO WHERE
THE SERVICES I NEED I NEED TO GO
TO HELP THE STUDENT THE BEST SO.
I HOPE I PAY ATTENTION TO THAT
TO WE DON'T NECESSARILY WANT
ACCOUNTS ARE TREATING THE
STUDENT EITHER WE NEED SOMEONE
WHO IS A GREAT TRAINED
PROFESSIONAL CERTIFIED
CERTIFICATED WHATEVER MAYBE.
SO THAT WE GET OUR STUDENTS THE
HELP THEY NEED. WITH THAT MOTION
AGAIN IS TO PASS AS AMENDED HELP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. O'DONNELL
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THE BILL'S VOTE TO DEVELOP SOME
OF IT IS HOW WILL NOW MOVE TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX.
FINE I'M NUMBER TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE WHICH IS AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY ONE.
UP AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
WORKING MY OFFICE OP EXCEPT INTO
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
LAST YEAR I INTRODUCED ACR
EIGHT WHICH IS. A RECOGNIZED
THAT ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES OR POSTTRAUMATIC ST
DISORDER IS.
IS AS IT IS CALLED IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
NEEDED TO PAY CLOSER ATTENTION
TO BECAUSE IS HAVING NEGATIVE
EFFECTS ARE SCHOOLS. BASIS STUDY
HAS SHOWN THE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE ARE MAJOR RISK
FACTORS FOR THE LEADING CAUSES
OF ILLNESS AND DEATH. AS WELL AS
POOR QUALITY OF LIFE IT IS ALSO
SHOWN A STRONG ASSOCIATION
BETWEEN HIGH IT'S BASIS COURTS
AND POOR PERFORMANCE IN SCHOOL
INCLUDING A HIGHER RISK OF
LEARNING. AND IN BEHAVIOR
PROBLEMS.
EXERCISE PLAYED A TROMBONE IS
NOT AND EVEN IN AND VET ITSELF A
RATHER RESPONSE ONE OR MORE
OVERWHELMING STRESSFUL INCIDENTS
WHERE ONE'S ABILITY TO COPE IS
DRAMATICALLY.
UNDERMINE THE TRUMP INFORMED
SCHOOL INITIATIVE WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA TO CATCH UP WHICH
STATES LIKE MASSACHUSETTS OHIO
MICHIGAN AND OTHERS HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED. OUR TRAUMA INFORMED
PROGRAM FOR TO SCHOOL HERE WITH
ME TODAY. ITS EARNINGS SILVA
FROM SGI. AS I A TECH WHO IS
GOING TO SHARE WITH YOU TO
TROUBLING FOR PROGRAM THAT AS I
A TECH HAS IMPLEMENT. MEMBERS
ARE STRICTLY AT TI VO.
THANK YOU ANY SO FROM SAITEK
WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY ONE BECAUSE THERE'S AN
UNMET NEED FOR TRAUMA BASED CARE
AMONG ALTERNATIVE SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
WE FOUND THAT OUR RE ENGAGE
STUDENTS SEVEN X.
DREAM EXPOSURE TO ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AND TRAUMA
ON AVERAGE AT LEAST TEN
EXPOSURES IN ADDITION TO
POVERTY.
WE'VE ALSO FOUND THAT OUR
TEACHERS LIKE MOST TEACHERS
RECEIVE LITTLE OR NO TRAUMA
TRAINING. DOCTRINE IN LANSING
FROM UC SAN DIEGO AND WE WORK
WITH LINKS THIS LACK OF TRAINING
TO HIGH TEACHER TURNOVER. IN
SCHOOLS SERVING LOW INCOME AND
TRAUMA INFUSED STUDENTS I
BELIEVE THIS IS SUPPORT SPORTS
I'M GONNA.
I'M GONNA STOP RIGHT THERE WE
ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
DIANA MAC DONALD PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA AND
SUPPORT.
CLEAR DEREK CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
IN SUPPORT.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN KNOWN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY.
COMMENTS FROM ANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
ANY OPPOSITION SORRY ANY
OPPOSITION ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER SAYING NONE.
.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTIONS MOVED SECONDED THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED HOW
THEY JUST WANNA CLARIFY THE
AMENDMENTS OTHER REQUIRE THE
TRAINING BE MADE AVAILABLE IN
ALL.
YES THERE MOVE THE CAR THAT
HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENTS WHO
RIDE TRAUMA INFORMED CLINICAL
CARE OURS AT KEY TWELVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THOSE ARE REMOVED.
AND AGAIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED HEALTH.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY FEI
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
COVER AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE THURMAN. THURMOND AYE AND
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
COMMITTEE SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU.
WILL NEXT.
GO TO OUR.
MY GOD JUNE SIR.
JIM ARE SIMILAR FRAZIER THE
PRESENT.
YEAH IF FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE
.
YOU HAVE RECEIVED IN WRITING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
DIDN'T A AMENDMENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THE BILL AND.
COMMITMENT TO HELP STUDENTS WITH
ABILITIES.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT INSURES THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
DEPARTMENT REVOLT REHABILITATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ARE COORDINATING
EFFECTIVELY TO SERVE INDIVIDUALS
WILL DEVELOP DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THROUGH THAT INITIAL PHASES OF
THE PLANNING PROCESS AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY ONE FOCUSES ON THE
INDIVIDUAL AND THEIR GOALS.
IT MAKE SURE THAT A PERSON WITH
AIDID THE WHO HITS THE AGE OF
TWENTY TWO.
WILL NOT BE LEFT BEHIND ONCE
THEY LEAVE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I RECOGNIZE THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
WORKING BEHIND THE SCENES WITH
THE GOAL OF COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT.
PER THE CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE
IN AGREEMENT INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT BLUEPRINT.
WHAT HURTS MY HEART IS THAT ONLY
FIFTEEN PERCENT OF INTO
INDIVIDUALS ID DE?
ARE CURRENTLY EMPLOYED.
OUR INTENTION IS TO SUPPORT THE
PROGRESS BEING MADE IN THE
BLUEPRINT.
AND SURE THE BLUEPRINT HAS THE
PIECES OF THE PUZZLE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THE STUDENT SUCCEEDS.
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND SPEAK TO THE NECESSITY OF
THE BILL ARE DOCTOR LIBYA RAINER
AND SANDY GATE GEOGHAN.
A PARENT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
NAME IS OLIVIA RAINER I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE TORSION CENTER.
A UNIVERSITY CENTER FOR
EXCELLENCE AT UCLA.
I AM ALSO A MEMBER OF THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WHAT
WE HEAR OVER AND OVER AGAIN IS
THAT FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THE TRANSITION TO ADULTHOOD IS
EXPERIENCED AS FALLING OFF A
CLIFF AND HERE'S WHY.
WHEN A STUDENT IS IN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THERE'S A GUARANTEED
SYSTEM OF SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
AND FAMILIES GENERALLY KNOW HOW
TO NAVIGATE THE SYSTEM.
THEY LEAVE THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
AND THE LEGAL MANDATE FOR THE
SUPPORT ENDS THEY LACK THE KNOW
HOW TO SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATE
OTHER AVAILABLE SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT. THE US RATHER THAN
GETTING THE SERVICES THEY NEED
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES ON
THEIR OWN ALL TOO OFTEN DO NOT
CONNECT WITH VITAL. OF
VOCATIONAL SERVICES THAT ARE
OBTAINED THROUGH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES AND HENCE THE CLIFF.%
AS RECENTLY AS LAST WEEK I SPOKE
WITH A MOTHER WHOSE SON WITH
AUTISM AND GRADUATED WITH A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND DID NOT HAVE
PLACE AND NEVER FOUND A JOB. FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS THIS YOUNG
MAN HAS BECOME A COUCH DWELLER
THIS IS NOT WHAT WE WOULD WANT
FOR ANY STUDENT.
APPLYING EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOO ADDRESSING THE%
CLIFF WE KNOW WHAT WORKS WE JUST
NEED TO CREATE POLICIES AND
INCENTIVES TO DO IT. THE USE OF
INTER AGENCY COLLABORATION.
AS PROPOSED IN THIS OP BILL IS
CONSIDERED AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE IN SCHOOL TO WORK
TRANSITION THAT LEADS TO BETTER
ADULT OUTCOMES TO EMPLOYMENT.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
DEPARTMENTS OF EDUCATION AND
REHABILITATION AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES.
ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT CALLED
THE CALIFORNIA COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT BLUEPRINT
FOR CHANGE.
THIS PLAN WAS CREATED TO
IMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA'S OF FIRST
POLICY AS WELL AS ADDRESS OTHER
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICIES.
THE OVERALL GOAL WAS TO JOINTLY
ADDRESS THE NEED FOR EMPLOYMENT
IN AN INTEGRATED SETTING AT A
COMPETITIVE WAGE FOR INTELLECT
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ANIMATED ITS
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
WHILE ESTABLISHED AT THE STATE
LEVEL ITS IMPLEMENTATION IS
LOCAL AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE
CONTINUES THIS BY CREATING
STATEWIDE GUIDANCE.
THAT HAPPENS PERSON TO PERSON
STUDENT TO STUDENT.
AB ONE SEVENTY ONE MAKES THE
FOLLOWING UP FIVE PROPOSED
CHANGES.
FIRST IT HAS THE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ADOPT THE EXISTING
EMPLOYMENT FIRST POLICY OF THE
STATE.
SECOND IT ASKS THE THREE
DEPARTMENTS TO HAVE SECTIONS OF
THEIR SERVICE PLANS ADDRESS HOW
THEY WILL WORK TOWARD THE SAME
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT GOAL. FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT.
THIRD IT ASKS THE THREE
DEPARTMENTS TO FIND WAYS TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE COORDINATION
ON PERSON CENTERED PLANNING.
FOURTH IT ASKS THE THREE
DEPARTMENTS
FIND WAYS TO SHARE DATA THEY
HAVE ON PEOPLE WITH TO SOME
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES IF
YOU COULD SUMMARIZE OUTCOMES.
MAYBE BETTER TRACKED I'M ALMOST.
LASTLY IT GIVES STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR PARENTS
ACCESS TO THEIR OWN RECORDS AND
FILES ALLOWING THE PERSON TO
ACCESS THE DATA AND SHARE IT AS
HE OR SHE CHOOSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA GEOGHAN AND
I AM THE PARENT OF KYLE GEOGHAN
AND EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD HIGH
SCHOOL SENIOR.
THIS IS HIM AND THE PITCHER YOU
CHOSE FOR ME TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE FUTURE
DREAMS THE DREAMS OF HIS PEERS
AND THE STRUGGLE THEY AND US
PARENTS ARE HAVING PLANNING FOR
THEIR FUTURE.
LIKE MOST EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS HE
HAS DREAMS OF INDEPENDENCE AND
WORK THAT HE FINDS MEANINGFUL
AND PROFITABLE.
HE HAS A VERY CREATIVE
IMAGINATION AND HIS FUTURE
TERRAIN CONSISTS OF WRITING A
BOOK.
THIS YEAR HE HAS STARTED USING
VOICE TO TEXT TO WORK ON HIS
WRITING SKILLS.
HE HAS NOW ACKNOWLEDGED HE NEEDS
A PILLAR JOB.
BUT HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT TYPE OF
JOB YOU MAY WANT TO PURSUE OR
HAS PERSPECTIVE ON WHAT JOB
SKILLS HE WILL NEED TO FIND. TO
FIND A JOB AND TO KEEP ONE.
AS IS ADVOCATE OBTAINING
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE
A BILL TO SUPPORT HIM IN
TRANSITION IS REMINISCENT OF THE
DIFFICULT EARLY YEARS WE HAD.
LOOKING FOR A DIAGNOSIS IT AND
SUPPORT AND PLACING SUPPORT
SERVICES INTO PLACE.
I'VE SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS
RESEARCHING WHAT IS AVAILABLE
FOR OUR SON YET STILL I'VE NOT
FOUND A PROGRAM FOR HIM THIS
SUMMER OR DETERMINE WHAT WILL
BEST FIT HIS NEEDS NEXT YEAR.
AT A PARENT GROUP.
I WAS TOLD I WOULD BE LEARNING
ALONG WITH EVERYONE ELSE.
I SPOKE WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
AND WAS TOLD THEY COULD GO TO
THE I EP WITH ME LIKE THEY
ALWAYS DO BUT CONFIRMED THAT THE
REGIONAL CENTER DOES NOT PROVIDE
TRANSITION TYPE SERVICES UNTIL
HE IS TWENTY TWO.
AT THE I EP THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION DIRECTOR TOLD ME I DO
NOT HALF LOOK TO THEM FOR
SERVICES.
BUT THAT KYLE COULD CONTINUE
WITH THIS CURRENT PROGRAM. AND
HE STARTED WITH SOME WORKABILITY
HOURS WHICH HE STARTED LAST
WEEK.
FORTUNATELY IN MY SEARCH ANOTHER
PARENT ADVOCATE RECOMMENDED I
ASK THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION TO ATTEND HIS
IEP.
IT WAS THE FIRST IEP THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
ATTENDED THAT SHE HAD EVER
ATTENDED IT WAS OF. SHE PROVIDED
SOME HELPFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE.
BUT THAT WORK ABILITY WOULD GO
THROUGH THE SCHOOL. IT STILL
REMAINS CLOUDY.
SO THIS EXPERIENCE IS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU HAVE WHEN
YOU ARE LEARNING ABOUT YOUR
CHILD'S NEEDS WHEN YOU WANT TO
BRING A GROUP OF PROFESSIONALS
TOGETHER TO PLAN FOR THEM.
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY ONE ONE
PERSON ONE GOAL WOULD ASSURE
THAT EACH AGENCY HAS MORE
CLEARLY ARTICULATED PULLS. ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES IN
PREPARING BICU MY SON TO LEAVE
SPANK YOU READY TO WORK IN THE
ARMY OTHERS IN SUPPORT WE THANK
YOU.
EVELYN ITEMS PASS AND DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE WERE
INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE BLUEPRINT AND
I'M STRIKE YOU PUT THIS BILL.
Q..
TRUTH ANDERSON WITH ARKAN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEN OPPOSITION ANY CONFIRMADO
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE HAVE
A MOTION.
BILL'S MOVED AND SECOND I
WATCHED KARA.
NOW THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HUMAN SERVICES.
YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE ON THIS DESPERATELY.
NEEDED.
BILLS GOING FOR NIGHT OF
RESPECT ASK THE COMMITTEE CYCLE
THANK YOU. UP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL
AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA IKE MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN THURMOND
AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
BILL HAS SIX VOTES IT IS UP
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSENT CALORIES AS FOLLOWS ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
FOUR BY MR MCCARTY. THE MOTIONS
TO PASS TO HEALTH COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY MR MEDINA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY TO THIRTY NINE
BY MISTER GARCIA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO
NINETY ONE I MISTER CHU THE
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY
NINE MISTER ARAMBULA MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS I
DON'T OR SEVENTEEN.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE ROOMS
PERCY AT MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED NATURAL RESOURCES.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SEVEN BY MR MCCARTY
MOTIONS TO PASS AS MANAGER OF
CORPORATIONS I DON'T OR TWENTY
TO AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY TWO BY
MISTER DALI MOTIONS TO PASS AS A
MAJOR APPROPRIATIONS.
I DON'T KNOW TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR MISS REYES
MOTIONS TO PASS.
I REMEMBER THIRTY TWO AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT MINISTER
CHOSE MOSES TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY MY RESTRICT THEIR EMOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED HUMAN
SERVICES.
I NUMBER THIRTY SIX A. B. THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT BY MISTER TURN
THE MUCH IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. O'DONNELL BY FOR DONAL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE KALRA. CULVER I
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH STEINORTH I WERE
THURMOND THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE THE CONSENT CALENDAR SIX
VOTES.
IT HAS BEEN APPROVED. MOVEON DO.
.
MISTER MURATSUCHI I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE FILE NUMBERS HERE.
MR WITH VIOLENT OVER THIRTY.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY EIGHT OWING.
DO WE DO WE HAVE A MOTION THAT
STUDENT AND. WE DID HAVE A
MOTION SO LET'S.
DOCTOR WEIR MOVES MISTER CURRENT
SECONDS THIS CALL THAT ROLE
AGAIN PLEASE.
THAT IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR BUT
I READ EARLIER.
O'DONNELL I O'DONNELL AYE KILEY
KILEY AYE KALRA.
OUR AYE MCCARTY STEINORTH
STEINORTH AYE THURMAN THURMOND
AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
FAMILY.
THE BILL IS THE PARTICULAR SIX
WHAT'S IT IS OUT.
THEY GO MOVE TO A FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
.
THIRTY WHICH IS TWENTY EIGHT OO
EIGHT MINISTER MURATSUCHI.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
PROBLEM HERE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FROM LARGE URBAN
DISTRICTS LIKE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED OAKLAND SACRAMENTO SAN
DIEGO.
THE SUBURBAN DISTRICTS
TO RULE DISTRICTS THEY'RE ALL
SAYING THE SAME THING.
WHICH SAYS THAT DESPITE
SIGNIFICANT SCHOOL FUNDING
RESTORATION THAT WE'VE
ACCOMPLISHED IN RECENT YEARS.
THOSE FUNDING INCREASES ARE NOT
KEEPING PACE
WHAT THE INCREASES IN FIXED
COSTS THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
FACING IN UPCOMING YEARS.
WE ARE PROPOSING A SOLUTION AB
TWENTY EIGHT AWAY.
A SOLUTION BUT I'D BEEN WORKING
ON WITH THE EDUCATION COALITION
AND THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT IS
PROPOSING LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA BASE GRANT.
FUNDING TARGETS.
THAT WILL MAINTAIN THE EXISTING
FORMULA.
THIS BILL WILL A STABS FUNDING
TARGETS TO PROVIDE FULL AND FAIR
FUNDING FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY LIVE.
THESE FUNNY TARGETS ARE SIMILAR
TO THOSE CONTAINED IN THE
ORIGINAL LCF BATH.
WELL WE PASSED THE L. CFF IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WE PASSED IT
WITH FUNDING TARGETS TO GET THE
STATE BACK TO PRE RECESSION
FUNDING LEVELS. BY TWENTY
TWENTY.
NOW THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING TO REACH THE FULL
FUNDING TARGET TWO YEARS EARLY.
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE ASKING WHAT'S NEXT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT IS THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION.
BY PROVIDING ASPIRATIONAL
FUNDING TARGETS TO GET THE STATE
TO AT LEAST THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING WE ARE
MAKING A STATEMENT THAT K.
THROUGH TWELVE FUNDING. IS AND
SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE OUR
STATE'S TOP PROJECT BUDGET
PRIORITY.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OR A TO
SUPPORTED BY OUR PARENTS OUR
TEACHERS OR ADMINISTRATORS ARE
SCHOOL BOARDS AND. OUR STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TOM TILLOTSON.
AND RULE DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE I ASK YOU TO JOIN THIS
GROWING COALITION BY SUPPORTING
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH EIGHT. I'M
HONORED TO HAVE WITH ME THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION FOR THE
STATE PTA LEAH TARA.
AS WELL AS SO ALSO REPRESENTING
THE REDONDO BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT A LONG TIME PTA
ACTIVIST I NEED TO AFRICA.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
CALPERS THE PTA WHICH REPRESENTS
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS
AS A CO SPONSOR AT EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHT OH WAIT. THIS BILL
ADDRESSES ONE OF OUR KEY
ADVOCACY GOALS.
IMPROVING EDUCATION FUNDING FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON EIGHTY TWO EIGHT AWAY.
I'M A PARENT OF FOUR KIDS MY
YOUNGEST DAUGHTER SCARLETT IS IN
THE EIGHTH GRADE.
OVER THE YEARS ARE RAISING MY
CHILDREN THEY'VE ALL ATTENDED
SCHOOLS PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALTERING THEIR
CLASSROOMS I'VE SEEN THE CUTS TO
EDUCATION FUNDING IMPACT
CLASSROOMS.
I WISH I COULD SAY THIS IS ONLY
A PROBLEM MY COMMUNITY. BUT AS A
P. T. LEADER I'VE HEARD HORROR
STORIES FROM MY FELLOW PTA
VOLUNTEERS AT THE IMPACT THESE
EDUCATION FUNDING CUTS HAVE.
CROSS THE STATE.
STORIES OF CHILDREN NOT HAVING
DUST SISSETON. AND IN CLASSROOMS
IT WAS FORCED TO PUT OUT WHICH
LISTS FOR BASIC SUPPLIES LIKE
KLEENEX AND PENCILS.
TEACHERS.
A SEWING CLASS WITH BROKEN
SEWING MACHINES AND NO FUNDS TO
FIX THEM.
BROKEN AND DANGEROUS P.
EQUIPMENT.
AND SCIENCE LABS THE ADEQUATE
SUPPLIES.
IN FACT OUR HIGH SCHOOL PTA HOW
TO RAISE MONEY FOR BIOLOGY
SUPPLIES WE LITERALLY HAD TO
FUNDRAISE FOR EYEBALLS.
AND DISPOSABLE WAS FRIDAY
SECTION LAB IT'S FUNNY BUT IT'S
NOT FUNNY WHEN THE TEACHER CALLS
AND SAYS CAN THE PTA PLEASE
HELP.
LIKE ALL PARENTS AYE ONE EIGHTH
GRADER TO GET THE BEST EDUCATION
SHE CAN. WITH THE CURRENT LEVEL
OF PER PUPIL FUNDING IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE NEAR THE
BOTTOM IN THE NATION.
AS A PARENT BY THIS
UNACCEPTABLE.
AB TWENTY OH EIGHT TEN TWENTY
EIGHT NO EIGHT CAN BRING MORE
MONEY INTO OUR SCHOOLS. EFFORT
CANBRING US UP TO THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE OF PER PUPIL FUNDING.
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE THAT AT
LEAST.
I'M EXCITED TO SEE SOLUTION I
CAN HELP EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE STATE.
I BELIEVE IN PUBLIC EDUCATION.
ALL MY CHILDREN ATTENDED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
I VOLUNTEER PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
MY SEATS ABOUT TIMES BUT I'M
REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING
SOME BETTER TIME TO THE PASSAGE
OF AB TWO EIGHT OH EIGHT.
SO ONCE MORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT IT SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THINK.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
A PENNY THE AVERAGE CRIME THE
PRESIDING OFFICER FOR ALL SCHOOL
BOARD REDONDO BEACH.
THE HEART OF THE LC FF
CHALLENGES THE INADEQUACY OF THE
BASE FUNDING.
UNDER CURRENT CONDITIONS
DISTRICTS WITH HIGHER
PERCENTAGES OF KIDS OF POVERTY
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
FOSTER YOUTH AND UP WITH MORE
OVERALL FUNDS TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME THEY
STRUGGLED TO KEEP THE BASIC
FUNCTIONS OF THE DISTRICT
RUNNING FOR THE SAME FOR ALL THE
KIDS INADEQUATE BASE FUNDING
CREATES PRESSURE FOR SUCH
DISTRICTS.
TO FIND MORE WAYS TO UTILIZE A
TARGETED DOLLARS FOR THE BENEFIT
OF ALL CHILDREN IT DEFEATS THE
VERY PURPOSE. OF THE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES THEY GET.
THE FUNDING DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
REDONDO BEACH AND NEIGHBORING
COMMUNITIES ARE OPT UP TO AND
OVER TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
STUDENT.
THAT MAKES A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF DIFFERENCE.
THE BASE FUNDING IN L. L. C. F.
F..
SHOULD BE THE NECESSARY AMOUNT
OF FUNDING TO ENSURE A DECENT
EDUCATION FOR ALL OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS STUDENTS.
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP IN THE
COMMITMENT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE PROTECT OUR FUTURE BY
INVESTING IN THE LC FF BASED SO
THAT IT ADEQUATELY SUPPORTS
EXCELLENT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS.
AND ENABLES CORRESPONDING GROWTH
IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL AND
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDS TO
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
THE STUDENTS.
THAT ARE IN POVERTY ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS. AND FOSTER
YOU.
I WANT TO LEAVE YOU WITH TWO
THOUGHTS.
ONE WE ARE EDUCATING THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE GOING TO BE RUNNING
THIS COUNTRY IN A FEW YEARS.
HEALTHY FF AS A MECHANISM WE USE
TO DECIDE HOW MUCH DISCRETIONARY
DOLLARS ARE DISTRICTS RECEIVE IN
THE STATE IT IS THE WAY WE
DIVIDE THE PIE UP IT DOES NOT
INCREASE APART SO PLEASE
INCREASE OUR PIE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER BAKER THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS THE CFD AS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF TWENTY EIGHT AWAY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ANDREA FOLLOW THE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ALSO CO
SPONSORED RICHER SUPPORT.
THE CHAIRMAN JEFF ROSTRUM
RESIGNED THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
STEVE WARD WITH THE CLOVIS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG
SUPPORT.
LEILANI I CANNOT ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AN AVID IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DALY EATEN SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
BRENT WHEN UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR SECOND
DISTRICT PTA IN SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON NANCY LA CASA
NINE REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FUNDING COALITION MINUTES
FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIND JACKSON WITH
SENATOR UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ROBERT PIERCE ALCOVE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT.
INDICATE WATCH ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
DIANA MAC DONALD PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PTA WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THINK YOU.
KATHY RAVEN THIRTY SECOND
DISTRICT PTA IN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN MOTHER OF THREE PTA
MEMBER IN CHULA VISTA AND SPORT.
MICHAEL MORGAN DIRECTOR OF
EDUCATION THIRTY THIRD DISTRICT
PTA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GENEVA MORENO ORCHARD SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU GET ALL ITS
SUPERINTENDENT ORCHARD SCHOOL
DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT.
ERNIE SILVER FOR SAITEK IN
SUPPORT.
NEVER BROWN TO BE HAVE A STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JEFF TALK ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS SINCE.
MARK OUR WRISTS AND WOOD ALSO A
CO SPONSOR THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
TO STRONG SUPPORT.
TO SPAFFORD ON BEHALF OF CLOSE
UNIFIED SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL
PLAN AREA AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE ANGELA REED
ON BEHALF OF AS A PARTICULAR
MINERAL THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SO.
SARAH ROGERS THE CASBAH IN
SUPPORT.
MARTHA ZERO GOES IDEAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
VICKI ROMMEL'S HARRIS WITH
ADVANCING PUBLIC CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
DILLER STRAND FLORES CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION.
SENIOR OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK AMONG JUST MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT HOME.
SOME MIGHT SEE THIS IS
ASPIRATIONAL PROBABLY THIS MAYBE
EVEN CEREMONY A LITTLE BIT OF
THAT TOO BUT I ALSO THINK IT. IT
SETS A PARADIGM GOING FORWARD.
WITH THEIR. HAVE FUNDING IN OUR
GOALS ASSOCIATED WITH IT.
.
THIS STRUCTURE ASSOCIATE LCF
HAVE THAT HAPPENS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IS VERY IMPORTANT. I THINK
GOING FORWARD IT'S NOT
SACRAMENTO CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA WE TRIED THAT IT DID NOT
CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP NOW
WE'RE TRYING ANOTHER WAY. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE SEE THIS WAY
THROUGH. AND VERY IMPORTANT WE
HAVE THIS BILL TODAY BEFORE US
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
NEW GOVERNOR.
AND WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU KNOW
UNDER TWENTY LEGISLATORS WHO ON
THE LEGISLATURE WARS THEY WANT
TO CREATE THEIR OWN CATEGORICAL
WELL HUNDRED NINETEEN AND WE ONE
OF THEM. BUT DOWN THAT WANT TO
CREATE YOUR OWN CATEGORICAL
PROGRAM NEXT YEAR. AND WE NEED
TO RESIST THAT WE NEED TO SEE
THIS THROUGH WE NEED TO GIVE THE
LOCALS CONTROL.
WE NEED TO IVE THEM THE TOOLS
FUNDING THE RESOURCES THE
ABILITY TO DESIGN THE PROGRAMS
THEY NEED.
AT THEIR LOCAL LEVEL WE HEARD A
MANY BILLS TODAY AND MANY OF THE
SPEAKING TO DIFFERENT PARTS OF
OUR COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA. AND
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA BECAUSE
WE ARE A VERY DIVERSE STATE. IN
WHO WE ARE AND AND THAT'S WHAT
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULAS MEANT TO ADDRESS
CERTAINLY THAT BUT ALSO YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE BASE THE BASE
IS VERY IMPORTANT WE RAISE THE
BASE.
IT'S AND I YOU KNOW A FREE AN
ADEQUATE EDUCATION FOR EVERYONE.
IN MY WORRIES THAT SOMEDAY WE
MAY SEE A LAWSUIT ALMOST THE
RIVER A REVERSE SERRANO THE
PRIEST RIGHT THAT SOME STUDENTS
ARE THE BASES A HIGH ENOUGH FOR
THEM.
TO GET ADDED ADEQUATE EDUCATION
SO WE DO NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO THAT BASE.
AS WELL SO I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THAT FORWARD AS WELL
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTER KILEY.
I GOT HIM SOME ARE SUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON.
YEAH ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE.
THE LANDMARK GUY GETTING DOWN
TO FACTS STUDY.
THAT WAS COMMISSIONED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT A DECADE
AGO.
UNDER GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
OUTSOURCING YES RIGHT. YEAH JUST
A LITTLE BACKGROUND FOR THOSE
WHO ARE FAMILIAR I IT WAS A
RESEARCH PROJECT OF MORE THAN I.
TWENTY STUDIES IS I TO PROVIDE
CITIZENS WILL COMPREHENSIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE STATUS OF
THIS. STATE SCHOOL FINANCE AND
GOVERNMENT SYSTEMS.
OVER EIGHTEEN MONTH PERIOD IT
BROUGHT TOGETHER AN
EXTRAORDINARY ARRAY OF SCHOLARS
FROM THIRTY TWO INSTITUTIONS
WITH DIVERSE EXPERTISE AND AWFUL
POLICY ROUNDABOUT ORIENTATIONS
IT REPRESENTS AN UNPRECEDENTED
ATTEMPT. TO SYNTHESIZE WHAT WE
KNOW AS A BASIS FOR COMMITTING
THE NECESSARY PUBLIC
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE
SHOULD DO. AND DIE SO PRETTY ARE
FAR REACHING EFFORT COMMISSIONED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION EXCELLENCE
AND. SOME OF THE.
.
THE FINDINGS.
WERE PRETTY INTERESTING I
HERE'S ONE OF THAT MORE MONEY IN
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS UNLIKELY
TO UP TO FOR MAGICALLY IMPROVE
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT TO MEET
EXPECTATIONS UNLESS ACCOMPANIED.
BY SIGNIFICANT SYSTEMIC REFORMS.
COST ESTIMATES FOR IMPROVING
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT ARE ONLY
MEANINGFUL WHEN VIEWED IN
CONNECTION WITH OTHER REFORMS.
S. ASSIST THAT TIME YOU KNOW
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN WE'VE
INCREASED THE ANNUAL EDUCATION
BUDGET BY.
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT I CAN YOU IDENTIFY THE SIX
SYSTEMIC SIGNIFICANT SYSTEMIC
REFORMS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
WELL I THINK.
.
WE JUST HAD A BUDGET HEARING.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FUNDING AND.
.
WE HAD TESTIMONY FROM.
SUPERINTENDENTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
INDICATING THAT THAT THERE HAVE
BEEN SIGNIFICANT
PROVE MEN'S AND STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
WELL WHEN YOU LOOK AT.
.
THE GRADUATION RATES THE A
THROUGH G. COMPLETION RATES
THE.
SUSPENSION RATES.
THE DROPOUT RATES AND SO.
CLEARLY YOU KNOW.
WE CAN'T JUST THROW MONEY AT A
PROBLEM AND EXPECT TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING BUT.
CLEARLY.
MONEY DOES MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
AND.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN TELL THAT TO
ANY.
PARENTS WHO IS SEEING THEIR. WHO
HAS SEEN THEIR CLASS SIZES
INCREASE AND YOU'RE HAVING TO?
DO FUNDRAISING FOR BASIC SCHOOL
SUPPLIES WHEN THERE IS AN
ADEQUATE FUNDING AND SO. WHILE
YOU KNOW I.
RECOGNIZE YOUR POINT THAT.
.
THAT MONEY DOESN'T SOLVE ALL
PROBLEMS
THEY CLEARLY. GOES A LONG WAY
STATE AND IF I MAY INTERJECT
HERE I'M AN EXPERT ON SCHOOL BUS
SAFETY AS WELL SCHOOL FINENESS
ON IMPACT.
AND
I HAVE TWO KIDS I HAVE A SEVENTH
GRADER IN NINTH GRADE YOU WANT
THEM AND SEAT BELTS WHERE HE AND
I. I HAD MY MY OLDEST WENT
THROUGH CLASS SIZE REDUCTION.
IN MY US DID NOT AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S AN IMPACT EVEN TODAY IN
THEIR PERFORMANCE.
I I REALLY TRULY BELIEVE THAT
AND THE IN AND AND AND THAT HAS
IMPACTED THEIR ACADEMIC ABILITY
DAY.
IT BUT I ALSO WANT MY KIDS TO
FIELD TRIPS.
I ALSO WANT THEM TO MORE MUSIC
CLASSES. AYE I WANT THEM TO HAVE
AN ENRICHING EXPERIENCE IT ISN'T
ALWAYS ABOUT ACHIEVEMENT BUT ITS
FULFILLMENT WHICH LEADS TO
ACHIEVEMENT OFTEN I THINK.
AND EIGHT IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
QUANTITATIVE BUT IT'S OFTEN THE
QUALITATIVE EXPERIENCE
IN A CHILD'S SCHOOL THAT MAKES
THEM WANT TO COME BACK THAT
ENGAGED IN THAT HELP SINCE
SEAT AS A HUMAN BEING.
IT ISN'T ALL ABOUT THAT TEST
SCORES PART OF THAT FOR SURE BUT
IT ISN'T ONLY ABOUT THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I WAS
UNAWARE OF THE BREADTH OF YOUR
EXPERTISE. AND I AM MORE I HAVE
MORE COMING.
BUT I AND I YOU KNOW I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH WITH WITH A LOT OF
THAT.
BUT IF WE SPEND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS MORE PER YEAR AND BY THE
OBJECTIVE MEASURE.
THE NEEDLE HASN'T MOVED I THINK
THAT THE PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY IT
WAS PREDICTED OVER TEN YEARS AGO
IN THIS STUDY THAT JUST PUTTING
IN MORE MONEY. WITHOUT SYSTEMIC
REFORM.
ISN'T GONNA LEAD TO ANY
PROGRESS AND IT'S ESPECIALLY I
THINK.
DISCOURAGING WHEN WE SEE GREAT
EXAMPLES OF SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE DOING THINGS
RIGHT AND GETTING GREAT RESULTS.
AND WAS THE OTHER JURISDICTIONS
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES THAT
HAVE MADE SYSTEMIC REFORMS THAT
HAVE LIFTED ALL STUDENTS.
IN MEANINGFUL WAYS AND
BIOMETRICS THAT MISTER O'DONNELL
REFERRED TO.
I THINK THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
HAVE.
LEGISLATE ASPIRATION ONLY.
THAT'S FINE BUT THE SUBSTANCE
OF THOSE ASPIRATION SHOULD BE
STUDENT.
ACHIEVEMENT IN LIFE SUCCESS NOT
JUST FUNDING AND FORGET IT YOU
KNOW MARK MARK OUT HOW DO WE GET
TO HAVE THE BEST SCHOOLS IN THE
COUNTRY.
SURE INCREASE FUNDING MIGHT BE
A PART OF THAT.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE END GOAL AND
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
HOW INCREASINGLY A LOT OF THE
MONEY ISN'T GOING TOWARD THE
CLASSROOM WE HAVE DISTRICTS
THEY'RE HAVING TO CUT BACK ON
THINGS LIKE TEACHER SALARIES
BECAUSE SUCH A BIG PART OF THEIR
BUDGET. IS A POST RETIREMENT.
OBLIGATIONS AND WE'RE NOT DOING
A LOT AT TO ADDRESS THAT SO.
I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I.
WHEN WE. THINK ABOUT WHERE WE'RE
GOING AS A STATE. THIS
CONVERSATION WHAT THE RIGHT
FUNDING LEVEL SHOULD BE
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE PART OF
THE CONVERSATION BUT IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO SUPPORT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TODAY WHEN I
SEE. THE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT
THINGS WE NEED TO DO
CONSISTENTLY BEING NEGLECTED BY
THIS COMMITTEE SO I THANK YOU
FOR BRING THIS CORDON
CONTRIBUTED COMPENSATE.
THANK YOU NAY OBSERVED YOU TO
THINK ABOUT THE MISTER
COLLEAGUES I THINK WE SURE YOU
SEE SUPPORTING AN INCREASE IN
FUNDING YES THAT'S PART OF IT I
ALSO THINK. WHAT HE'S SAYING
HERE'S LOCAL CONTROL IS BEST I
THINK THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
GOING FORWARD IN THE FOUR YEARS?
AND LET'S ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT
GOING BACK.
I DURING THE RECEPTION ARE
RECESSION HOW MUCH DO WE GET IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
EDUCATION FUNDING WENT WAY DOWN.
WERE NOW COMING BACK IN JUST
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
PURCHASING POWER SOURCE STILL
DOWN. AND TO EDUCATE KIDS IT
TAKES MONEY. IT TAKES STAFF IT
TAKES FACILITIES IT TAKES
OPERATIONS PURSE.
SO IT IS NOT A CHEAP VENTURE.
AND AND IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
YOU KNOW. I JUST THINK MY OWN
KIDS AND AND YOU'LL YOU'LL GET
THEIR KILEY AND I'M CONFIDENT
THAT I'M SURE I'M GONNA SEND
YOUR KID YOUR KIDS THE SCHOOL
ALL WE ASK YOU FOR ON THE
LARGEST.
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ONE LARGER CLASS SIZES FOR MY
CHILD.
CONFIDENT THAT WHEN YOU WALK
YOUR LITTLE KINDERGARTENERS AND
THEY'RE GONNA SAY THIS CLASS
SIZES
IT IS TOO SMALL WE WANT MORE
KIDS. SUBJECT JUST YOU KNOW.
BE OPEN MINDED I WOULD ONLY ASK.
DOCTOR THANK YOU OF AND I'M NOT
WILL DECLARE MYSELF AN EXPERT ON
OWN FINANCES SCHOOLS.
BUT I DO WANNA AND THEN I
APPRECIATE MR KYLIE'S COMMENTS
รณ I THINK THOSE ARE ARE ARE
ALWAYS BALLOT IN IMPORTANT
CONCERNS.
AND PROBABLY NO ONE THE BANGS
HARDER THAN I DO ABOUT STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT HERE AT THIS AT THIS
HOUSE. AND I NEED FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
BUT I'VE ALSO ALWAYS TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
PROFESSION OF TEACHING
HAS TO BE A PROFESSION OF
DIGNITY AND IT'S MATCHED BY THE
RESOURCES SOMETIMES THAT WE PUT
INTO IT. THAT THE VALUE OF WHAT
WE BELIEVE AND IS OFTEN
REFLECTED IN WHERE WE SPEND OUR
MONEY.
AND HOW WE SPEND OUR MONEY AND
IF WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE OF SIGNIFICANT.
THAT THE EDUCATION THEY GET WILL
BASICALLY UP ENHANCE THEIR LIVES
THEN WE HAVE TO INVEST IN IT
THAT IS A ME WHENEVER HOLDEN
ACCOUNTABLE. AND IN FACT I THINK
THE MORE WE GIVE THE MORE
BUT LE BUT IT ALSO HELPS US TO
DEVELOP THE KIND OF EDUCATIONAL
SETTING. IT HELPS TO DEVELOP
THOUGH THE TEACHING STAFF THAT
WE WANT THAT WE TALK ABOUT
CONSTANTLY ABOUT HAVING OUR
TEACHERS IS REALLY THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL INFLUENCE
AND CHANGE THE LIVES OF OUR
CHILDREN EVERY DAY. ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE CRITICAL
WELL IF FOR TEACHERS TO BE ABLE
TO RELATE TO STUDENTS AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE THEY'RE COMING
FROM. A TEACHER HAS TREMENDOUS
POWER.
TREMENDOUS POWER
CHANGE THE LIVES OF CHILDREN FOR
THEIR WHOLE LIFE.
AND HOW TO BE ABLE TO BE IN A
CLASSROOM WHERE YOU REALLY GET A
CHANCE TO TALK TO AND TO MEET
WITH STUDENTS. ARE AND TRANSFORM
THEM.
INTO A RESPONSIBLE CITIZENS AS
A RESULT OF YOUR ABILITY TO CARE
FOR THEM AND TO MEET WITH THEM
ON A ONE ON ONE BASIS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA HAD SOME OF THE BEST
OF SCHOOL SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD
AND WE STILL DO IT WITH OUR OUR
K. TWELVE IN OUR POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS.
WE HAVE LOST OUR IT BECAUSE WE
HAVE LOST THAT WE'VE TAKEN OUR
EYE OFF OF WHAT WE NEED TO BE
FOCUSED ON. AND WE SEE THE
IMPACT OF THAT.
THROUGHOUT OUR SOCIETY I MEAN
INCREASE IN JUVENILE HALL THE
INCREASE IN PRISONS THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS AND WE SEE WHAT
HAPPENS IS A DIRECT RESULT
SOMETIMES.
OF OUR INABILITY TO HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE SCHOOL SYSTEM MORE
TEACHERS TO REALLY MEET AND MEET
THE NEEDS OF THOSE STUDENTS OUT
OF THERE. AND SO I THINK WE'LL
SEE A LOT OF POSITIVES THAT COME
FROM WITH FACING TEACHER
SHORTAGES WHEN I WAS AT THE
UNIVERSITY WAS HARD TO TALK TO A
PERSON ABOUT GOING INTO
EDUCATION. WHEN THEY DIDN'T
THINK THAT IT WAS GOING TO NOT
ONLY JUST BE A PRODUCTIVE
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM. BUT ONE
THAT PUTS A WOOD MAY LIVE IN
POVERTY MOST OF THEIR LIVES A IN
TRYING TO JUST SIMPLY KEEP THE
PROFESSION THAT WAS THERE.
AND THE IDEA OF THE PROFESSION
OF TEACHING BECAUSE I HAD
TEACHERS WHO I THOUGHT WERE
MILLIONAIRES AND THEY WORK BUT
THEY LOOK LIKE IN THE ACT LIKE
IT AND THEY HAVE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM. THAT WE
SOMETIMES DON'T HAVE AVAILABLE
TO TEACHERS TODAY AND SO I YOU
KNOW THIS IS INVESTMENT IT'S
IT'S LIKE A WISH LIST WE
UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S A. THAT WE
MAY NOT GET THERE. BUT I ALWAYS
BELIEVE IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE GOING ANY ROLE TO TAKE
YOU THERE. AND WE DO KNOW WHERE
WE WANT TO GO IN THIS IS A PATH
THAT'S GOING TO LEAD US THERE.
AND IT DOESN'T DOESN'T RELIEVE
US OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE KNOW
THAT MONEY IS NOT ALWAYS THE
ANSWER TO EVERYTHING. BUT IT CAN
GIVE US THE RESOURCES AND THE
SUPPORT TO ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS
THIS THE YEAR. SOME GRATEFUL
THAT YOU BROUGHT THIS FORWARD
BECAUSE SURELY WE'VE DONE THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
WITH THEIR NOW THE QUESTION IS
NOT JUST TO STAY THERE BUT WHERE
DO WE GO FROM THERE. AND HOW DO
WE CONTINUE TO EXPAND THAT HOW
DO WE CONTINUE TO BRING US
THROUGH SCHOOLS UP TO WHERE THEY
NEEDTO BE. AT A LIKE TO BE IN
THE FORTIES.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE ARE YOU
KNOW I WAS ALWAYS SAY WHEN WE
BELOW MISSISSIPPI ALABAMA WE IN
TROUBLE INSULT. YOU KNOW SO I
DON'T I DON'T WANT MY SCHOOLS IS
TO BE THERE BECAUSE I WHEN I
WENT TO SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA. WE
WERE IN THE TOP TEN. IN TERMS OF
SCHOOLS IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
AND AND OUR TEACHERS HAD DIGNITY
AND PRIDE ABOUT THEIR PROFESSION
Y. BECAUSE A PROFESSION AND THE
AND THE STATE HAD PRIDE IN THEM.
AND SO I I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
ASPIRATIONAL GOAL I THINK IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARD AND WORK HARD
BECAUSE IT TAKES ALL OF THIS TO
CREATE THE KIND OF EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. THAT I WANT TO BE PROUD
OF THAT EVERYBODY WANTS TO BE
PROUD OF AND THAT I KIDS DESERVE
SO THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND I
AND I LOOKED UP MOVE THE.
I THINK WE'VE ALREADY HAD A
MOTIONS OF THIS WE HAVEN'T IF
NOT THEN I MOVE. THIS BILL.
THE MOVED AND SECONDED.
.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAKE CLOTHES
THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE AYE
WEBER AYE.
FOR VOTE THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU YOU HAVE
ONE OTHER MISTER MURATSUCHI.
.
WHICH IS.
EIGHTY IS FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN.
WHILE I'M OVER THIRTY ONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
A FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND YOUR
EXCELLENT CHIEF OF STAFF FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK. ON THIS.
THE BILL I EXCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AS OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS.
WHICH.
IN SUMMARY I WILL HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PASSED REGULATION
TO ONE CONDUCTED EVALUATION OF
THE INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT
PLANS AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SEE WERE AT.
TO RECOMMEND TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WHETHER ONE OR MORE PESTICIDES
SHOULD BE BANNED.
AND THREE TO AUTHORIZE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PASSED.
A REGULATION TO CONSULT WTH
OTHER STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES
STAKEHOLDERS AND EXPERTS IN
DEVELOPING SUCH RECOMMENDATIONS.
THIS A BILL CAME TO MY ATTENTION
WHEN MY DAUGHTER GOING TO ONE OF
MY LOCAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS I WAS
FACING.
AN ISSUE INVOLVING.
TOXIC PESTICIDE OF BEING USED
AT HER SCHOOL OF FOLLOWING THAT
THERE WAS AN UPROAR AMONG
PARENTS AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW
I.
REALIZED THAT THAT THIS IS A
PART OF AN ONGOING EFFORT THAT'S
BEEN CONDUCTED FOR MANY YEARS TO
ADDRESS.
TOXIC CHEMICALS COMMONLY BE
BEING USED AT OUR SCHOOL GROUNDS
WHETHER IT'S. A ROUND UP WHETHER
IT'S PUMA TOXIN BUT THE LIST IS
LONG IT TOO LONG BUT WE ALL KNOW
THAT THERE IS A GROWING
SCIENTIFIC. CONSENSUS THAT
PESTICIDES
WELL BECAUSE HEALTH.
SIX SIGNIFICANT HEALTH PROBLEMS
PARTICULARLY FOR OUR CHILDREN
ACCORDING TO THE U. S.
ENVIRONMENT PROTECTION AGENCY
PESTICIDE EXPOSURE CAN CAUSE.
CANCER REPRODUCTIVE DISORDERS
DEVELOPMENTAL AND NEUROLOGICAL
DISORDERS.
AS WELL AS OTHER. ILLNESSES.
FURTHERMORE THE NATIONAL ACADEMY
OF SCIENCES REPORTS THAT
CHILDREN ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
CHEMICALS THAN ADULTS AND
ESTIMATES A FIFTY PERCENT. OF
LIFETIME PESTICIDE EXPOSURE
OCCURS DURING THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF LIFE.
MOST RECENTLY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION HAS CLASSIFIED LIKE
TO SAY.
COMMONLY KNOWN AS ROUNDUP AS A
LIKELY CARCINOGEN.
MORE MORE EVIDENCES IS GROWING
THAT PESTICIDES CAN BE DANGEROUS
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
THAT IS WHY I AM INTRODUCING
THIS BILL. TO.
CUT DOWN AND ULTIMATELY TO WORK
TOWARD BANNING OF THESE TOXIC.
CHEMICALS.
AT OUR SCHOOLS I AM PROUD TO BE
JOINED HERE TODAY BY THE TWO
WITNESSES. OF FIRST A.
GUADALUPE GARCIA.
GONZALEZ.
PARENT.
AND.
FOLLOWING WITH.
PEDIATRICIAN AND EXPERT ON THE
SUBJECT DR MICHELE PARA.
THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
ADDRESSING THIS IMPRIMATUR TODAY
MY NAME IS WHETHER GOOGLE NEWS I
AM A FARMWORKERS. AND A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE WITH
COALITION ADVOCATING FOR
PESTICIDE SAFETY. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY I AM A MOTHER
WORKING IN THE FIELD STRAINS NAY
BUT I TOOK FOR MY DAUGHTER.
TODAY I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX SEEN.
AS A MOTHER I AM WORRIED AND
UPSET TO KNOW OF VERSION OF SAID
TO KNOW THAT TOXIC CHEMICALS CAN
BE SPRAYED NEAR SCHOOL CHILDREN.
MY DAUGHTER WILL SOON BE.
ANSWERING THE PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM I WORRY ABOUT HER HEALTH
AND HER SAFETY AS A FIELD
DIRECTOR I ALREADY LIVE WITH THE
CONCERN OF PESTICIDES BEING
BROUGHT HOME. BUT TO KNOW THAT
MY DAUGHTER WILL BE ATTENDING A
SCHOOL WHERE CHEMICALS THEY
COURTESY.
IF.
ARE PART OF THE.
WHERE CHEMICALS LAKE?
LEPA THEATER FOR THE PART OF THE
IPM. PROGRAM IS SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE.
LIMITS HOWEVER MY DAUGHTER HER
NAME IS HOPE SHE'S FOUR YEARS
OLD SHE'S A SMART BEAUTIFUL
CARING CHILD THEIR ENERGY SHE
CARRIES IS CONTAGIOUS SHE LOVES
THE OUTDOORS ENJOYS VISITS TO
THE PARK. AND PLAY WITH THE
FAMILY DOG SHE MISSES ME WHEN
I'M NOT HOME MY TIME WITH THERE
IS VERY LIMITED.
BUT I AM HERE TODAY TO ENSURE
THAT MY DAUGHTER HAS A BETTER
FUTURE THERE ARE OTHER PARENTS
LIKE ME THAT WOULD DO ANYTHING
TO PROTECT THEIR CHILDREN. BUT
THEY CAN'T BE HERE TODAY TO
SHARE THEIR CONCERNS.
MY DAUGHTER IS LITERALLY MY HOPE
SHE IS MY ALL AS A MOTHER I ASK
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD YOU
BE OKAY WITH YOUR CHILD
ATTENDING A SCHOOL. FOR THIS
CHEMICAL IS BEING SPRAYED OR IS
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE IPM
PROGRAM. A SCHOOL IS SUPPOSED TO
BE A SAFE PLACE WHERE CHILDREN
LEARN AND PLAY BUT IS THERE
REALLY IF WE CONTINUE ALLOWING
USE OF PRIVACY TO IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN STYLE WITH
PARENTS AND FOR WORKING PARENTS
ON SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX I THINK
YOU.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
HI MY NAME IS OLGA MICHELLE PARA
ON THE VETERAN PEDIATRICIAN I'VE
BEEN PRACTICING FOR OVER. A
THIRTY SEVEN YEARS NEARLY FOUR
DECADES FRONTLINE I TAKE CARE OF
CHILDREN FOR A LIVING I'M ALSO
THAT YOU DIRECTOR OF GMO SIGNS
DOT ORG. AND CO AUTHOR OF THIS
BOOK WHAT'S MAKING OUR CHILDREN
SICK WHICH I'D LIKE TO OFFER
THIS COMMITTEE FOR A LITTLE
LIGHT READING IF THAT'S POSSIBLE
ON KIND OF A NEWBIE SO I DON'T
KNOW ALL THE RULES. BUT IT'S A
SIGNED COPY SO THERE YOU GO.
SO WHAT IS HAPPENED OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS OF MY
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AS I'VE SEEN
A DECLINE IN THE STATE OF OUR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH. I DON'T NEED
TO READ FROM THIS PAPER BECAUSE
THIS IS WHAT I DO FOR A LIVING.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR FROM AN
AND DELIGHTS YOU GET SOME
STATISTICS BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
WE LOVE STATS AND I'M ALL ABOUT
THE SCIENCE NO VOODOO NO FROU
FROU. EVEN THOUGH I'M FROM MARIN
COUNTY ALL JUST HAVE YOU KNOW.
SO LET ME GIVE YOU SOME
STATISTICS ONE INTO AMERICAN
CHILDREN NOW HAS A CHRONIC
DISORDER. FORTY PERCENT OF
AMERICAN CHILDREN HAVE FOOD
ALLERGIES AND YOU KNOW THAT FROM
THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS ARE NOW
REQUIRED TO CARRY AT THE PENS
FOR LIFE THREATENING ALLERGIES.
ONE OUT OF EIGHT CHILDRENNOW
HAS ASTHMA BETTER OF WHITE ONE
OUT OF SIX AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN DID DATA IS ALL OVER
THE PLACE ON THE TEAM KNOW
CHILDREN ALL HAVE YOU KNOW BUT
IT'S ABOUT ONE IN SIX.
WHAT SHOULD CONCERNED THIS
COMMITTEE WILL CONCERNS ALL OF
US AND ALSO THIS BRAVE MOM WHO'S
SPEAKING IT ARE NEUROCOGNITIVE
DISORDERS THOSE A FUNCTION OF
LEARNING? YOU SHOULD BE SHOCKED
TO KNOW THAT ONE OF FORTY THREE
BOYS AND ONE SIXTY CHILDREN IS
NOW DIAGNOSIS AUTISTIC.
SPECTRUM DISORDER FROM CDC
TWENTY SIXTEEN HOWEVER
ANECDOTALLY I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THAT NUMBER HAS RISEN IN THE
PAST YEARS TO WANTED THIRTY FOUR
BOYS.
YOU KNOW AS AN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THE IMPACT ON SCHOOL
HAVING CHILDREN ON THE SPECTRUM
AND THE DISRUPTION AND THE COSTS
THAT IT TAKES EDUCATE THEM IS
PROFOUND.
WE NOW KNOW THAT THESE CHILDREN
HAVE BEEN EXPOSED TO A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF PESTICIDES
I HAVE FOCUSED MY CAREER FOR THE
PAST TWELVE YEARS LOOKING AT
LIKE THE STATE. THE MAIN
INGREDIENT IN ROUNDUP AND THAT
WHAT BROUGHT FORTH THIS BOOK
WITH MY BILLION CO AUTHOR VINCE
AND ADAMS MEDICAL ANTHROPOLOGIST
A PROFESSOR AT UCSF. AND WE
PRODUCE THIS BOOK
SO WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT BY
ABOUT ABOUT CHILDREN AND LIFE
ASSUME WOULD TELL YOU WHAT IT
DOES VERY BRIEFLY. YOU ALREADY
HEARD THAT IT'S A CARCINOGEN
CLASS TO A AYE HUMANS IT'S A
CARCINOGEN IN ANIMALS IT'S ALSO
WHAT IT DOES IT'S AN ANTIBIOTICS
PLEASE SUMMARIZE SO I'M GOING TO
SUMMARIZE BECAUSE I'M FROM NEW
YORK A SPEAK QUICKLY. I CHILDREN
ARE NOT MANY ADULTS THEY TAKE UP
MORE PESTICIDES QUICKER THAN
ADULTS.
PESTICIDE BANNING HAS DONE IN
IRVINE SUCCESSFUL SUCCESSFULLY
MY HOME STATE YOU ARE. IN
CONNECTICUT WILL GO TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
TONY TO CAROL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK THE
AUTHORS TO ANYWHERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I'M DIANE EVERYDAY WERE
FRATERNAL ORGANIZATION ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OF CHAPTERS.
FOCUSING ON AGRICULTURE AND
ENVIRONMENT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT PESTICIDES
IN SCHOOLS THANK YOU NEXT A
PERSON.
BOB SAUNDERS CALIFORNIA GUILD I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND ALSO I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF BEEN EMORY AND
SUSAN ROBERTS EMORY WHOSE THIRD
GENERATION FARMER NIECE. WAS
BORN WITH.
HER INTESTINE THANK YOUNG TECH
OTTERSON.
YOUR COLLEGE STUDENT I'M HERE TO
REPRESENT ONE UP I'M A FARMER
AND I'VE HAD TO GIVE YOU A
LIVESTOCK LOSS BECAUSE IF
IMPROPER. PESTICIDE GUILIN
CLIENTS.
TWO I.
IN HERE TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA YELLED
UNDERSECRETARY.
AND THE KEY VERY MUCH PLEASE
SUPPORT DISPEL.
WILLIAM BURKE SMALL GANIC
SACRAMENTO STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I HAVE GARCIA COALITION
ADVOCATING FOR PASSED SITE
SAFETY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AND TO DO MORE AT THIS.
CHIEF GROW THEIR OWN LIVES OUT
OF MY SEAT.
YOU THE SYLLABUS I AM A FORMER
FORMER CHILD MIGRANT FORMER
CHILD. I AM ALSO. OPI FELLOW
WITH THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE NOW AS A
MEMBER OF THE COALITION ADVOCATE
PURPOSE AT SAFETY WHEREIN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PAUL TOWERS WITH PESTICIDE
ACTION NETWORK AND CALIFORNIANS
FOR PESTICIDE REFORM IN SUPPORT.
THREE MONTH THAT'S WHAT ACKERMAN
GIRLS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF BRAWL GARCIA FROM PORTABLE
CALIFORNIA AS A FORMER DAIRY
WORKER AND AS THE CURRENT.
CAN.
OUTREACH COORDINATOR FOR THE
COALITION ADVOCATING FOR US I
THINK YOU ARE ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TO LARA STRAND FLORIST HELPING
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
AIR BOX WITH THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT TO WITH
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED.
WILL HAPPILY REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING THE
AUTHORS AS BILL NEWS FOR EXACTLY
IT'S IMPORTANT DISCUSS.
LIKE.
LARA PARMI HALF OF THE PEST
CONTROL OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA
BASED ON THE AMENDMENTS AMOUNTS
OF BILLS AND PRINT WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO MOVE REMOVE OPPOSITION
AND ONE THING STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US AS WELL.
LARA PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WHERE DATA WITH WHAT YOU'VE JUST
HEARD THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
SENIOR OPPOSITION ICONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE SING NO COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE WE HAVE A MOTION.
THAT'S BEEN MOVED BY MISTER
KALRA.
SECOND I DR WEBER.
THE MOTION IS.
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY.
TOXICS COMMITTEE.
SO THAT IS THE MOTION YOU MAY
CLOSE QUICKLY I ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY KILEY AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS OUT FOR VOTES.
YOU'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO.
WHAT IS WITH?
WE'RE NOW GOING TO NEW MOVED TO
FILE A NUMBER FIVE.
IN THE NINETEEN FIFTY ONE BY
O'DONNELL.
LIKE
.
I.
THIS AB IN NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
I'M STRODE DONALD PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE WILL
INCREASE THE PATHWAY TO COLLEGE
BY ENSURING THAT ALL ELEVENTH
GRADE STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO A
REQUIRED ENTRANCE COLLEGE EXAM
FOR COLLEGE.
THIS IS ABOUT GETTING MORE KIDS
INTO COLLEGE.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS IN GRADES
THREE THROUGH EIGHTH AND
ELEVENTH.
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE.
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT TEST
STATE REQUIRED TEST FOR THOSE
GRADES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
COLLEGE AND CHURCH AND ENTRANCE
EXAM SUCH AS THE ACT OR THE ACT
THE SAT OR THE ACT. INSTEAD OF
THE STATE REQUIRED ASSESSMENT
FOR ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS THIS
IS ELEVENTH GRADE ONLY.
OVER THIRTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INCLUDING OAKLAND SAN JOSE
SACRAMENTO IN MY HOME DISTRICT
LONG BEACH ARE CURRENTLY
OFFERING THE SAT OR THE ACT
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY FOR FREE
IN AN EFFORT TO INCREASE.
THE COLLEGE ATTENDANCE RATE.
AND OPPORTUNITY FOR SURE.
AS A MIDDLE HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
HEAR MY REASONS FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL.
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
IS ATTACHED
IT IS NOT ASSESSMENT IS SIMPLY
ATTACHED.
THE SAT IS AN ASSESSMENT.
WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT A TEST
TELLS YOU WHERE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
ARE?
AND ASSESSMENT SHOWS YOU HOW TO
CLOSE THOSE ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
BEGINNING TODAY IN THE EIGHTH
GRADE STUDENTS CAN TAKE THE PSA
T..
WHICH STEEP WHICH TEACHERS CAN
USE TO ADDRESS GAPS IN STUDENT
LEARNING.
THE S. BACK WAS INTENDED TO BE
MORE USEFUL TO TEACHERS BUT IS
NOT THERE YET AFTER FOUR YEARS
THEY HAVEN'T COMPLETED THEIR
MISSION WERE WAITING.
THE SAT IS MEANINGFUL TO
STUDENTS THEY HAVE A STAKE IN
DOING WELL.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF TESTING AND GIVE STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS MORE TIME FOR
INSTRUCTION.
ELEVENTH GRADE IS A BUSY YEAR.
STUDENTS ARE NOT ONLY TAKING THE
RIVER THAT REQUIRED STATE TEST
BUT ALSO EIGHT P. AND COLLEGE
ENTRANCE EXAMS.
AND LET ME ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS
BILL.
WE'LL ACCOMMODATIONS BE REQUIRED
ABSOLUTELY THE ANSWER IS YES.
ACCOMMODATIONS WILL BE BASED ON
A STUDENT'S I EP OR FIVE OH FOR
PLAN.
BUT THEY WILL NOT BE IDENTICAL
TO ACCOMMODATIONS PROVIDED FOR
STUDENTS TAKING THE ASPECT.
SOME OF THE IT ACCOMODATIONS ARE
UNIQUE TO THE US BACK.
BECAUSE ITS A COMPUTER TEST
WHICH WILL NOT APPLY TO THE SAT
OR ACT BECAUSE AGAIN IT IS NOT.
A COMPUTER CHESS SO SOME OF
THOSE WILL BE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
ACCOMMODATIONS WILL BE EASIER TO
COORDINATE.
BECAUSE IT'S US IT'S THE TEST IS
CONDUCTED AT THE SCHOOL SITE.
THE REQUEST WILL BE HANDLED BY A
SCHOOL STAFF BY SCHOOL STAFF OR
COUNCIL RATHER THAN A PARENT
NAVIGATING.
THE PROCESS ALONG.
WILL BE OUT ALTERNATIVE
ASSESSMENTS BE ALIGNED TO OUR
STATE STANDARDS THAT HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE CONCERNS.
PRESENTED.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT.
I WANT TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT THERE IS NO ONE TEST NOT
EVEN THE ESPECTADOR THAT IS
COMPLETELY ALIGNED TO THE COMMON
CORE STANDARDS.
EACH OF THE FIFTEEN CONCOURSE
DATES MAY HAVE CHANGED OR ADDED
TO THE STANDARDS BUT THE S. BACK
AS THE SAME TEST.
FOR ALL PARTICIPATING STATES.
ANOTHER CONCERN.
ARE THE SCORES FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND ELS STUDENTS
INVALID FOR COLLEGE ADMISSIONS.
NO BECAUSE THE ACCOMMODATIONS
ARE WORKED OUT AND PLAN FOR
AHEAD OF TIME.
ANOTHER CONCERN.
DOES THE ACHIEVE REPORT THERE'S
A REPORT CALLED THE ACHIEVE
REPORT RECOMMEND AGAINST THIS
PROPOSAL.
ACHIEVE IS AFFILIATED WITH PARK
ANOTHER COMMON CORE TEST IT HAS
AVENGED VESTED INTERESTS OR THE
ACHIEVED TASK BE ACHIEVED.
REPORT.
WAS ASSOCIATE WITH A COMPANY
THAT GIVES ANOTHER.
TEST.
OR SO. A GROUP TO GET ANOTHER
TEST
IT ALSO NEGLECTED TO CITE
FAVORABLE STUDIES TOWARDS OTHER
TESTS.
ANOTHER CONCERN
CAN WE USE THE SAT FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY PURPOSES.
THERE IS DEFINITELY A WAY TO
ALIGN THE SAT WITH THE S. BACK
SCORES THROUGH CORDONED
CONCURRENT CONCORDANCE STUDIES.
WE CAN GET A SAT SCORE FOR EACH.
S. BACK PERFORMANCE LEVEL YES WE
CAN.
MEMBERS WHAT WE ARE DOING HERE
IS AUTHORIZED BY FEDERAL LAW IN
FACT A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES
INCLUDING CONNECTICUT. DELAWARE
ILLINOIS MAINE MICHIGAN HAVE
RECEIVED APPROVAL FROM THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ADMINISTER A COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAM IN PLACE OF THE STATE
ADOPTED TEST.
THERE MAY BE A RELUCTANCE FOR
THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
WAS ONE OF THE MAIN CONTRIBUTORS
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE S.
BACK BUT AGAIN.
THE ASPECT NEVER MATURED INTO
THE PRODUCT IT WAS DESIGNED TO
BE. WERE WAITING.
I ASKED THAT WE THINK ABOUT
WHAT'S GOOD FOR OUR STUDENTS
TODAY NOT LOYALTY TO SOMETHING
JUST BECAUSE WE HELPED CREATED.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY
ARE MISTER CHRIS STEIN HOUSE OUR
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE LONG BEACH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
GLORIA AGUILAR SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND MELISSA
BORDEAUX A SENIOR AT KENNEDY
HIGH SCHOOL IN SACRAMENTO NOT
TOO FAR AWAY FROM HERE. SO WE
HAVE.
AN EXTRA WITNESS TODAY BUT THEY
WERE GRANTED PERMISSION.
BECAUSE THEY CAME IN HERE.
WELL LET US LIVE.
AYE MR STEIN HAS ROUGHLY OUT OF
WHOEVER.
ONE OF YOU GO.
NOT FOR ME.
VICE CHAIRMAN OF KILEY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS HOW CAN YOU LIVE.
PRIVILEGED TO BE THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
OUT WE SERVE OVER FORTY THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN SEVENTY
SEVEN SCHOOLS RIGHT HERE IN THE
HEART OF SACRAMENTO.
WE'VE A SIGNIFICANTLY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS OVER SIXTY PERCENT OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE ON FREE OR
REDUCED LUNCH.
I WERE ALSO VERY DIVERSE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WITH FORTY THREE
LANGUAGES SPOKEN ON IN ANY OF
THOSE SEVENTY SEVEN SCHOOLS.
OUR GUIDING PRINCIPLE IS RATHER
SIMPLE AND IT STATES THAT WE ARE
TO GIVE EVERY STUDENT AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO GRADUATE WITH THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF POST
SECONDARY CHOICES.
FROM THE WIDEST ARRAY OF
OPTIONS.
THIS BILL THE PATHWAYS TO
COLLEGE ACT WILL HELP US ACHIEVE
THAT GUIDING PRINCIPLE BY
ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN
FULFILL. THE COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAM REQUIREMENTS THAT SO MANY
OF OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
HAVE AS PART OF THEIR
APPLICATION REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS WHY I SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION TO ENSURE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE ADMINISTERING THE SAT
OR OTHER COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM.
TO ALL ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS.
WANT TO SHARE SOME DATA THAT I
HOPE WILL SHED LIGHT ON THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND HOW
IT WILL HELP OUR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE OF GREATEST
NEED.
IN SACKS CITY CURRENTLY OF OUR
CURRENT OF ARE APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY NINE HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS.
ONLY FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
NINE.
OR ABOUT NINETEEN PERCENT.
HAD AN SAT OR ACT SCORE BY THE
END OF THEIR JUNIOR YEAR.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED HIGH SCHOOL
JUNIORS IN OUR DISTRICT.
OF THE STUDENTS ONLY FIFTY FIVE
OR TWO PERCENT HAD AN SAT OR ACT
SCORE PRIOR TO YESTERDAY.
MORE OVER WE HAVE TWELVE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY ONE HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS RIGHT NOW WHO ARE ON
TRACK TO MEET THE ATG. COLLEGE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA HOWEVER TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE OF THEM
WERE ABOUT TWENTY THREE PERCENT
DID NOT TAKE THE S. EIGHTEEN. OR
THE ACT BY DECEMBER OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
THIS IS A SIZEABLE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WERE ON TRACK FOR
COLLEGE BUT DID NOT TAKE A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM BY THE
MIDPOINT OF THEIR SENIOR YEAR.
OUR ELEVENTH GRADE COHORT
CONSIST OF ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AND AFTER FALL SEMESTER GRADES
ARE CALCULATED ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY OF THEM ARE
ON TRACK TO COMPLETE THE ATG
COURSE PATTERN. BUT ONLY THIRTY
FOUR.
ONLY THIRTY FOUR HAVE AN S. C.
T. ON RECORD OR ACT SCORE.
YESTERDAY. ON APRIL TENTH WE
OFFERED THE SAT TO EVERYONE OF
THOSE TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
JUNIORS
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY FOR FREE.
YOU MAY ASK OURSELVES WHAT ARE
THE BARRIERS PREVENTING STUDENTS
FROM TAKING COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAMS THAT IS SO IMPORTANT TO
THE FUTURE.
AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE MORE
IMPORTANT QUESTION WE SHOULD BE
ASKING IS WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
AND THE BILL THIS BILL IS ONE
ANSWER IT WILL HELP BRING DOWN
WHATEVER THE BARRIERS ARE THAT
PREVENT STUDENTS FROM TAKING THE
TEST BY OFFERING IT DURING THE
SCHOOL DAY. AND GIVING DISTRICTS
LIKE SACKS CITY MORE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN CREATING A
CULTURE THAT ALLOWS US TO
ADMINISTER COLLEGE ENTRANCE
EXAMS
TO ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
CERTAINLY THIS BILL WILL HELP
OUR DISTRICT AND EVERY OTHER
DISTRICT IN THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY STUDENT. HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE.
A CHOICE FROM THOSE CHOICES OF
OUR POST SECONDARY FROM THE
WIDEST ARRAY OF OPTIONS. BEING
ABLE TO USE THE S. A. T. OR THE
ACT AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE
STATE'S STANDARDIZED TESTS WILL
BE A RELIEF FOR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS SO THEY MAKE FOCUS ON
PREPARING STUDENTS FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND CAREER.
PREPARATION.
I THINK UP SIMPLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL FOR INTRODUCING THE
BILL ON HOPE THAT THE COMMITTEE
WILL AGREE ON THE VALUE TO OUR
STUDENTS OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
GOOD LUCK FINANCE PERSONAL SIR
AND I'M THE.
SUPERINTENDENT ALONG WITH
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I
WON I THINK THE CHAIR IN. THE
COMMITTEE ARE ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ALONG WITH UNIFIED HAS
GIVEN THE AS THE TEARS AS HE'S
T. US SCHOOL DAY FOR THREE
YEARS.
AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES
BEFORE WE.
GAVE THE SAT ARE ONLY ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE PERCENT OF MY
STUDENTS ACTUALLY TOOK THE SAT
LONG BEACH IS A VERY DIVERSE
DISTRICT ARE EIGHTY SIX PERCENT
MINORITY SEVEN PERCENT POVERTY.
I'M ONLY TWENTY THREE PERCENT OF
MY SPECIAL ED STUDENTS TOOK THE
TEST I'M ONLY SIXTEEN PERCENT OF
MY EMAIL STUDENTS TOOK THE TEST.
AND ONLY ABOUT TWENTY PERCENT OF
MY STUDENTS ON FREE OR REDUCED
LUNCH TOOK THE TEST
SINCE WE WERE GIVEN AT THE LAST
THREE YEARS. ALL MY STUDENTS ARE
TAKING THE TEST IN THE BEAUTY
HAS BEEN THAT THERE IS A
POSITIVE CORRELATION BETWEEN
STUDENTS MEETING COLLEGE CAREER
READINESS STANDARDS ON THE
ASPECT. AS WELL AS S. ET FOR
EXAMPLE MOM BEACH LAST YEAR
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS
MADE IT ON THE ASPECT FIFTY
THREE PERCENT ON THE SEC. AND
MATHEMATICS THIRTY TWO PERCENT
ON THE ASPECT THIRTY ONE PERCENT
AND ON THE S. ET.
THE BEAUTY HERE IS THAT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS IT WE GIVE FREE AS
A CHEAPER TO ALL OF OUR JUNIORS
IN EACH YEAR PROMISE OF THIRTY
THREE OUR. SORRY PROGRAM LAS
WHAT SEVEN SATURDAYS THIRTEEN
HUNDRED JUNIOR SIGNED UP TO TAKE
A TEST HUNDREDS OF KIDS ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
THE OTHER PIECE IS OUR COLLEGE
AND ARE GOING RATE IS AROUND
SEVENTY NINE PERCENT NOW LONG
BEACH UNIFIED HAS AN EIGHTY SIX
PERCENT GRAD RATE FOR EXAMPLE
EIGHTY ONE PERCENT OF MY AFTER
AMERICANS ARE GRADUATING SCHOOL.
WITH A GUN COLLEGE GOING RATE OF
SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT AFTER THE
FIRST YEAR MY STUDENTS ATTEND
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
DIFFERENT COLLEGES WE'VE BEEN
TRACKING THIS FOR OVER TEN
YEARS.
THE BEAUTY IS THAT WE REQUIRE
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS TO LINK
THEIR ARM THAT'S ET ACCOUNTS TO
THE KHAN ACADEMY WHICH PROVIDES
THEM FREE PERSONALIZED
TUTORIALS.
AND THIS IS CRITICAL BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY THAT YOU CAN IMPROVE
YOUR SAT SCORE IT TO GO TO THE
CSU FOR THE CSU INDEX WHICH IS A
VERY COMPLICATED FORMULA. IS.
YOU HOW TO IMPROVE YOUR SAT
SCORE YOU YOUR GPS SET BY THE
END OF YOUR JUNIOR YEAR SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF MY SENIORS TAKE
THE SAT AGAIN. ON OUR DIME AS
THE SENIORS AND THE BEAUTY HERE
IS THAT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SENIORS WHO COULD HAVE
GUARANTEED ADMISSION TO SEE
ISSUE LOBBYIST BECAUSE THEIR
INDEX IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THE
OTHER AND.
UNIVERSITIES
GET IN IN THE BEAUTY OF THIS IS
A NINETY ONE PERCENT OF THOSE
ARE STUDENTS OF COLOR WE CAN'T
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR CONSERVING
THIS BILL WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF OUR CHILDREN.
THINK.
MY NAME IS MOST EDUARDO I'M A
HIGH SCHOOL SENIOR HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT.
AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE BECAUSE
AS A STUDENT I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE ONE THING THAT WE ARE
MISSING WITHIN OUR SCHOOLS IS
PASSION IN OUR STUDENTS AND THE
STUDENTS CAN FIND PASSION AND
MOTIVATION IN THE THINGS THAT
THEY. THAT THEY CAN UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY HAVE POWER TO DO SO A
LOT OF OUR STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS
THEY SEE THAT AS BACK TEST THAT
THEY'RE GIVEN. AND THEY SEE IT
AS A WORTHLESS TEST
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WE GET
NOTHING BACK FROM THAT TEST
PERSONALLY AS STUDENTS SO
STUDENTS WILL TAKE THAT TEST AND
THEY WON'T TRY ON IT. AND THEY
WILL CARE LESS ABOUT IT AND THEY
WILL JUST WASTE THE SCHOOL DAY
TAKING A TEST THAT ULTIMATELY
DOES NOTHING FOR THEM BUT WHEN
STUDENTS SEE THE SAT OR THE ACT.
THEY SEE POTENTIAL MAY SEE AN
OUTLET TO THOSE CAREERS IN THE
SUCCESS THAT THEY ACTUALLY WISH
THAT THEY CAN GO TO AND BY
ADMINISTERING THIS TEST.
FOR FREE ON CAMPUS STUDENTS DO
NOT ONLY SEE THAT TEST BUT THEY
SEE THE DOLLAR SIGNS ALONG WITH
THAT TEST GO AWAY AND THEY SEE
THAT OUT WOULD. COME DIRECTLY TO
THEM AND A IT WOULD BE IT BLOWS
MY MIND THAT JUST YESTERDAY WHEN
WE HAVE AS A TWO DAY AT OUR
CAMPUS ARE JUNIORS HAVE BEEN
RUNNING AROUND FOR WEEKS.
GOING TO TUTORING SESSIONS
ASKING SING IS FOR A PRACTICE
EXAMS AND EVERYTHING ELSE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THIS IS
THE ONE TICKET THAT CAN GET THEM
SO WHERE THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO
GET TO IN THE WAY THAT THEY CAN.
A LOT OF THEM DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY A LOT OF THEM DON'T HAVE
THE MOBILITY TO GET TO THESE
EXAMS IN THE WAYS THAT THEY'VE
BEEN ADMITTED BEFORE. AND THAT
JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING IN
OFFERED TO THEM NOW YOU'RE
SEEING FULL ADVANTAGE COME OUT
OF THE STUDENTS AND YOU'RE
SEEING FOR PASSION COME OUT OF
THE STUDENTS AND I DEFINITELY
BELIEVE. THAT WHEN THE SCORES
COME BACK AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE
SO MANY MORE JUNIORS WHO ARE
GOING OFF TO BE SUCCESSFUL
PEOPLE.
THAN WE HAVE EVER SEEN IN A
LONG TIME AND SO I REITERATE
MYSELF I I DEFINITELY BELIEVE
THAT BY PUTTING FAITH BEHIND
THIS BILL YOU'RE NOT ONLY
PUTTING FAITH BEHIND THE BILL
ITSELF BUT YOU ARE PUTTING
FAITH.
BEHIND THE FUTURE WITHIN OUR
STUDENTS THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE.
APPROACH TO MAKE BUT THE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
POSITION ON THE BILL.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION A SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT THIS BILL DOES PROVIDE.
THE LOCAL DECISION MAKING TO THE
LOCAL DISTRICTS.
IF THEY WOULD LIKE TO USE THE S.
EIGHTY IF THEY WANT TO USE THE
S. BACK IT THEN BECOMES A LOCAL
CONVERSATION WHICH IS WHERE
THESE DECISIONS SHOULD BE MADE
THANK YOU.
KIND JACKSON SAY NEW UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
JEFF ROSS CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LATINO SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE CENTRAL
VALLEY EDUCATION COALITIONS.
A LOT I CAN NOT ON BEHALF OF
OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND ADDED IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
JOSE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS SPEAKING IN SUPPORT ONE
OF THE KEY CONCERNS WE HAD
INITIALLY WAS.
PROVIDING ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
STUDENTS WHO WHO NEEDED THEM AND
WE WERE ASSURED THAT THAT WOULD
BE THE CASE SO.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JEFF FLOCK OF REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT
AND THANK YOU TO MISTER
O'DONNELL STAFF FOR MEETING WITH
US ON.
CRISTINA MARCELLUS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THERE CLINICS ON BEHALF OF THE
SAME PORTANTINO COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN ALL
OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WITHIN
SAMPER'S DINA COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
MARTHA ALBERTSON HAVE ACCESS
SEIZURE OF CALIFORNIA'S CLUB
DETERGENT SUPPORT AND SHOUT OUT
TO RECONSIDER THE UPPER THE
GREAT WORK ON THE BILL.
LARA PART BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH IN SUPPORT.
AND YOU COULD WATCH ON BEHALF OF
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL POSITION AT THE MOMENT.
BUT WE SUPPORT A THE LOCAL
CHOICE FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ADMINISTER THE TESTS AT THE TO
USE NQ.
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO SUE BANG ON
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TRUCKS
AND. UNFORTUNATELY OR HEARINGS
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BELL I HAVE
WITH ME MICHELLE CENTER ARE.
DIRECTOR OF OUR ASSESSMENT
DIVISION AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHO
SPEAK
TO THE SUPERINTENDENT'S
CONCERNS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE ARE HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG CONCERN AN URGE THAT YOU
OPPOSE ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FIFTY ONE.
IN DOING SO YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THE COHERENT AN
INTEGRATED SYSTEM.
STANDARDS ASSESSMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT IS NOW BEING
USED IN OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS WERE KEY TO
IMPLEMENTING THIS AND TAKE THIS
INTEGRATED SYSTEM. THAT HAS
RELIABLE VALID AND FAIR
ASSESSMENTS AT ITS CORE.
FOR ASSESSMENT TO BE VALID THEY
MUST HAVE A SOLID FOUNDATION OF
ALIGNMENT TO CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS THAT ARE BEING TAUGHT
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
IN AN INDEPENDENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE HUMAN RESOURCES
RESEARCH ORGANIZATION. THE
SMARTER BALANCED HIGH SCHOOL
ASSESSMENT RECEIVED AN EXCELLENT
RATING FOR ITS MASKS TO
MEASURING CONTENT MOST NEEDED
FOR COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS.
THISIS IN STARK CONTRAST TO
STUDY THAT CONDUCTED THAT
CONCLUDED THAT LESS THAN HALF OF
THE SAT MATH ITEMS ALIGNED TO
OUR HIGH SCHOOL COMMON CORE MATH
STANDARDS.
ADDITIONALLY.
MICHAEL COHEN PRESIDENT OF
ACHIEVE RECENTLY STATED IN
REFERENCE TO THE ACT AND SAT.
THAT THEIR LACK OF ALIGNMENT
WITH STATE'S COLLEGE AND CAREER
READY STANDARDS MEANS THAT THEY
ARE NOT THE ASSESSMENTS TO BE
USED FOR ACCOUNTABILITY
PURPOSES.
FOR ASSESSMENT TO BE FAIR THEY
MUST OFFER STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
THOSE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THOSE STUDENTS WHO ARE LEARNING
ENGLISH. THE SUPPORT THEY NEED
TO DEMONSTRATE WHAT THEY KNOW
AND CAN DO.
EVEN IF THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WOULD ALLOW US TO
IMPLEMENT AN ALTERNATE
ASSESSMENT WITH LESS
ACCESSIBILITY SUPPORTS. OR WITH
A MORE BURDENSOME REQUESTING
PROCESS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. IT IS OUR
MORAL OBLIGATION TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS RECEIVE THE ACCESS THAT
THEY NEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND SLIPS.
SOME GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION MY NAME
IS JENNIFER PETTY AN ENGLISH
TEACHER IN ORANGE IN A FIVE FOR
TWENTY ONE YEARS. AND THIS IS
ALSO MY FIFTH YEAR AS CHAIR OF
CTA'S STANDING COMMITTEE ON
ASSESSMENT TESTING.
ON BEHALF OF CTA I'M SPEAKING TO
YOU TODAY ABOUT THE ASSOCIATIONS
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
CD BILLY'S LEADERS AT BOTH THE
DISTRICT AND STATE LEVEL SHOULD
CONSIDER THIS OPTION AS PART OF
A THOUGHTFUL PROCESS OF CREATING
A HIGH QUALITY IN BALLOT SYSTEM
OF ASSESSMENT.
SEE IF YOU BELIEVE THAT IN
REGARD TO REPLACING THE STATE
APPROVED A GRADE ELEVEN
ASSESSMENTS IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS LITERACY AND MATHEMATICS.
THE STATE HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE.
YOU TO APPROVE A REQUEST BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO EXERCISE THE
OPTION TO ADMINISTER AN
ALTERNATE ASSESSMENT SUCH AS
NATIONAL RECOGNIZE ASSESSMENTS
RECONNAISSANCE MINTS.
GIVEN THE CURRENT FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SSA CRITERIA
FOR PUTTING SUCH TESTS SHALL
INCLUDE BUT NOT BE LIMITED TO.
PEER REVIEW THE STATE MUST
SUBMIT EVIDENCE FOR PEER REVIEW
TO DOCUMENT THAT THE RECOMMENDED
TESTING PROGRAM AS VARIOUS
COMPONENTS MEET REQUIREMENTS FOR
VALIDITY RELIABILITY AND
FAIRNESS.
I'M INCLUDING IN SUPPORT MY
TESTIMONY A MAP THAT YOU AT THE
HAS BEEN DISTRIBUTED TO YOU THAT
LAYS OUT THE CRITICAL ELEMENTS.
OF THE PEER REVIEW WHICH THIS
BILL WAVES THERE ARE FOUR
CRITICAL ELEMENTS.
OF THOSE THE SENATE CRITICAL
ELEMENTS IN CLEAR BOXES WITH
SOLID OUTLINES.
ARE ONES THAT MAYBE SKIT IF
REVIEW OF THESE ELEMENTS
ALTOGETHER AS A PRIMARY REASON
FOR CITIES OBJECTION TO THE
BILL.
ALIGNMENT TO THE STATE ADOPTED
STANDARDS SEE BELIEVES STATE.
THE STATE MUST CONDUCT AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION OF THE
ALIGNMENT OF THE RECOMMENDED
TEST AS MY AS MICHELLE'S
UNDERSTATED.
TO THE STATE'S ADOPTED CONTENTS
ENTERS THE DEPTH AND BREADTH OF
CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTED A COMMON
CORE STATE STANDARDS THE REVIEW
FROM THE STATE MUST PROVIDE
DOCUMENTED CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT
THE RECOMMENDED TEST WAS
DEVELOPED USING A PROCESS.
TO THE NEEDS OF ASSESSING THAT
STATE STANDARDS.
FAIRNESS TO ALL STUDENTS CT
BELIEVE THE RECOMMENDATION
RECOMMENDED TESTS SHOULD PROVIDE
VALID AND RELIABLE MEASUREMENT
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF
PERFORMANCE. OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
LOW PERFORMING THE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND STUDENTS WHO
WERE ENGLISH LEARNERS
IS HAS ABILITY FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WHO WERE ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND OR HAVE A
DISABILITY. CT DEPLETE BELIEVES
THE RECOMMENDED TEST MUST
PROVIDER USE THE SAME SET OF
SUPPORTS AT MINIMUM AND
ACCOMMODATIONS PROVIDED BY STATE
SANCTIONS ASSESSMENTS.
OF CITY BELIEVES RECOMMENDED
TEST MUST BE REVIEWED USING THE
STANDARD SETTING PROCESS THAT
INCLUDES PERFORMANCE LEVEL
DESCRIPTORS BASED ON THE STATE'S
STANDARDS. WE HAVE BEEN
CONTACTING TEACHERS AND TEACHER
LEADERS IN THE DISTRICTS
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL AS
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BILL
ANALYSIS AS SUPPORTING THIS
BILL.
SO FAR THE LOCAL ASSOCIATION
LEADERSHIP IN ALBERT BEAUMONT
BRAILLE LINDA CHINO VALLEY
DUBLIN HELMET LYNN WOULD OAKLAND
ORANGE SAN JOSE SAN DIEGO AND
SANTA CLARA HAVE ALL STATED TO
US THAT THERE DISTRICT
LEADERSHIP HAS NEVER CONTACTED
POLICE TRAFFIC ABOUT SUPPORTING
THE IDEAS AND WAS DONE IN THIS
BILL. AND FOR THE REASONS I'VE
OUTLINED IT WILL NOT SUPPORT THE
BILL AS WRITTEN.
THIS BILL IN ITS CURRENT FORM
DOES NOT SUFFICIENTLY YEARS THE
PEER REVIEW PROCESS TO ASSURE
THE PARTICULAR ASSESSMENT AND
SENSIBILITY NEEDS OF STUDENTS
DISABILITIES AND LISTENERS ARE
ADDRESSED.
WHILE THERE ARE MANY OTHER
CONCERNS WITH THIS SORT CUTS IN
THIS BILL THERE ARE MANY.
MOST URGENT ISSUES SUCH AS
SIMPLY AS THE BILL SHOULD
ADDRESS
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF BORIC OUR
CONCERNS ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE AND I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AT ARLINGTON REESE YOU RETIRED
SPECIAL ED TEACHER AFTER THIRTY
SIX YEARS SECONDS S. ECONOMIC
LACKEY HIGH SCHOOL. CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION LIAISON TO
THE SECONDARY PRACTICE AND
TRANSITION AND ALSO CHAIR OF THE
NEA A CAUCUS WHICH CATERS OF
EXCEPTIONAL CHILDREN. AMONG THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL TO THE
LACK OF ADDRESSING
ACCOMMODATIONS AND MODIFICATIONS
FOR NOT JUST THE EL AL.
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
SPECIFICALLY TIME. THOSE ARE NOT
ALLOWED WITH ACCOMMODATIONS AND
MODIFICATIONS THAT DIFFERENT WE
URGE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
EVELYN APPLE HASN'T DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF OPPOSITION
JUST REALLY BRIEFLY WE WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THIS BILL HOLD
STUDENT WITH DISABILITIES TO A
LOWER STANDARD THAN MY FEDERAL
LAW CURRENTLY REQUIRES RUN THESE
TESTS.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
COMMENDATIONS ISSUE IN ENSURING
THAT ACCOMMODATION NEEDS ARE
ACTUALLY.
MATT AND WHOSE COULD ENFORCE
THE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES THE BILL
REFERENCES I'M REQUIREMENTS
ABOUT IT A BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE AYE BEFORE
PLANS DO THEY GET ACCOMMODATED
AS WELL. BUT THERE'S MANY
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THE
LANGUAGES AND CLEAR FOR OPEN
HAVING CONVERSATIONS BUT AS THE
BILL STAND RIGHT NOW WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
MARTHA CERRITOS IDEAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER. AND I JUST WANTED A
CLARIFICATION WITH REGARD TO THE
AMENDMENTS DID YOU STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. O'DONNELL THAT
THERE WERE GOING TO BE
ACCOMMODATIONS BUT SPECIFIC TO
THE EYEPIECE AND PRIVATE
FORESTS.
I I'LL THAT.
O'DONNELL I POTENTIALLY ADDRESS
THAT ACTUALLY MEANT THAT YOU
OPEN IT TO MEMBERS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU HOPE OKAY
WELL OUR CONCERN IS THE FACT
THAT WE SEEK AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL. WITH REGARDS TO
ACCOMMODATIONS TO ENGLISH
LEARNERS.
SPECIFICALLY THOSE ENGLISH
LEARNERS WHO ARE NOT YET ENGLISH
PROFESSIONS HOW WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO TAKE THE ESSAY. THE
ESSAY T. D. S. BACK PROVIDES IS.
APPROPRIATE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
THOSE ENGLISH LEARNERS ALSO HOW
DOES THIS BILL AFFECT ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND BILINGUAL PROGRAMS
THESE ARE THE CONCERNS THAT WE
RAISED TO. BE AUTHOR AND WE HAVE
NOT YET RECEIVED A RESPONSE FROM
THEM THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MANY MEMBERS OF THE.
THE DOCTOR WEBER.
YEAH.
OKAY THIS IS NOT ONLY EVER HEARD
FROM YOU TODAY MY MONEY GO
FIRST.
WELL I I CAN CLOSE.
HOUSE AND ASK YOU CLOSE NO
ACTUALLY I WAS GONNA ASK IF YOU
WOULD ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT
WE JUST HEARD FROM THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM CALGARY.
MY I THINK THAT THIS IS A GOOD
MEASURE AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT
IT.
I AM SENSITIVE TO THOSE WHO'VE
ASKED ABOUT HOW ACCOMMODATIONS
WOULD HAVE BEEN.
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS AND FOR
OTHERS YOU JUST ADDRESS THEM
WHEN WHENEVER YOU ARE MAKING
YOUR.
WELL THE QUESTION THE I IS
ELECTED BEEN ASKED OF A COUPLE
DIFFERENT WAYS YEAH ARE THEY
GOING TO BE ACCOMMODATIONS THE
ANSWER IS YES IF WE NEED TO WORK
WITH.
SOMEONE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC. ON
SO AMENDMENT CERTAINLY WILLING
TO HAVE THOSE DISCUSSIONS BUT
THE INTENT IS ABSOLUTELY TO
PROVIDE ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR THOSE WHO NEED THEM.
DOCTOR OR. I WAS GOING TO.
WELL ONE OF THOSE MY QUESTIONS
WAS THAT BUT. THE OTHER ONE.
.
IT EVIDENTLY THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE ALREADY IMPLEMENT THIS IN
LONG BEACH AND IN SACKS.
YOU'RE ALREADY DOING IT.
AND YOU DOING THE OTHER EXAMS
WELL.
SO IT IS POSSIBLE TO DO BOTH.
AND THAT'S MY CONCERN BECAUSE
I'M A TRUE FOR OF READY TO JUST
DROP IT AND MOVE. AND I WANT
THOSE WHO DECIDE TO DROP BUT I
DON'T SEE ANY REQUIREMENTS HERE
TO REALLY DO.
THOUGH THE REAL HARD WORK THAT
YOU CAN DO IN ORDER TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT. IN OTHER WORDS YOU
KNOW IT'S ONE THING TO SAY OKAY
YOU GUYS COULD NOT TAKE THE SAT.
OR THE A CTU WHATEVER THAT ON
TAPE.
BUT THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO GET STUDENTS TO THAT
POINT IS CRITICAL. IN THE
SUCCESS OF THOSE EXAMS.
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN DO
IT. OR THE SAY OKAY THIS WILL
GET OUR KIDS IN COLLEGE BECAUSE
IT WON'T.
IF THERE'S NOT PREPARATION FAR
IN ADVANCE
TO HAVE THE STUDENTS BE
SUCCESSFUL.
YOU KNOW I'VE SEEN.
ANNA AND NOBODY PUTS HIS
COLLEGE MORE TO ME AND ME NOT
ALWAYS CRITICIZED BECAUSE YOU
SAY YOU YOU WANT EVERYBODY TO GO
TO COLLEGE YES YES I DO IN AND
AND SO AS A RESULT I ALWAYS GET
CRITICIZED BECAUSE I'M NOT GOOD
ENOUGH. WHATEVER CT  IN
THIS IN THIS BUSINESS BECAUSE I
FIGURED FOLKS CAN DO THAT AS
WELL. SOME ALWAYS PUSHING THE
COLLEGE PIECE THAT SURVEYOR BUT
ALSO KNOW THAT I'VE HAD STUDENTS
WHEREBY SAFETY NET YOU NEED TO
TAKE THEIR SAFETY. AND THEY TAKE
IT AND THEY DON'T DO WELL
BECAUSE THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT THE S. A. T. IS A LIFE
JOURNEY ALMOST TO GET TO THE
POINT WE'RE GOING TO DO WELL AND
IT. IS NOT SOMETHING YOU DECIDED
TO IN ELEVENTH GRADE. AND IT HAS
TO BE A LOT OF PREPARATION IN
ADVANCE TO TO TAKE THAT THAT
EXAM AND DO WELL ON IT.
I AM SO I'VE SEEN STUDENTS EVEN
GOOD STUDENTS WHO'VE TAKEN AND
NOT DONE WELL. IN A BEEN CRUSHED
BY BY THE SCORES AT AT THE IT IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE GPA AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT GOES
INTO IT AND AND.
.
I THINK THERE'S VALUE IN
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
WHO TAKE THE EXAMPLE IN TERMS OF
THE OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE
TO THEM.
BUT I KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
PRE WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE
PRIOR TO POST BE JUST SAY WE
WILL TAKE THE SAT.
I'M ONE YOU DISTRICTS REALIZE
THAT IF THEY DECIDE TO GO THAT
THERE'S NOTHING. I DIDN'T SEE
EVEN MAYBE IT'S YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
ANYTHING THAT WAS SAYS IN ORDER
FOR YOU TO.
S. NOTE TO MAKE THIS TO MAKE THE
SLEEP YOU HAVE TO HAVE DONE THIS
THIS WORK WAS HARD WORK BUT MOST
OF YOU'VE DONE. I KNOW LONG WE
JUST A LOT OF HARD WORK TO GET
TO THE POINT WITH OUR STUDENTS
ARE TAKING THAT EXAM DOING WELL
AND BEING AND HIGH PERCENT OF
THEM POINT COLLEGE. A LOT OF
THEM HAVE DONE THAT I'VE SEEN
LOTS OF SCHOOLS WHO PUSHED THE
SAT. IN INNER CITIES AND THE
KIDS TAKE IT. AND THEY DON'T DO
WELL AND THEY DON'T GO TO
COLLEGE OR THEY MAY THE
PATERNITY BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE
ENDED UP ANYWHERE WITHOUT. EVEN
WITHOUT THE TEST SO I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOME ALMOST
FEEL LIKE I'M IN A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT WITH REGARDS TO. THE A
FULL BILL THAT REALLY SAYS I
SHOULD GET RID OF THIS TEST.
AND.
AT THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW ALL
MOVE ON TO THESE OTHERS THAT AT
THE I KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN TOLD
THAT THE S. A. T. IS CHANGED
SINCE I TOOK IT.
THOUSAND YEARS AGO.
AND THAT IS CHANGE EVEN SINCE
MY KIDS TOOK IT OUT TO TRY TO
ALIGN ITSELF WITH THAT. BUT I I
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA GETS INTO
THIS THING SOMETIMES WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN ASSESSMENT INSTRUMENT
AND THEN WE FLIP OVER GO TO
SOMETHING ELSE AND IT WOULD GO
SOMETHING ELSE AND SOMETHING
ELSE. IN THE PANTS A TOTALLY
CONFUSED AS TO WHAT WE'RE DOING
NOW AND WHERE THE NOT YOU KNOW
IT IT IT WHETHER THE ASSESSMENTS
ARE REALLY INFORMING NOT ONLY
HOW WELL KIDS ARE DOING. BUT
INFORMING OUR INSTRUCTION AS
WELL BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT ALSO
BE DOING AS WELL INFORMING US
ABOUT OUR INSTRUCTION WHERE WE
NEED TO GO. SO I JUST LIKE
THERE'S A LOT MORE CONVERSATION
THE NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH THIS
SOME PADDED TOWARD I MAY VOTE
FOR JUST TO GET IT.
MORE CONVERSATION.
GIVE IT TO THE FLOOR WITHOUT
KNOWING EXACTLY WHAT I'M GET ALL
THE ANSWERS AYE AYE HABIT
CONCERNING THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
BUT I THINK IT'S A IT'S A LOT OF
WILL GOAL.
AND BUT AT THE SAME TIME IF
THOSE FOLKS ARE DOING IT. AND
ARE DOING IT ALREADY.
WITH THE OTHER TEST THERE I
MEAN I KNOW SOME FOLKS SAY ALL
MY GOD WOULD HEAL TO KIDS TAKE A
LOT OF TESTS. BUT ALWAYS REMIND
FOLKS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO
TO UNIVERSITY YOU TAKE SIX SEVEN
TESTS IN ONE WEEK SOMETIMES
DON'T FINALS WEEK IN THE SAME
THING IN MIDTERM. SO IF YOU
REALLY GOING TO GO TO COLLEGE
BIG EACH ACT TOGETHER ON THE
TEST AND STORY BECAUSE IS COMMON
OKAY.
BUT UP BUT I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT
THAT THE HARD WORK THAT WOULD WE
HAVE ENOUGH IN HERE TO THE SAYS
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS HARD WORK AND THE HARD WORK
BEGINS BEFORE THE ELEVENTH
GRADE.
AND IBM'S VERY EARLY FOR
STUDENTS TO ACTUALLY TAKE THIS
TEST AND TO DO WELL ON IT AND
HAVE IT REFLECT YOU KNOW THE
ASPIRATIONS TO GO TO COLLEGE AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. ARM. I DON'T
KNOW IT IT JUST IT I HAVE COME
SOME CONCERNS AND I APPLAUD THE
IDEA AND THOSE OF YOU IN OF THE
DISTRICTS WHO DONE IT. BUT I
DON'T WANT TO DIMINISH THE HARD
WORK YOU'VE DONE BY SEA AND
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN DO IT. YOU
KNOW BECAUSE YOU FOLKS HAVE MADE
GREAT INVESTMENTS IN THIS EFFORT
I KNOW LONG WE TAKE AS AN AND NO
SEX STATE IS NOW MAKING GREAT
INVESTMENTS. IN THIS EFFORT
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO TAKE THE SAT
AND TO HAVE THE KIND OF RESULTS
THAT YOU WANT FOR USE FOR THE
KIDS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I HAVE ONE OF
THE SUPER TENNIS RESPONDED THAT
QUESTION BUT YOU WHAT I SAID
ABOUT. AND THAT IS THE WORD
ASSESSMENT. THE CHALLENGE I HAVE
WHAT THE US BACK SYSTEM IF YOU
WILL. IS THAT IT'S MORE OF A
SUMMATIVE TEST THAT IT IS AN
ASSESSMENT AND MOVE THE
SUPERINTENDENT WILL SPEAK TO
THIS BUT YOU CAN START THE
EIGHTH GRADE AND THAT THERE IS
YOUR ASSESSMENT.
TASKS SHORT TREATMENT GAPS
ASSESSMENTS HELP US CLOSE THEM
THAT MAYBE ONE OF THE SUPER
TENANTS COULD RESPOND TO A
QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
.
I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT IS IS
THE IT'S ABOUT ASSESSMENT IT'S
ABOUT IT'S GOING TO START EARLY
AND I WOULD ARGUE IT STARTS AS
EARLY AS PRESCHOOL AND SO. SO
WHAT WE'VE DONE IN LONG BEACH
I'M ALL OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE TAKE
THE PS EIGHTEEN GRADE EIGHT NINE
TEN ELEVEN THAT CITY IN GRADE
ELEVEN AND TWELVE. AND WE HAVE
THESE CAREER.
AT COLLEGES.
IN READING THIS GUIDES THAT
STUDENTS GET TWICE A YEAR
STARTING THE EIGHTH GRADE TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT DOCTOR WEBER TALK ABOUT
PROGRESS TALK ABOUT THEM GOALS
TALK ABOUT INTERVENTIONS. IN THE
BEAUTY IS THAT OUR TEACHERS HAVE
USE THIS INFORMATION TO ABOUT
CORD MAP SO FOR EXAMPLE WHAT
KISSING TO BE. ABLE TO SEE THE
SUCCESS ONE ALGEBRA TWO BACKWARD
MAPPING ONLY DOWN TO ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. PASSPORT ON THE OTHER
PIECE OUR OUR COLLEGE PARTNERS
HAVE TOLD US WHY WE NOW REQUIRE
FOUR YEARS OF MATHEMATICS SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF A STUDENT IS IN
COLLEGE READY. ON THE SAT THEN
THEY ARE PUT IN A.
CREDIT RECOVERY COURSE FOR
EITHER THE GOING TO JUNIOR
COLLEGE OR THE GOING TO ONE OF
THE UNIVERSITIES THAT GETS RID
OF REMEDIATION SO WE HAVE AROUND
SIX HUNDRED STUDENTS RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TAKING REMEDIAL COURSES ON
OUR DIME. TO DO THAT ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE HOUSE WERE
OFFERING COLLEGE MATH IN THEIR
SENIOR YEAR THERE. FROM CSU LONG
BEACH WITH THE STUDENTS CAN TAKE
OUT AND GET RID OF IT SO YOU'RE
AND AS YOU KNOW. IDEA C. T. OR
THE ACT IS A REQUIREMENT TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE POST SECONDARY
CHOICES. ABOUT WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE PUT IN THE EFFORT THAT
YOU'VE DESCRIBED UP FOR US TO
ORGANIZE THIS WELL AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE.
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION ALL OF
THE ACCOMMODATIONS QUESTIONS AND
AS MELISSA JUST MENTIONED.
THAT WE BEGIN TO CREATE A
CULTURE WHERE STUDENTS BEGAN TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS. WHAT
THEY HAVE TO START GETTING USED
TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
CHOICES?
THANK YOU I THINK YOU BOTH
PROBABLY ANSWERED MY QUESTION IS
WHY WE SHOULDN'T DO THIS UP BUT
ONLY BECAUSE. ONLY BECAUSE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK
PARTICULAR IN LONG BEACH.
WHICH HAS BEEN A MODEL OF THE
WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE FOR A LONG
TIME WITH THE PSE AND MOVING IT
FORWARD SO THAT. YOU DOING THE
ASSESSMENT EARLY IN THE GAME
WHEN YOU'RE DOING THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS THAT BRING THAT BRING YOU
TO THE SAT. LA ELEVENTH GRADE
RATHER THAN THE LEVIN GREAT YOU
DO AN ESSAY T. AND. ALL THE
OTHER STUFF IS NOT THE OR SO I
DON'T YOU KNOW I'M I'M REALLY
TORN WITH THIS.
LIKE I SAID I MADE JUST TO JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU TO PUSH
THE CONVERSATION FORWARD.
BUT I'M OUT BUT I AM CONCERNED
THAT.
IT DOESN'T BECOME ANOTHER SHINY
OBJECT TO US IN THE IN THE
STATE.
THAT THE HARD WORK THAT IS DONE
THE CHIU M. INDICATING IS NOT
JUST US PASSING THE ABILITY FOR
PEOPLE TO DO IT. IT'S REALLY
MAKING SURE OF THOSE WHO DECIDE
TO DO IT UNDERSTAND A WHOLE
PACKAGE THIS THE AIR AND NOT
JUST THE CHANGE FROM ONE TEST TO
THE OTHER. THAT THERE ARE
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT GOES
INTO IT AND I RESPECT THE WORK
THAT HAPPENS I KNOW WOULD LONG
BEACH DOES. I RESPECT THAT HARD
WORK THIS THERE AND THE QUESTION
BECOMES WHETHER NOT THAT'S GOING
TO BE. INCORPORATED IN SOMETHING
HERE THAT DEMANDS THIS LEVEL OF
UNDERSTANDING AND THE HARD WORK
THAT HAS TO OCCUR.
BECAUSE I YOU KNOW I KNOW SOME
FOLKS WHO DO IT AND SOME FOLKS
WHO DO THE SHINY OBJECT.
AND.
AND IN THE END WE WON'T SEE
NECESSARY THE KIND OF RESULTS WE
WANT WE CHANGE TESTING WE WILL
NOT SEE MORE STUDENTS BEING
SUCCESSFUL IN GOING TO COLLEGE
WILL HAVE THE BILL THAT THIS THE
DISCOURSE. AND ACT SCORES BUT
THEY MAY NOT BE ANYTHING THAT
WOULD GET THEM INTO ANYBODY'S
COLLEGE TO HELP THEM IN THAT
PROCESS OF THAT SO THERE WILL BE
A CHECK OFF THE BOX. IF THEY GOT
GREAT GPAS DIDN'T YOU KNOW THAT
THEY TAKE IN THIS CITY SO THAT'S
MY THAT'S MY CONCERN AND UP.
I APPRECIATE IT AND I AND I'M
HERE WITH YOU SAYING ABOUT
WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH THIS CITIES
SOMEONE TOLD ME THE CHANGE AND
ALL THAT GOOD ASSESSMENT BETTER
CARS. BUT I DON'T JUST WANT US
TO BE CHANGING TO BE CHANGING
AND NOT HAVE. THE OF THE BREASTS
OF THE WORK THAT YOU FOLKS HAVE
DONE OUGHT TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
MR DOT OBJECT CLOSE.
OH YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST BE CLEAR THAT THE
PURPOSE. OF THIS BILL ARE
SIMPLE.
OTHER CLEAR AT ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL THAT THE DISTRICTS ASIDE
WHAT ASSESSMENT IS BEST FOR
THEIR STUDENTS BUT. THERE MUST
BE AN ASSESSMENT.
THE SAT IS MORE MEANINGFUL TO
STUDENTS IT MEANS A LOT MORE
THEY ARE INVESTED IN.
IT WILL INCREASE COLLEGE GOING
RATES INSURES THAT STUDENTS TAKE
A COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM.
SAT IS MORE OF AN ASSESSMENT NOT
JUST A TEST WE DISCUSS THAT.
IT'S ONE LESS TASK THAT ELEVENTH
GRADER HAS TO TAKE IN YOU'VE GOT
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU GIVE THE
ASPECTHAST ON A SCHOOL SITE THE
LOGISTICS ARE PRETTY INCREDIBLE
YOU HAVE TO MOVE CLASSES YOU
HAVE TO CHANGE THE DAY YOU HAVE
TO BRING IT OFTEN. SUBSTITUTE
TEACHERS SOME TEST ADVISORS FROM
FROM THE FROM THE DISTRICT LEVEL
TO REALLY GET THE DAY MOVING AND
GET THE TEST TAKEN AND YOU GOT
TO CAPTURE THE KIDS THAT WEREN'T
THERE SO IT'S A. HUGE LOGISTICAL
VENTURE AS WELL ALL THE SIMPLE
VICE THAT YOU KNOW THE S. C. A.
S. R. ALLOW STATES TO AUTHORIZE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS USE A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED HIGH
SCHOOL ASSESSMENT. AND WE SEEK
TO EXERCISE THAT OPTION THROUGH
THIS BILL THIS BILL IS ABOUT
EQUITY. AN OPPORTUNITY AND I ASK
FOR YOUR IDOL.
I THANK YOU TO ALL WHO ARE
OFFERED YOUR INPUT TO OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS FOR THE GREAT
EXAMPLE YOU PROVIDED IN
PARTICULAR TO OUR VERY ELOQUENT
AT KENNEDY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT.
.
THIS IS A WONDERFUL JOB.
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THIS IS A SOLID BILL.
IT'S THAT A GOOD IDEA AND FOR
THE REASONS WE'VE HEARD I THINK
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO MAKE A.
REAL POSITIVE IMPACT AND I
PARTICULARLY APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS COMMITMENT TO.
MAKING SURE THAT THE
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENTS CAN
STILL BE USED FOR PURPOSES OF
MEASUREMENT.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OUT SOME
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT AND.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL BY O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
MCCARTY.
STEINORTH.
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
FOR VOGTS.
THE BILL IS OUT. THANK YOU.
YEAH.
DOING NOTHING.
SHOULD BY
.
FOR THAT I'M NINETEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR NINETY EIGHT BY MISS EGGMAN
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DIFFERENT CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT A.
B. TWENTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT.
JUST SO MANY PEOPLE KNOW LIKE A
MISTER THURMAN I SHARE A A BACK
ON AS BEING A SOCIAL WORKER. AND
I'M PROUD TO POINT TO MY TO STOP
MEMBER SITTING OUT THERE WHO
ALSO M. S. W.'S AYE MANY OF US
WHO WORK IN DIRECT PRACTICE
OFTEN REALIZE THAT MONTHLY START
WORKING ON POLICY AREAS YOU
CAN'T REALLY ACHIEVE. ALL THE
JUSTICE OF SYSTEM CHANGES THAT
YOU WANT.
WHICH BRINGS US TO THE POLICY
ARENA.
AND SO THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM
PROVIDE MORE SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SCHOOLS.
BOB EHRLICH SURPRISING WE ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE OFFERED
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THIS.
AS ALL OF US KNOW THERE'S A
HOST OF ISSUES YOUNG PEOPLE FACE
IOWA WE THINK WE'VE ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT HAVING MORE SUPPORT
IN. SCHOOLS FOR KIDS TO BE ABLE
TO WORK YOU DO HOME VISITS I
WORK ON GROUP DYNAMICS WORK WITH
PARENTS ISRAEL'S WAS STUDENTS
GETTING RESOURCES. IS A WIN WIN
WIN SITUATION FOR EVERYBODY US
OF THE TRAUMA KIT SPACE IN HOMES
THAT THAT THAT DOESN'T JUST STOP
AT THE DOOR.
AND THEY NEED SUPPORT AND
ONGOING.
INTERVENTIONS.
I WE HAVE RESISTING DATA THAT
THAT SAYS THAT.
THEY'RE BETTER WITH IT AND OTHER
STATES DO A BETTER JOB THAN WE
DO THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO SET UP
A PILOT PROGRAM A TWO FOR FORCED
TO FOR DISTRICTS THAT MEET A
CERTAIN CRITERIA THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL BE AN ALAMEDA
RIVERSIDE SAN BENITO SAN JOAQUIN
AND SHASTA.
AND THEY'LL BE ESTABLISH A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO BE ABLE TO.
APPLIED TO GET A SOCIAL WORKER
FOR EVERY SCHOOL BUT IN
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AYE DURING
DEEMED TO BE THE MOST IN NEED
AND THIS IS ABOUT THE SCHOOL
THAT WE AT DISTRICTS IT WE HAVE
NAMED THAT THAT CRITERIA.
WE HOPE THAT THEN OTHER PEOPLE
SEE THAT THE BUG OUTCOMES
IMPROVE AND THAT WILL ALSO THEN
WANT TO. BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THEIR OWN SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
SCHOOL SETTINGS SO I THE MONEY
HAS NOT BEEN APPROPRIATED YET WE
WOULD GET THIS BILL THROUGH
FIRST AND THEN APPROPRIATE THE
MONEY AND THEN THAT'S HOW. THIS
WOULD BE FUNDED WITH ME HERE
TODAY I HAVE LEON FOR CLARK KERR
BE WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
COMMITTEE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND REBEKAH GONZALEZ.
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME ALSO RECKON IT OF
YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES.
HELLO MY NAME IS REBECCA
GONZALEZ AND I REPRESENT THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS AND CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE SPELLING
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING
AT. I THE PILOT PROGRAM FOR
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS CREATED BY
THE SPELL WILL IMPROVE THE
DELIVERY THE DELIVERY OF
CRITICALLY NEEDED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN THE SCHOOL.
FORTY PERCENT OF AMERICAN
CHILDREN ARE AT RISK FOR SCHOOL
FAILURE DUE TO POVERTY RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION IMMIGRATION
LANGUAGE BARRIERS. LIVING IN A
SINGLE PARENT FAMILY AND PARENTS
WITH LITTLE EDUCATION OR HEALTH
PROBLEMS ABOUT NINETEEN PERCENT
OR ONE IN FIVE OF ALL CHILDREN
SEEN BY PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIANS.
HOW BEHAVIORAL AND EMOTIONAL
PROBLEMS BUT FEW RECEIVE HELP IN
FACT FEWER THAN ONE IN FIVE
NEEDING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACTUALLY RECEIVED THEM? IN THE
SCHOOLS SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
HELP TEACHERS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES OVERCOME BARRIERS TO
LEARNING SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
ARE MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
THAT PROVIDE SERVICES THAT
PROMOTE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND
BEHAVIORAL IT JUST BEEN. IN
SCHOOL AND IN SOCIETY.
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS ALSO HELP
CONNECT STUDENTS TO CRITICAL
SUPPORT SPACE SUCH AS HOUSING
FOR HOMELESS STUDENT. IN
ADDITION SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS
CAN HELP REDUCE ABSENCES AND
DROP OUTS BY PROVIDING CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AN ANGER MANAGEMENT
SKILLS HELPING STUDENTS LEARN
SOCIAL SKILLS. AND HELPING TO
PREVENT BULLYING BEHAVIOR
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS IN
THE SCHOOLS THEREFORE WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
BEAUTY.
GOOD EVENING I'M A DOCTOR LEON
TO CLARK HARVEY THE DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
AT CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES WE REPRESENT OVER
SEVENTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. MANY OF AND WE ALSO
REPRESENT LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS AMONG OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH PERSON NOW.
WORKFORCE ISSUES ARE CURRENT
CONCERN OF OUR MEMBER AGENCIES
ASH AND RECENT DATA SHOWS FROM
THE HEALTH FOR CENTER AT UCS
OFF.
THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE TWENTY
EIGHT PERCENT FEWER MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIANS AND WILL BE
NEEDED TO PROVIDE SERVICES IN
OUR STATE. AND WE LOOK AT
SERVICES PROVIDED WITHIN SCHOOLS
WE KNOW THAT THE SERVICES.
ARE OFTEN TO DIE FIRST TO BE
CUT WHEN SOCIAL WORKERS ARE
INVOLVED THE BENEFITS OF EARLY
INTERVENTION FOR CHILDREN WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING ISSUES AT
SCHOOL AND THE LONG TERM MENTAL
HEALTH BENEFITS THE INTERVENTION
CAN PROVIDE ARE INVALUABLE.
THE SERVICES CAN ONLY BE
PROVIDED IF THE APPROPRIATELY
TRAINED PERSONNEL ARE EMPLOYED
BY SCHOOLS AND WE ENCOURAGE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CONTRACT
WITH OUR SERVICE PROVIDERS WE
BELIEVE AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
EIGHT WILL SUPPORT THE BIG PEDRO
HEALTH WORKFORCE. AND PROVIDE
SCHOOL AGE YOUTH WITH NEEDED
SERVICES THANK YOU.
ALTHOUGH THIS ISN'T SUPPORT MORE
ASSEMBLE WOOD SHY ORDER AND TO
BE ON BEHALF OF THE SHASTA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOT REDWOOD YET BECAUSE I
RESPECT REASSURING HOUGHTON.
THE MOTION IS A DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
YEAH IS MOVED BY. THIS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN EXECUTIVE
VICE MEMBER WEBER O'DONNELL.
KILEY.
HAD WE NOT VOTING.
CARA.
CARTY.
STEINORTH THURMAN. THURMOND AYE
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS ALL CALL THINGS OFF
IT DOCTORATE
ALRIGHT MR THURMAN WILL BE
PRESENTING  B. TWO FOUR
SEVEN ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
PROBABLY BEFORE YOU TO PRESENT
AB TWO FOUR SEVEN ONE.
THIS BILL.
WILL ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S.
NEED FOR MORE STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES IT WILL ESTABLISH
GRANTS THAT INCREASE THE
DELIVERY OF SUPPORT SERVICES AND
THE INTEGRATION OF THOSE
SERVICES WITHIN THE ENTIRE
SCHOOL AT MANY SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
THE PROGRAM ESTABLISHES GRANTS
THAT WILL LEVERAGE FELT FEDERAL
DOLLARS IN DRAWDOWN MORE
RESOURCES.
AND IT WILL ENABLE US TO HAVE
IMPORTANT RESOURCES IN OUR
SCHOOLS LIKE NURSES AND SOCIAL
WORKERS AND SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
THE BILL DOES HAVE.
A FUNDING STREAM OF THAT HAS
BEEN IDENTIFIED THAT WOULD
ENABLE US TO BRING NEEDED
RESOURCES INTO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO PROVIDE.
ADDITIONAL.
TESTIMONY TO EMPHASIZE THE NEED
FOR THAT I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME
HELEN DOWDEN FROM THE TEACHERS
FOR HEALTHY KIDS ALLIANCE IN ON
OUR HOUSE WE BOUGHT FROM THE
NIGHT WAY OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
I'M HELEN ROSS DOWDEN FROM
TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY KIDS THIS
BILL IS BASED UPON A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM IN COLORADO. WHERE THEY
TOOK THEIR CANNABIS MONEY IN THE
YEARS TO TO PROVIDE A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR PSYCHOLOGIST? ON A
SOCIAL WORKERS SCHOOL NURSES UP
FOR PROGRAMS IN THE SCHOOLS
USING CANNABIS MONEY AND IT'S
BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL THEY'VE
SEEN. OUR REDUCTION THEY'VE SEEN
SOME REAL AFFECT ON MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
ALSO DECIDE CANNABIS MONEY
SINCE IT'S COMES FROM AN
INITIATIVE THAT CAN'T BE MATCHED
WITH FEDERAL MONEY IT CAN
PROVIDE A FISH A. FIFTY PERCENT
MATCH TO BRING MEDI CAL MONEY
DOWN. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE'S A STATE PLAN
AMENDMENT AS OF JULY OF THIS
YEAR THAT WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE CYCLE A PSYCHOLOGY
SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
SO THIS MONEY WOULD PROVIDE THE
MATCH SO RATHER THAN HAVE
HUNDRED NINE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WE WOULD HAVE A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION BY DOING IT
THIS WAY AND. IT WOULD BE AND A
LOT OF THIS PROGRAM IS ALREADY
IN PLACE BASED ON WHAT COLORADO
HAS DONE SO WE COULD REALLY.
ADAPTED QUICKLY AND USE IT FOR
SCHOOLS A SUPPORT SERVICES THANK
YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION OF
POSITION ON THE BILL.
HOW I THINK WHEN WE HAVE A
SECOND ONE GUY HAD AND THEN
WE'LL GET TO THE LINE THANK YOU
I WILL TRY TO BE BRIEF?
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS ON A
HASSELBLAD I'M WITH UNITED WAYS
OF CALIFORNIA UNITED WAY'S
FIGHTS FOR THE HEALTH EDUCATION
AND FINANCIAL STABILITY OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN EVERY
COMMUNITY. WE'RE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURMAN AS THIS BILL ADDRESSES
THE IMPORTANT NEXUS OF ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT AND THE SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA HAS AN
UNEVEN TRACK RECORD WHEN IT
COMES TO INTEGRATING CARE
BETWEEN SCHOOLS HEALTH PROVIDERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES AS A RESULT MANY
STUDENTS ARE FALLING BETWEEN THE
CRACKS.
THIS IMBALANCE CAN BE SEEN
PARTICULARLY FOR STUDENTS THAT
ARE ENGLISH LEARNERS FOSTER
YOUTH OR FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY CONCERNING.
CONSIDERING THAT NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA ARE COVERED BY HEALTH
INSURANCE BUT AS WE SADLY NO
COVERAGE DOES NOT EQUAL ACCESS.
TO CARE AND TOO MANY CHILDREN DO
NOT RECEIVE RECEIVE THE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES.
THEY NEED EARLY IN LIFE THIS IS
WHERE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
OFFERS A SMART SOLUTION CHILDREN
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES DESERVE
ACCESSIBLE INTEGRATED
COORDINATED SERVICES THEIR
SCHOOLS TO ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHEST
POTENTIAL. AND THIS BILL WOULD
FOLLOW THE INTENT OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOURS USE EDUCATION
PREVENTION EARLY INTERVENTION
AND TREATMENT ACCOUNT AND
PROVIDING TARGETED GRANTS TO
SCHOOLS TO SUPPORT STUDENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
CREATES UNNECESSARY MECHANISM BY
WHICH GRANTS TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES CAN BE DEVELOPED IN ORDER
TO SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES WITH
HEIDI POPULATIONS. WE KNOW FROM
OUR WORK ACROSS CALIFORNIA THAT
WRAPPING CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THEY NEED AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE DRAMATICALLY ALTERED
THE COURSE OF THEIR LIVES FOR
THE BETTER. THE SCHOOLS MANY
TIMES THE CENTER COMMUNITIES
WHERE WE CAN MOST EFFECTIVELY
INTERVENE.
ADDITIONALLY AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE DRAWS FROM ROBUSTLY
EVALUATED SCHOOL BASED
COORDINATE CARE MODELS LIKE THE
HEALTHY START INITIATIVE FOR
THESE REASONS.
WE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE
IS A BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR PROVIDING SCHOOL
BATES COORDINATED CARE.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TONY TO KERO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN DOWN
SUPPORT.
VIDEO BORN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
VERISIGN NOWHERE WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S HEALTH COVERAGE
COALITION WHICH INCLUDES
CHILDREN NOW THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP UNITED WAY AND CCHS.
WHAT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
I'VE MISTER FUHRMAN JUST TO
CLARIFY THERE WERE A COUPLE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
ARE YOU ACCEPTING THOSE
ELEMENTS.
YES WITH CHAIR WE ARE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE MINUTES.
AND THEN THIS IS COMING OUT FOR
ME NOT A SILLY THE COMMITTEE BUT
IT SEEMS THAT THE ALLEY IS
DEFINED IN A WAY THAT I THIS.
MIGHT INADVERTENTLY I'M NOT MAKE
OUT CHARTER SCHOOLS ELIGIBLE ARE
YOU WILLING TO.
AMEND THAT DEFINITION TO MAKE
CHARTER SCHOOLS ELIGIBLE AS WELL
I THINK IT'S EXPLICIT IN THE
LANGUAGE HERE THIS IS NOT. I
BELIEVE IT MENTIONS THAT
EXPLICITLY.
SO IT'S LIKE YES SUBSECTION BE
ONE ITS LA A A LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY MEANS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
OR A COUNTY OFFICE OF ITS.
LET ME GET TO THAT SECTION BUT
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT ALL
SCHOOLS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
APPLY FOR THESE GRANTS
NOW GOT TO LET YOUR ATTENTION IF
NEED BE WE. CAN AMEND THAT.
TAKARA.
IS THAT RIGHT.
I THINK IT'S ALREADY EXPLICIT IN
THE LANGUAGE BUT WE'RE SEARCHING
RIGHT NOW IT MAKE SURE WE CAN
POINT TO THE EXACT LANGUAGE
WHERE IT'S REFERRED TO. ADDRESS.
I THINK YOU AND I ARE THERE
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SECOND.
MISTER THEIR BUDGET BECAUSE ARE
JUST BE ON BEHALF OF OUR
STUDENTS TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE ACCESS TO LICENSE
PROFESSIONALS WHO CAN PROVIDE
HEALTH AND MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS. TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR
ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AYE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
HEALTH.
WITH AMENDMENTS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL.
KILEY AYE.
KILEY AYE KALRA. MCCARTY
STEINORTH THURMOND.
I THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THREE VOTES SITS.
THE BILL IS ON CALL.
WHEN THE.
YES PLEASE.
WITH THE CHAIRS.
AGREEMENT THAT WOULD PREVENT
NOT PRESENT EIGHTY TWO FOUR
SEVEN ONE.
A BILL THAT. I'M SORRY.
.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY THIS MAKE SURE
YOU'RE STILL PAYING ATTENTION AT
THIS LATE HOUR.
JUST GET IT NOW.
WITH YOUR INDULGENCE I AM HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN.
THE BILL THAT PROVIDES DUAL
LANGUAGE PROGRAM UP FOR OUR
STUDENTS
I WAS BILL CREATES PATHWAYS TO
THAT PATHWAYS TO SUCCESS GRANT
PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH GRANTS TO
ESTABLISH AND EXPAND. DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS
DEVELOPMENTAL BILINGUAL PROGRAMS
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS AND EARLY
LEARNING DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNER
PROGRAMS THESE PROGRAMS WOULD
PROVIDE STUDENTS IN PRESCHOOL.
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE WITH
PROGRAMS CONSISTENT WITH ADOPTED
STATE POLICY.
CD REPORTS THAT THERE ARE ONLY
TWO HUNDRED DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS AT THOUSANDS
OF SCHOOL SITES IN OUR STATE.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE SHOWN TO
PRODUCE MANY BENEFITS OF FOR
MANY STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOR NATIVE ENGLISH
SPEAKING STUDENTS AS WELL. THIS
BILL GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE
TOOLS TO CAPITALIZE ON THE
CHANGES OF PROP FIFTY EIGHT AND
TO DEVELOP PROGRAMMING TO. THAT
IS PROVEN TO IMPROVE STUDENT
LEARNING AND STUDENT SUCCESS.
AND WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS IS MARTHA
SAID ACROSS ID ASK REPRESENTING
KOBE IN CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER
AND VICKI ROMMEL'S HARRIS
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
POLICY. THAT THE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I THINK IT WAS ATTORNEY
OF SOMETHING THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER.
AS WELL YES WE ARE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT COMES TO
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARTHA
CERRITOS IDEAS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
WE ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
AS WAS STATED BY THE AUTHOR AB
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN WOULD
PROVIDE A GRANT PROGRAM WOULD
ESTABLISH A GRANT PROGRAM.
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OR
EXPANSION OF EXISTING DUAL
LANGUAGE OR A DEVELOPMENTAL
DEVELOPMENTAL BILINGUAL
PROGRAMS.
WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT THIS.
GRANT PROGRAM IS THAT IT WOULD
ALSO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR EARLY
LEARNING PROGRAMS FOR OUR DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS.
THE PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE A
SORELY NEEDED.
START UP FUNDS FOR.
OUR OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
CONSORTIA THIS NEEDED TO PROVIDE
NEEDED TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
PATHWAYS TO BUY LITERACY. FROM
PRESCHOOL TO TWELFTH GRADE.
OTHER START UP FUNDS WOULD ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO USE THESE RESOURCES
IN AN EFFECTIVE AND QUALITY
MANNER FOR THESE PROGRAMS. TO
INCLUDE OF THE ABILITY TO DO
SUCH AS.
OF.
TEACHER BILINGUAL TEACHER
RECRUITMENT THE PROVISION OF
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS IN
VARIOUS FOREIGN LANGUAGES.
AS WELL AS TEACHER COACHES.
ONCE THE PROGRAMS ARE
ESTABLISHED THEY WOULD BE
SUSTAINED WITH EXISTING
RESOURCES SUCH AS VLC AT THAT.
AND FEDERAL FUNDING WE KNOW WHAT
THE BENEFITS ARE ARE WITH
REGARDS TO BILINGUALISM AND
MULTI LINGUAL IS SO. THERE IS
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH REGARDING THE
ADVANTAGES.
BRAIN AND COGNITIVE ACADEMIC
ECONOMIC AND STRONGER FAMILY
COHESION AND HERITAGE
CONNECTION.
SPECIFICALLY DUAL LANGUAGE
IMMERSION PROGRAMS BENEFIT
NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKERS WHO
DEVELOP SKILLS IN THE NATIVE
LANGUAGE WITH NO NEGATIVE
IMPACT.
ON THEIR ENGLISH SKILLS NTL I
PROGRAMS ALSO ASSIST IN THE
NARROWING OF THE A ACHIEVEMENT
GAP OF ENGLISH LEARNERS.
AS WITH THE SUCCESS OF THE STATE
SEAL OF BY LITERACY AND OUR
HE'LL LAY AND HE'LL DE
FRAMEWORK.
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE NATION
IN CREATING BILINGUAL PATHWAYS
FOR ALL STUDENTS.
LET'S
KEEP THE PROMISE OF PROPOSITION
FIFTY EIGHT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN PLEASE VOTE YES ON AB
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
IF I'M A FACT THAT I'M.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS VICKI
ROMMEL'S HARRIS I'M ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY
WITH ABOUT SOME PROJECT
CALIFORNIA WHERE CIVIL RIGHTS
ADVOCACY IN POLICY ORGANIZATION.
AS THE OTHER STATED THE BILL
CREATES A THREE YEAR GRANT
PROGRAM TO CREATE.
DUAL LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS
DEVELOPMENTAL BILINGUAL PROGRAMS
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS AND EARLY
LEARNING TOOL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND ARE PARTICULARLY DELIGHTED
TO SEE.
EARLY LEARNING INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL.
MANY STUDIES INCLUDING IN THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN BY THE
NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF SCIENCES
CLEARLY SHOWS THE BENEFITS OF
BILINGUALISM. TO INCLUDE LONG
TERM ECONOMIC SOCIAL ACADEMIC
AND COGNITIVE BENEFITS AND ALSO
HOPE TO COULD.
TO CLOSE A CHEAP ACHIEVEMENT
GAP
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME OF STUDENTS.
RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS THAT ALL
CHILDREN ARE WIRED TO LEARN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES THAT THE
BRAIN IS MOST RECEPTIVE TO
LEARNING A LANGUAGE IN THE
EARLIEST YEARS OF LIFE.
AND THAT THE HOME LANGUAGE IS
REALLY FOUNDATIONAL FOR ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY FOR SOCIAL AND
COGNITIVE DEVELOPMENT.
AND FOR OVERALL ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT.
THE OVERWHELMING SUPPORT FOR
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT WAS A
BIG SIGNAL FROM OUR FAMILIES
THAT THEY WANT BY LEGAL PATHWAYS
FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
LARA AND SO THEY NEED SUPPORT
LAST YEAR THE STATE GENEROUSLY
PROVIDED FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
CREATE A NEW BILINGUAL TEACHER
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
TO SUPPORT THESE PROGRAMS.
EIGHT. ELEAZAR RECEIVE THE
FUNDING BUT THERE WERE FIFTY ONE
LETTERS OF INTENT SO THAT'S A
BIG SIGNAL OF THE KIND OF
SUPPORT THE DISTRICTS ARE
LOOKING FOR.
WE ARE EXCITED THE DISTRICTS
LIKE LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH
UNIFIED ARE BEGINNING TO
IMPLEMENT NEW DUAL LANGUAGE
PROGRAMS IN THEIR EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS. AND THEY TO
NEED SUPPORT TO BUILD.
THAT THEIR CAPACITY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO WE'RE EXCITED.
TO SEE AB TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN
AND THE POSSIBILITIES OF THE
START UP FUNDING THAT WOULD
SUPPORT FAMILIES TO WORK WITH
THEIR SCHOOLS TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO THESE DUAL LANGUAGE PROGRAMS.
FROM PRESCHOOL THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE.
AND THE AND FOR ALL STUDENTS
INCLUDING ENGLISH LEARNERS THANK
YOU.
AND WE.
WE'VE WHOM HE TOOK THAT REPORT
DOES. A GREAT JOB.
GREAT JOB LOT OF INFORMATION
WITH THAT OTHERS IN SUPPORT MAY
COME TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
HI CAROL BECAUSE OF. ARE
REPRESENTING SECOND DISTRICT PTA
AND SAN FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT.
LEAH PARA THING CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA AND SUPPORT.
THREE PANGYO NINTH DISTRICT PTA
PRESIDENT SAN DIEGO AND IMPERIAL
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THE MONEY I CAN OUT ON BEHALF OF
AVID IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL CAN A CAUSE ON BEHALF OF
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION WE
AWARDED THIS BILL ARE STAR AWARD
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN CHILI LISTA PDAS IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MORGAN THIRTY THIRD
DISTRICT PTA IN SUPPORT.
WE ANGELA READ MBF TENANTS CAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THAT'S A TORTOISE A SPINOFF SOME
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION OF SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL SCENE OPPOSITION THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S MOVED ALL SECONDS MOVED AND
SECONDED DO WE HAVE ANY COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN A COLOR FOR THE COMMITTEE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS YOU MAKE. YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALLTHE ROLL
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE KALRA. MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND. THURMAN THURMOND AYE
WEBER WEBER AYE.
VOTES IT'S A LOSS FOR VOTED IS
OUT AND MINIATURE ORDER MISTER
CAR THEY WOULD THANK YOU ONE
BILL THAT MR BONTA YOU CAN GO
AND THEN I'LL PRESENT THE REST
OF MY
.
MISTER CHAIR ARE YOU READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
RECOMMENDED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS FOR SURE. AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING FOR THE
EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
SERVICES. AND FOR HIGH COST
PLACEMENTS.
OUR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS DESERVE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO
REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
BUT ARE CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING SYSTEM
PRESENTS BARRIERS WHERE THERE
SHOULD BE OPPORTUNITIES.
FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING RATES HAVE
VARIED CONSIDERABLY.
FROM FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS
TO NINE HUNDRED THIRTY DOLLARS
PER PUPIL FOR REALLY NO LOGICAL
REASON.
IN FACT THE DIFFERENCE IN THE
FUNDING THAT THE THE DIFFERENCES
IN THE FUNDING DATE.
TO AN INFORMAL SURVEY OF
EXPENDITURES CONDUCTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN LIVING WITHIN
THESE AND IT WOULD SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN LIVING WITH THESE
INEQUITIES FOR NEARLY FORTY
YEARS IN ADDRESSING THEM IS SO
IS A SIMPLE MATTER OF FAIRNESS.
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
PRESCHOOL ALSO PRESENTS A
BARRIER WHERE THERE SHOULD BE
OPPORTUNITY
AT A CRITICAL TIME IN CHILDREN'S
LIVES.
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A FREE AND
APPROPRIATE.
PUBLIC EDUCATION TO PRE SCHOOL
AGE CHILDREN.
BUT IN SPITE OF THIS MANDATE NO
STATE FUNDING IS ALLOCATED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
THIS IS SHORTSIGHTED BECAUSE AN
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAM EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS ARE AN EXCELLENT.
INVESTMENT
FINALLY THE BILL PROVIDES FOR
ADDITIONAL SWAT FINDINGS TO
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS WITH MORE
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES.
WHEN OUR CURRENT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCE SYSTEM WAS
ESTABLISHED WE HAD SUCH AN
ALLOWANCE.
BUT WAS ELIMINATED DURING THE
RECESSION LEAVING SCHOOLS WITH
NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
HIGHER COSTS.
PLACEMENTS.
ALL OF THESE ADJUSTMENTS IN THIS
BILL ARE COMMON SENSE
INVESTMENTS AND FAIRNESS AND
EQUALITY FOR OUR VALUED
STUDENTS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
TEMPLAR PURSUER INTENT OF
GROSSMONT UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND MICHAEL FLORES
COST ANETA CHAIR OF THE SPENT
CTA SPECIAL EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND SPECIAL EDUCATION TEACHER
TEACHER IN THE ARVIN UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MISTER MISTER COLOR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DOCTOR
TIM LEBANON THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE GROSSMONT UNION HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I'M ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE.
SUPERINTENDENTS COUNSEL FOR THE
EAST COUNTY SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREA OR THE SALPA.
THAT SERVES OVER TEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AND
HAS AN ATA OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
SEVENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
ON BEHALF OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS
OF THE STUDENTS WOULD BE
DISABILITIES ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
I THANK THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR
OF AB.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX AS WELL
AS THE COMMITTEE FOR OPPORTUNITY
SHARE INPUT WITH YOU.
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING EQUITY
IS NEEDED NOW THE CURRENT
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING MODEL
ALSO CALLED AB SIX SO TO WAS
ENACTED IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES. THIS NOT KEPT UP WITH
THE CHANGING LANDSCAPE OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
ONE GLARING ISSUE THE SHOWS A.
B. SIX SO TOO HAS NOT KEPT UP IS
IN EQUITY IN THE BASE FUNDING
BETWEEN THE SELFLESS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. IN MY OWN COUNTY ARE
SUPPOSED TO TOUCH OUR BOUNDARIES
ARE FUNDED OUT FIVE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE DOLLARS FOR ADA Y.
MINE IS FUNDED AT FIVE HUNDRED
TWENTY TWO DOLLARS FOR A DEER.
IF OUR SUPPER RECEIVE THE SAME
AMOUNT OF EDTA FUNDING NEVER
WOULD RECEIVE FIVE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS MORE TO SERVE
OUR STUDENTS.
THIS DISCREPANCY EXISTS FOR NO
LOGICAL REASON AND EXIST ACROSS
THE STATE.
AB THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX
CORRECTS THESE INEQUITIES IN
PLACES US ON A PLAYABLE PLAYING
FIELD TO SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ACROSS THE
STATE LIKE THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDS.
ADDITIONALLY AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX ALSO CREATES A
FUNDING FORMULA TO OFFSET THE
COSTS OFFICIALLY MANDATED
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
FOR NOT ONLY THE EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN PRESCHOOL STUDENTS
IN MY SUPPER.
BUT THE NEARLY FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND PRESCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON STATEWIDE REPORTED DATA
WE'RE ONLY RECEIVING TWENTY
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR THAT WE
SPEND ON THE SERVICES FOR OUR
YOUNGEST STUDENTS.
WE ALL KNOW THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT INTENSIVE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE
EDUCATIONAL AND SOCIAL GAINS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AS WE ALWAYS SAY IF YOU DON'T
WANT AN ACHIEVEMENT GAP DON'T
LET IT START.
AND LASTLY REPLETE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING IS NEEDED FOR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
THE STUDENTS WITH SIGNIFICANT
DISABILITIES COME TO US NEEDING
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT SUCH AS
INTERPRETERS SPECIALIZED
EQUIPMENT AND INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
FOR EXAMPLE IN MY VERY OWN
DISTRICT WE RECENTLY PAID OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR ONE
TEXTBOOK TO BE TRANSCRIBED INTO
BRAILLE FOR EACH STUDENT WITH
VISUAL IMPAIRMENTS.
THAT'S STUDENT DESERVES THAT
BOOK.
AS PART AS AS A STATE WE'VE MADE
INCREDIBLE PROGRESS UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REFORM ONE
PART OF OUR EDUCATIONAL FISCAL
SYSTEM.
AS THE SUPERINTENDENT OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE SUPPORTS THEY NEED
TO MEET THEIR FULL POTENTIAL. WE
BELIEVE THE PISTOL THE CURRENT
FISCAL CLIMATE IS RIGHT TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN CLOSING I URGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO SEIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION. BY SUPPORTING AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SIX
AND TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SPECTACULAR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THE STAFF AND
FAMILIES THAT SUPPORT THEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHAEL FLORES
CASTANEDA HERE REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AS THE CHAIR OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. AS WELL
THAT ELEMENTARY SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER IN THE
ARMENIAN SCHOOL DISTRICT IN KERN
COUNTY WHERE I'VE TALKED FOR THE
PAST FOURTEEN YEARS.
HONORED TO BE HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. WITHOUT A
DOUBT SEATS HE SUPPORTS
INCREASING FUNDING FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION OF OUR CALIFORNIANS
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
I'M SURE WELL WHERE THAT'S THAT
STATE AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAVE CONSISTENTLY PROVIDED
INSUFFICIENT FUNDS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS. AND THIS MEASURE WOULD
MOVE US FORWARD IN PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES THAT OUR STUDENTS
MOST CRITICALLY NEED.
WHEN I FIRST BEGAN TEACHING IN
OUR VAN ARE THE DISH COULD JUST
PULL BACK THE PROGRAM FROM THE
COUNTY I'M CREATING THEM SO THAT
ITSELF QUITE A SAVINGS SO. I HAD
A BRAND NEW CLASSROOM WAS ABLE
TO GO PICK UP THE FURNITURE WHEN
THE SHOPPING SPREE WITH MY
SUPERINTENDENT PICKED OUT.
MATERIALS PUZZLES BOOKS YOU NAME
IT. THAT WAS FOURTEEN YEARS AGO
MANY OF THOSE PUZZLES ARE STILL
IN MY CLASSROOM MISSING PIECES
BOOKS TORN PAGES. ON MY CLASS
THAT THE FIRST YEAR I HAD SIX
STUDENTS HAD TO FULL TIME.
FULL DAY INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES.
MY CLASS HAS CONSISTENTLY GROWN
LARGER AND LARGER JUST YESTERDAY
I ARRIVED AT SCHOOL RECEIVING MY
FIFTEEN STUDENT I NOW HAVE TWO
FULL TIME INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES
AND ONE THREE HOUR EIGHT. THESE
ARE FIVE THROUGH EIGHT YEAR OLD
STUDENTS WITH SEVERE NEEDS MANY
OF THEM NEEDING ASSISTANCE WITH
FEEDING TOILETING MOST OF THEM.
LIMITED ARE NON VERBAL.
SO.
WITHOUT A DOUBT I STUDENTS NEED
AT INCREASED FUNDING AND AND
THIS BILL WOULD DEFINITELY GET
GET US THERE APRECIATE MARRIED
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IS
POOR PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WITH YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION IMPOSITION ON THE
BILL.
SARAH BOTCHES THAT KASBAH PROUD
COSPONSORED BEAT AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY SIX THINK YOU.
CAROL BECAUSE OF OUR SECOND
DISTRICT PTA IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPIDLY HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
NANCY LOW COST REPRESENTING THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND THAT'S
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN MEMBERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND THAT'S A
CO. SPONSOR THANK YOU.
STEVE WARD WITH CLOVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT.
HEATHER DEFEATY SUPPER DIRECTOR
FOR EASE COUNTY SOUTH BY IN SAN
DIEGO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENTS
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
TRINA FRAZIER ON BEHALF OF
FRESNO COUNTY SOPA IN SUPPORT.
PAM A TOSS UP BUT SILVA DRUCKER
FOR NO MAN NAPA COUNTY SELF IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THERESA CURT SELF A DIRECTOR FOR
THE NORTH COASTAL CONSORTIUM OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION NORTHERN SAN
DIEGO THANK YOU.
RUSSELL CORONADO.
DIRECTOR SAN DIEGO SELF
COUNTIES HELP ON BEHALF OF SIX
MEMBER DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT.
JAMIE TATE SIMON'S NORTH AND
ONCE ABA OF TEN DISTRICTS IN THE
NORTH EAST ANYWHERE.
SORRY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BEEN A LOT THIS ANTELOPE VALLEY
SALPA AND IT'S TEN MEMBER
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA PAULA BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS IN SUPPORT.
JIM ANDERSON CHAIR OF THE SELF
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF ALL
STUDENTS TO DISABILITIES.
WE SUPPORT THIS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND INTELLIGENT BILL.
THANK YOU.
ALICE KESSLER BEEN ASKED TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
STOCKTON SOPA THANK YOU.
VERONICA CODE SUBDIRECTOR FATIMA
COUNTY CO CHAIR OF SMALL AND
SPARSE OPPOSITE STRONG SUPPORT.
AND HER OWN BE SOLANO COUNTY
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN
AREA STRONG SUPPORT.
PAUL BEING GREATER ANAHEIM
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN
AREA REPRESENTING MY SIX
DISTRICTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THERESA PAFFORD REPRESENTING
CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SELF BUT STRONG SUPPORT.
AND REVEAL LOBOS REPRESENTING
SANTA CLARA SALPA AREAS ONE TWO
THREE FOUR AND SEVEN STRONG
SUPPORT IN IT THAT MAKES UP
TWENTY DIFFERENT DISTRICTS.
WE A MOP OF THE SOUTHEAST
CONSORTIUMS HELP BY ITS FROM
SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN REPRESENTING THE
PDAS IN CHULA VISTA AND
SWEETWATER COUNCIL SUPPORT.
LEAH PARA CALIFORNIA STATE PTA
SUPPORT.
WHEN YOU GET ALL THAT
SUPERINTENDENT ORCHARD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS STRONG SUPPORT.
TO NITA MORENO ORCHARD SCHOOL
TERRY DANIEL PRESIDENT OF THE
NINETIES YOUR PTA SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTIES SUPPORT.
I NEED TO EVER CREEK PRECEDING
THIRTY THIRD DISTRICT WE
SUPPORT.
PLAY MONEY I CAN ALSO WITH THE
FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
JIM ANDERSON SILVA DIRECTOR LA
COUNTY CHARTER SELF OF SUPPORT.
CENTER BORRERO CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
INTERNET PELLETIER SAN MATEO
COUNTY SELF LA IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL SIZE IN BEHALF OF THE
FOUR CELL POSE.
THE FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT IN
KERN COUNTY INCLUDING THE ARVIN
ELEMENT
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MAUREEN O'LEARY BURNOUTS WITH
VICKI BARBAROUS MICHAEL
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
STATEWIDE SPECIAL A TASK FORCE
THAT WAS REPRESENT.
.
REFERENCED IN THIS I WITH THE
STRONGEST SUPPORT THIS IS BEING
ONE OF OUR STRONGEST
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THANKS.
LEIGH ANGELA RE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PRIVATE SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SCHOOLS AND AGENCIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
IT'S NOT A TRYING TO MY RESOURCE
PARENT AND ALSO AN ADVOCATE.
AND FULL SUPPORT.
CHRIS TECHIES SUTTER COUNTY I AM
ON THIS OUT COMMUNITY VISOR IT
COMMITTEE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND A PARENT.
AND I SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WHAT THE WITNESS IS IN
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THAT WEBER.
YES I WANT TO THANK OF BALL THE
CHEER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
THIS IS SO.
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND OF THOSE OF US
WHO HAD ANY DEALINGS AT ALL WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS KNOW THAT.
OFTENTIMES THE.
SUPPORT FUNDING FOR SPECIAL ED
HAS NEVER BEEN ADEQUATE IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN LIKE SIXTY PERCENT
AND SO THEY WILL YOU HAD TO EAT
INTO THE OTHER. BUDGET TO MAKE
IT HAPPEN.
I'M ALSO SPOKE PLEASE THAT
WOULD INCLUDING PRESCHOOL HIM
THIS BECAUSE THAT IS CRITICAL
AND I THINK WAS ABOUT FOUR YEARS
AGO WHEN I CHEER AT THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES BUDGET FOR
THE STATE. THAT WE ARE BEGIN TO
REFUND EARLY START. WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT TO KIDS AND.
AT THE TIME IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING TO ME BECAUSE I HAD
NO IDEA THAT I WOULD NEED. EARLY
START WITH MY OWN GRANDSON AND.
AND SAW SO PROUD WHEN I THOUGHT
ABOUT AS A WOULD MAKE THEIR
SERVICES FOR HIM IN THE AREA OF
LANGUAGE IT'S AN AND UP HE'S IN.
A.
NOT GO HE'S IN THE MASONS
DISTRICT WHICH IS RIGHT NEXT TO
YOURS.
BUT THE INTERESTING THING IS
THAT WE NEVER KNOW WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO NEED IT AND IT MAKES A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE. IN THE
LIFE OF A CHILD WHEN WE COME IN
EARLY IN PRESCHOOL BECAUSE WHEN
THEY GET READY TO GO TO ELOP
KINDERGARTEN THEY ARE PREPARED.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S JUST A MATTER
OF A COUPLE YEARS OF SERVICE BUT
IT MAKES A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE
WHEN THEY GO TO REGULAR SCHOOL
OR.
KINDERGARTEN FIRST GRADE BECAUSE
IN THEIR ON TASK AND THEY'RE
READY WHEN IF WE HAD NOT YOU HAD
WE HAD NOT INTERVENED AS
STATE. THERE'D BE STRUGGLING
THROUGH THE MOST INFORMATIVE
YEARS OF KINDERGARTEN FIRST
SECOND THIRD GRADE SO THE EARLY
START PROGRAMS THAT WE DO. ARE
VERY IMPORTANT OUR PRESCHOOL A
SPECIAL ED ASSESSMENTS ARE JUST
CRITICAL TO THE LIFE OF OUR KIDS
AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE. THIS IS AN
AMAZING PIECE OF LEGISLATION WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO PUSH IT
I APPRECIATE IT I MOVE THAT WE
APPROVE THIS AND IF POSSIBLE
WOULD LIKE TO BE A COLOSSAL.
MISTER O'DONNELL BUDGET BECAUSE.
THEY LOVE ME.
BUT AYE YES ON THE CO
AUTHORSHIP FOR SURE. IN ANY
OTHER MEMBER.
AND I EXPECT WE ASK WHEN I.
I THINK YOU AND I THINK WE'RE
ALL VERY AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE FACE WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCING DELIVERY IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND WE GOT A FULLER
SENSE OF THE LANDSCAPE AT A.
INFORMATIONAL HEARING A FEW
WEEKS BACK I THINK THIS BILL IS
AN IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
DIRECTION OF AT LEAST ADEQUACY
AND THAT COHERENCE AND I
RECOMMEND AND I. AYE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WITH. WITH AMENDMENTS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE KALRA. KALRA
AYE MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND. THURMOND AYE WEBER AYE
WEBER AYE.
FIVE.
FIVE VOTES THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER BONTA I BELIEVE YOU'RE
UP NEXT.
ITEM THREE.
A LOT OF THAT
SIZE HERE PASSING THEM BACK AND
FORTH.
IT WAS BONTA SPILLED.
COMPILE AND. THREE.
BROWN FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
IT'S AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY.
SEVENTY ONE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES
AND STAFF THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE ROUTE
WOULD REQUIRE A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL TO PROVIDE EACH LOW
INCOME STUDENT WITH ONE
NUTRITIOUS FREE OR REDUCED
PRICED MEAL. EACH SCHOOL DAY.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED A LOT TO
PROTECT CHILDREN ROM HUNGER. BY
GUARANTEEING THAT ALTHOUGH
INCOME PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO AT LEAST
ONE NUTRITIOUS MEAL. EACH SCHOOL
DAY.
DESPITE ATTENDING PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT PROTECTED. UNDER
THIS LAW MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THOUSAND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ATTEND CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND OF THE
STUDENTS MORE THAN EIGHTY ONE
THOUSAND ATTEND. A CHARTER
SCHOOL WITHOUT ACCESS TO FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS OR IN
MANY CASES ANY MEALS. AT ALL
RESEARCHING COMMONSENSE
TELL US THAT CHILDREN MUST BE
WELL NOURISHED IN ORDER TO LEARN
GROW AND ACHIEVE THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
ACCESS TO MAIL SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY
ATTEND A TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL. OR A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
CALIFORNIA ST PARENT TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
WESTERN.
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WHILE
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION IS OPPOSE WE KNOW
THEY ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
OVERALL GOAL OF THIS BILL. AND
WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THEM AS WE HAVE ALREADY TO.
A HOPEFULLY FIND REASONABLE
SOLUTIONS AND AREAS OF COMMON
GROUND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS TRACY
PATTERSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND
CAROL BECAUSE HE FIRED
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARENT.
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ALSO A CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
GOOD EVENING.
OF.
I WAS SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA WE'RE
REALLY PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL.
MAKING SURE THAT KIDS HAVE
NUTRITIOUS MEALS ARE IT'S REALLY
PART OF THE DNA OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA. IN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES PTA CREATED
SPECIAL NUTRITION PROJECT AND
EMERGENCY SERVICES TO PREVENT
CHILDREN FROM SUFFERING DURING
THE GREAT DEPRESSION.
IN THE NINETEEN FORTIES WE
LAUNCHED A NATIONWIDE SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES WE PASSED RESOLUTIONS
URGING ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
ESTABLISH AND PROMOTE SCHOOL.
BREAKFAST AND LUNCH PROGRAMS FOR
A BALANCED NUTRITIOUS MEAL.
I'M IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN WE
WERE ONE OF MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT.
ARGUED STRONGLY FOR THE
BIPARTISAN HEALTHY HUNGER FREE
KIDS ACT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR.
MEALS ARE NUTRITIOUS.
SO WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
NUTRITIOUS MEALS FOR ALL
CHILDREN AND I THINK THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT PART NUTRITIOUS MEALS
FOR ALL CHILDREN.
UP SO WE'RE REALLY PLEASED TO
COSPONSOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION.
AND THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE I'M TRACY
PATTERSON OF CALIFORNIA FOOD
POLICY ADVOCATES WERE PROUD TO
BE CO SPONSORS OF MAYBE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY ONE. AND WE WANT TO
COMMEND ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
STRONG LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
HIS LIFELONG DEDICATION TO CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HIS COMMITMENT TO
JUSTICE FOR LOW INCOME CHILDREN
OF COLOR.
TEACHING KIDS IS HARD WORK
FEEDING KIDS IN SCHOOL ISHARD
WORK AS A FORMER TEACHER IN HIGH
NEED SCHOOLS I CAN TELL YOU
FIRST HAND HOW HARD THAT WORK
IS.
BUT I CAN ALSO TELL YOU THAT FOR
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY
SHOWING UP TO SCHOOL HUNGRY AND
TRYING TO FOCUS THEY HAVE AN
EVEN HARDER JOB THAN WE DO.
SO WE'RE FOOD ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WE GENERALLY
DON'T WADE INTO THE THORNY
POLITICS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
ABUT AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY ONE
ISN'T ABOUT POLITICS
THIS IS ABOUT A COMMITMENT TO
CALIFORNIA KIDS AND BELIEVING
THAT NO STUDENT SHOULD GO HUNGRY
AND A PUBLICLY FUNDED SCHOOL.
BY ESTABLISHING THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA THE
STATE HAS RECOGNIZED THAT
SCHOOLS NEED MORE RESOURCES TO
BETTER SERVE DISADVANTAGED
STUDENTS AND CLOSE THE
PERSISTENT ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
WITH ALL THE FF ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS RECEIVE EXTRA
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FOR THOSE
LOW INCOME CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE MEALS THAT THEY ENROLL.
HOWEVER.
CLOSE TO TWENTY PERCENT OF THOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT PROVIDE
THAT MOST BASIC SERVICE FOR
WHICH THOSE CHILDREN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
PRICE MEALS.
WE'VE BEEN IN DISCUSSION WITH
THE CHARTER SCHOOL ASSOCIATION
FOR MONTHS WE HOPE TO COME TO US
A REASONABLE SOLUTION WITH THEM
BUT I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS PUT FORWARD ABOUT
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND MEALS.
THE CHALLENGES THE FEEDING
STUDENTS ARE NOT UNIQUE TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS THESE ARE
CHALLENGES THAT ALL SCHOOLS OF
ALL SIZES AND LOCATIONS.
OVERCOME.
THIS IS A SOLVABLE PROBLEM.
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS CAN RECEIVE
STATE AND FEDERAL CATEGORICAL
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL MEALS TO THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH AND
BREAKFAST PROGRAMS THAT FUNDING
GIMME USED OPERATE STAFF AND
ADMINISTER SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAMS.
ALL CHARTERS CAN RECEIVE
NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM
EQUIPMENT FACILITIES GRANTS AND
RURAL CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN
RECEIVE WELFARE FACILITY GRANTS
AS WELL.
ALL CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN PROVIDE
NIELSEN STUDENTS IN NEED
REGARDLESS OF LOCATION
REGARDLESS OF SIZE THEY HAVE
MANY OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO THEM
PARTNERING WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IS ONLY ONE.
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WHO OUR
WITHOUT MEALS RIGHT NOW IT'S
ABOUT ALL FUTURE STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN DRUG USE AS WELL.
BUT OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEVEN
BERMAN ROUND OUT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION PLEASE TO
CO SPONSOR WHERE DO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO OUR STRAND FLORES
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
RON RAPOPORT HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT THINKING.
SARAH BOTCHES WITH CASBAH IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
CHAU GIVENS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN SUPPORT.
CAROL GREEN REPRESENTING THE
PDA'S ANGELA DISTANCE WITH WATER
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LEAH PARA CALIFORNIA FOR STATE
PTA A CO SPONSOR AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
CARLOS MACHADO WITH CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
JERRY PATT GO PRESIDENT IN
NINETEEN STRICT PDA SAN DIEGO
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
THE INJURY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NUTRITION
ASSOCIATION AS WELL SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT INSTRUCTS.
COOLER COUNTING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN STROKE ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MICHAEL MORGAN THIRTY THIRD
DISTRICT PTA IN SUPPORT.
KATHY SURE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
DANIELLE CANADA BECAUSE OUR
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
JESSICA BARTOLO WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY WHERE
SPONSOR AND STEP.
MARTHA HOWEVER SOME HAVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I OTHERS IN OP IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
AS MY CLARIFY YOU DID ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
YEAH BUT YOU ARE.
CLEVER THE ALSO INTO THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
EXCLUSIVELY VIRTUAL SCHOOLS
KNOWS WHAT ORIGINAL LOCATION OR.
BONE STRUCTURES HOMEOWNER EXEMPT
FROM THESE PROVISIONS AND
CLARIFY THE SCHOOL A.
IS ONE WHICH PUPILS ARE IN
ATTENDANCE FOR ANY PART OF THAT
DAY YES THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION WEEKS AT THE
MOMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CALLING
MILLER THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER
SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION. AND.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
CALIFORNIA SHORT SCHOOLS
CESSATION DOES SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL.
WE WE.
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY THE.
THE INTENT ON THE GOAL TO SERVE.
STUDENTS WHO WHO NEED A MALE.
THAT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE.
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
ENGAGING US ON THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
SO.
UNLESS THE BILL CAN ADDRESS
SOME VERY REAL AND SPECIFIC
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES THAT ARE
SPECIFIC TO CHARTER SCHOOLS. THE
FACT IS THAT A VAST MAJORITY OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS ALREADY ARE
PROVIDING MEALS AYE WE ESTIMATE
THAT FEWER THAN FIVE PERCENT OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS BY THIS
MEASURE.
HOWEVER.
THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
PROVIDING MALES.
OFTEN FACE VERY SIGNIFICANT
BARRIERS.
TO DOING SO WHICH MUST BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE WE CAN IMPOSE A
SIGNIFICANT NEW MANDATE.
CHARTERS INTERPERSONAL SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE THE SAME RESOURCES
THAT DISTRICTS DO IN THIS AREA.
IT'S NOT A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
PARTICULARLY WHEN A CHARTER
SCHOOL IS A LEAST FACILITY IT
MAY HAVE NO AUTHORITY TO MAKE OF
RENOVATIONS TO THAT BUILDING.
REGARDLESS OF OF POTENTIAL
GRANT FUNDS.
THEY MAY NOT HAVE ANY RESOURCES
TO DO THAT.
EVEN WHEN THE SCHOOLS HAVE
FACILITIES AND THE MEANS TO
PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES.
IT CAN TAKE UP TO A YEAR
SOMETIMES TO GET THROUGH THE RED
TAPE AND BUREAUCRACY THROUGH
LOCAL HEALTH APPROVALS AS WELL
AS I GETTING LICENSED THROUGH
THE.
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM.
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING WHEN
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE TO MOVE
FROM YEAR TO YEAR AND GET. RE
COMPLIANT WITH THEIR WITH THE
FACILITY THAT THEY'RE MOVING
INTO.
SO I WE ALSO HAVE CONCERT WITH
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION.
AROUND THE DEFINITION OF.
EXEMPTIONS FOR NON CLASSROOM
BASED ON.
STUDENTS IN SCHOOLS ON THE CODE
ALREADY HAS A CLEAR DEFINITION
OF NON CLASSROOM BASED SCHOOLS
AND.
THERE WERE.
.
WITH OUT.
WITHOUT SOME CLEAR
THE SO WE WOULD WE WOULDN'T
REALLY NEED TO HAVE SOME CLARITY
AROUND AROUND THAT ISSUE.
IF THAT INTENT OF THE BILL IS
TO PROVIDE MEALS TOLD WILL
STUDENTS I WE DO NEED TO GET
AMENDMENTS TO INCLUDE SOLUTIONS
TO INSIST CHARTER SCHOOLS. IN
OUR REALISTICALLY MEETING THAT
GOAL AND WE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CASEY TAYLOR AND FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ACHIEVE
CHARTER SCHOOLS. WE'VE BEEN
OPERATING SMALL KATE CHARTER
SCHOOL IN RURAL PARADISE LOCATED
IN BUTTE COUNTY SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WILL OPEN A
HIGHSCHOOL STARTING WITH JUST
NINTH GRADE THIS FALL.
COMMITTED DEFEATING ALL STUDENTS
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT IN SOME
OF OUR SITUATIONS ARE STUDENTS.
THE MEAL THAT WE PROVIDE THEM AS
THE ONLY HEALTHY MEAL THAT THEY
RECEIVE.
IN A DAY AND WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE SPIRIT OF THE
SPELL. HOWEVER CAN BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS TO
MEET THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM GUIDELINES ESPECIALLY IN
RURAL AREAS SO IT TOOK MY SCHOOL
THREE YEARS TO GAIN ACCESS TO
SPACE TO CREATE A WARMING
KITCHEN. TO AFFORD TO UPGRADE
THAT SPACE TO MEET NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH GUIDELINES UP TO
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND.
FACILITY UPGRADES TO ELECTRICAL
AND PLUMBING THAT THE GRANTS
DIDN'T COVER AND THEN ALSO TO
HIRE AND TRAIN STAFF TO COMPLY
WITH REPORTING IN SERVING
GUIDELINES.
A SMALL SCHOOL BY DESIGN WE OPEN
WITH NINE STAFF IN A HUNDRED
STUDENTS WITH LIMITED SPACE
STUDENTS EIGHT LUNCHEON OUR
CLASSROOMS AND WE SERVED MEALS
OUT OF THE STAFF ROOM. WITH
INADEQUATE FACILITIES AND NOT
ENOUGH STAFF TO MEET THE
TRACKING AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WE COULD NOT
QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENTS SO HE SERVED
MEALS AND SUBSIDIZE OUR STUDENTS
QUALIFYING FOR FREE AND READ OUT
REDUCED LUNCH MEALS OUT OF OUR
GENERAL FUND BUDGET. WAS THAT
IMPORTANT TO US
BY YEAR THREE THAT WE HAD THE
RESOURCES TO LEASE SPACE AND
HIRE STAFF TO MEET GUIDELINES
AND WE STARTED RECEIVING
REIMBURSEMENTS.
I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
REIMBURSEMENTS DON'T COVER THE
COSTS OF THIS PROGRAM LIKE I
SAID IT COST MY SCHOOL TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN START UP
COSTS. AND IT CURRENTLY COSTS
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
IN OPERATING COSTS INCLUDING
OVERHEAD FEES FOR A MEAL
CONTRACT.
ADDITIONAL LEASE COSTS IN THE
COST FOR A FULL TIME STAFF TO
MANAGE THE PROGRAM.
FOR THE LAST FOURTEEN YEARS
WE'VE CONTRACTED WITH OUR
AUTHORIZING DISTRICT FOR MEALS
LAST MONTH WE WERE TOLD BY THEM
THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
CONTRACTING WITH US ANY LONGER.
AS THE DISTRICT DECIDES WHO THEY
CHOOSE TO CONTRACT WITH WE'RE
NOT LEFT HIGH AND DRY SCRAMBLING
TO FIND A MEAL PROVIDER. THE
NEAREST DISTRICT JUST TWENTY
MILES AWAY FROM OUR SCHOOL AND
IF THEY'RE WILLING TO CONTRACT
THERE WILL BE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPORTATION COSTS.
IN WORLD REVIEW COUNTY WE DO NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO OUTSIDE MIL
VENDORS FOUND IN URBAN AREAS AND
PROVIDING OUR OWN MEALS WOULD WE
CRY OUT WE CHOIR AS TO BUILD A
COMMERCIAL KITCHEN. AND HIRE A
NUTRITIONAL LIST COSTING
THOUSANDS AND REQUIRING MORE
TIME A FEW BEEN THREE MONTHS WE
HAVE BEFORE SCHOOL STARTS NEXT
YEAR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
AIRED PREREQUISITE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER
REPRESENTING SEVERAL HUNDRED
SCHOOLS WERE ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
I'M I I JUST HAVE MAYBE A
COMMONER QUESTION.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN CHOOSE
WHEN YOU WANT O BE EQUAL. WHAT
I HEAR IS YOU KNOW? CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE TO BE TREATED AS
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
SO THEY WILL BE TREATED AS
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS WE
SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
EXPECTATIONS.
AS TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT'S HOW I KIND OF SEE THIS
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT SO THERE'S
SOME NUANCES WITH THE VIRTUAL
WHICH WE HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
ANYWAYS. BUT.
YEAH I I I I I STRUGGLE
SOMETHING THEY SHOULDN'T BE
PROVIDING THESE MEALS BECAUSE
THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S THE
PUBLIC PROVIDERS THE LOCAL
DISTRICT IS ALSO PROBABLY THE
POTENTIAL FIND A PRIVATE.
PROVIDER.
FOR MEALS FOR STUDENTS.
ON A MAYBE CAN OPINE ON THIS AYE
THERE IS A SCHOOL A CHARTER
SCHOOL IN LONG BEACH.
.
THAT ACTUALLY HAS A STUDENTS
LEAVE DURING LUNCH.
IT'S A STOREFRONT.
FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM AND THEY
ACTUALLY THIS YOU GOTTA YOU
GOTTA LEAVE THE SCHOOL GOTTA GO
OUT IN THE SCHOOL
STUDENTS GO FIND THEIR WAY INTO
DOWN THE STREET I WOULD I DON'T.
NOT REAL SAFE MISS IN THIS AREA
OR REALLY AND I DON'T WANT HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS WALKING AROUND THE
STREETS DOING NOTHING ANYWAYS.
AROUND NOON.
DID YOU KNOW IT IT IS THAT THE
POLICY IS THAT WITHIN THE BOUNDS
A LOT YOU KNOW YOU STILL PLAN ON
AND. I'M I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THAT SCHOOLS LIKE REALLY CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT EXHIBIT WHERE THAT
SITUATION.
THAT DYNAMIC WHERE SCHOOL HAS A
CHARTER SCHOOL HAS A STUDENTS
LEAVE IT MUCH I I DON'T KNOW I
KNOW MANY HIGH SCHOOLS HAVE
OPENED.
RAN OPEN. YOU KNOW OPEN TO
FORCE THEM ORDERS THAT ALLOW
SCHOOLS TO LEAVE I DON'T I DON'T
KNOW THE SPECIFICS HERE I CAN
SPEAK TO IT. JUST QUESTION
WHETHER WHAT WE'RE REALLY
CONCERNED MORE ABOUT THE THE THE
MORE.
THEM MORE SPECIFIC.
YOU KNOW ISSUES OF SCALE SIZE
LOCATION AND RURAL LOCATIONS.
AYE WE'VE HAD SCHOOLS THAT THAT
HAVE BASICALLY HAD TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN MALES AND AND
TRANSPORTATION.
YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THAT
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN SUCH A SMALL
RURAL AREAS AYE BUT SO SO. THERE
ARE THERE ARE TRADE OFFS FOR
EVERYTHING IN MY AND.
YOU KNOW. AS IMPORTANT AS THIS
GOAL IS.
THE IT DOES COME WITH TRADE
OFFS AND LIKELY GET SEASON IN
DOLLARS AND START OF GRANTS
ALONE. AND THEN THERE'S FACILITY
MONEY THAT FLOWS EVERY YEAR TOO
SO LET'S JUST REMIND PEOPLE IN
THE ROOM OF THAT. ARE WITHOUT
OTHERS TOWARDS ANY OF THE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO WISH TO.
THE CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR QUESTION
YEAH.
IT I APPLAUD THE THE THIS YEAR
INFORMATION OUT. I WAS NOT AWARE
THAT THE CHARTER SCHOOLS DIDN'T
PROVIDE LUNCHEON IN LOW INCOME
AREAS I THINK MOST OF THEM
PROBABLY DO I'M NOT SURE. BUT
THE RULE AREAS AND ALL THOSE
KINDS OF PLACES BUT I DO KNOW
THAT. I THINK MOST OF THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO
PROVIDE OF LUNCH FOR THE
CHILDREN BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
CENTRAL KITCHENS AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON.
YOU KNOW I WAS GO BACK TO THE
AUTHORIZES STORY AS TO WHO
AUTHORIZED THE CHARTER AND WITH
THE NOT IN AUTHORIZING THE CHART
OF THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS TAKING
CARE FEEDING KIDS IS FUNDAMENTAL
YOU KNOWESPECIALLY IN POOR
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THERE MAY
NOT BE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES THAT
I THINK MANY OF OUR CHARTIST
RESPONDED THAT. BUT IT SEEMS
THAT THERE OUGHT TO BE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE PART OF
THE AUTHORIZING AGENCY TO AT
LEAST SHARE IF IT'S IF THEY HAVE
CENTRAL KITCHENS OR WHATEVER TO.
TO ALLOW FOLKS TO I HAVE THE
BILL'S BODY AND I KNOW WE DO
THAT WITH.
WITH MANY OF OUR.
ALTERNATIVE SCHOOLS THAT ARE IN
STRIP MALLS FOR KIDS WHO ARE.
WHO BEEN A PLACED IN THESE
FACILITIES LIKE ALTERNATIVE
SCHOOLS IN THE AND THERE THE
SMALLER AND I'VE BEEN IN THOSE
PLACES WHERE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
IS DRIVE ALL THOSE PLACES AND
BRINGS LUNCH? EVERYDAY TO THOSE
STUDENTS SO THIS SHOULD BE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY.
ON THE PART OF IT AND I I NEVER
LIKED THE FIGHT THAT WE HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN BETWEEN THE CHARTER
AND WHATEVER WE CONSIDER THE
OTHERS BECAUSE. YOU ALWAYS SAY
THAT YOU KNOW WHEN THE AFRICAN
PROVERB TELLS ME WHEN TWO
ELEPHANTS FIGHT IS THE GRASS
THAT SUFFERS.
AND IN THIS CASE THE GRASS IS
THE KIDS YOU KNOW WE SHOULD NOT
BE INVOLVED IN THIS BIG
DISCUSSION ABOUT FOOD THAT IS SO
FUNDAMENTAL. AND.
AND MANY OF OUR OF FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH THINGS COME TO
PARK AND REC AND EVERYWHERE ELSE
TO PROVIDE ELECTION SO WE HAVE
TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
BECAUSE IT'S JUST THAT IMPORTANT
AND I THINK IF YOU'RE TEACHING
KIDS WILL POUR IN THIS IS
PROBABLY THE ONLY MEAL THEY
HAVE.
ARE IT IT HAS TO HAPPEN SO WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT MAKE IT
HAPPEN HOPEFULLY. IN THIS BILL
YOU GOTTA FIGURE IT OUT BUT I
DON'T THINK ANY CHILD SHOULD.
NOT HAVE A THEY'VE MEAL.
PARTICULARLY KIDS WILL POOR
BECAUSE OFTENTIMES THIS IS THEIR
MEAL.
AND I'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
KIDS ARE HUNGRY A BIT IN OTHER
COUNTRIES WHERE KIDS DON'T GET
FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH. AND THEY
SPEND ALL DAY THINKING ABOUT
FOOD AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO PICK
ABOUT LEARNING WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT FOOD. AND SO WOULD AND WE
WE'VE GOTTEN PAST THAT AT LEAST
I THOUGHT IN THIS COUNTRY. ALSO
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW THOSE
OF US WHO ADULTS.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE SURE THOSE NEEDS OF EVERY
CHILD IS MET. REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY'RE IN WHAT WE
CONSIDER THE TRADITIONAL CHARTER
A PUBLIC SCHOOL OF THE CHARTER
PUBLIC SCHOOL I KIDS DESERVE TO
HAVE THE MEAL.
MISTER KILEY YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON
OR MAYBE IT'S GOOD EVENING WEST
POINT.
MISTER BONTA.
SO THAT INTENTION HERE IS
NIGHTLY.
GOOD AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT
IT'S REALLY A. VERY RARE.
CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHERE THIS WOULD EVEN BE
RELEVANT TO A SCHOOL ON WHERE IT
IS RELEVANT THERE SEEMS A REAL
PRACTICAL?
DIFFICULTIES THERE BUT.
YOU KNOW I.I GUESS I GO BACK
TO WHEN GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED A
VERY SIMILAR BILL O. LOOKS LIKE
SIX YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW THE BASIC IDEA IS THAT
THE THE POINT OF.
CHARTERING IS TO HAVE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT REGULATED
AS PRESCRIPTIVE ONLY AS.
AS OTHER PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE SAID.
CUBAN ATTRITION IS PROFOUNDLY
IMPORTANT BUT SO ALSO IS THE
FUNDAMENTAL PREMISE OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS THEY BE FREE FROM LARGE
PORTIONS OF THE LUMINOUS STATE
EDUCATION CODE I'M RELUCTANT TO
READ THE INDEPENDENCE AND
FLEXIBILITY. THAT OF WELL SERVE
THE FAMILIES AND TEACHERS WHO
CHOOSE THEIR CHARTER SCHOOLS SO
I DO DISAGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S SENTIMENT.
I I DO. I THINK THAT THEY ARE.
.
SOME THINGS THAT ARE
FUNDAMENTAL.
AND SHOULD.
BE.
SHOULD EXIST IN BOTH CHARTER
SCHOOL PUBLIC ARTICLES AND AND
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND.
WE'VE AT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
I'VE I'VE HAD THAT.
A POSITION ON A BILL THAT I'VE
BROUGHT FORWARD AND. NOT THE
FIRST TIME THAT WE SOUGHT TO
CHANGE THE GOVERNOR'S MINE.
THAT WE CHANGE THE GOVERNOR'S MY
LAST YEAR ON A VERY SIMILAR
BILL.
THAT HE VETOED IN THE PAST AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY.
WHERE WE SOUGHT TO HAVE OF SOME
FOUNDATIONAL FUNDAMENTAL?
?
EQUITY AND FAIRNESS POLICIES
AROUND ADMISSIONS
AND DISCIPLINE.
AND I WE WORK THE TART SCHOOL SO
SHE ACTION VERY CLOSELY WE FOUND
COMMON GROUND THEY ENDED UP
SUPPORTING THE BILL. WILL DO THE
SAME THING HERE WERE NOT THERE
TODAY WHEN THE FIRST HOUSE THE
FIRST COMMITTEE. I BUT I THINK
SOME THINGS ARE SO FOUNDATIONAL
THAT YOU CAN'T PUT THEM AND
FUNDAMENTAL YOU CAN'T PUT THEM
IN THE POCKET OF.
.
YOU KNOW I ECONOMY INNOVATION.
KIDS NEED TO HAVE.
OF MEAL WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE POOR DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO ONE THE CAN'T FIGHT THE CAN'T
LEARN WHEN THE FIGHTING HUNGER.
AND SO I PUT THAT IN IN IN.
IN IN AND IN THAT CATEGORY OF
OF FUNDAMENTAL FOUNDATIONAL
NEEDS OF STUDENTS HAVE TO LEARN
WHETHER IN A PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL OR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
THE CAR.
THINKING SURE WE'RE TALKING
FEEDING CHILDREN OF THE BILL.
OTHER BILLS REMOVED AND SECOND
MINISTER THURMAN.
YOU MAY CLOSE THE MOTION IS.
.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THAT IS THE
MOTION.
.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO.
TELL YOU HAVE DISCUSSED THIS
BILL IN AND THE NEED TO FEED OUR
KIDS IN SCHOOLS WHETHER THEY BE
PUBLIC CHARTER TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC.
WE.
I APPRECIATE THAT STAFF AND THIS
COMMITTEE'S INPUT WE WILL
CONTINUE WORK WITH AT THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
ASSOCIATION ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
TO TRY TO FIND COMMON GROUND WE
THINK THAT.
WE APPRECIATE THE AGREEMENT ON
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE CHALLENGES
WITH IMPLEMENTATION WE WANT WE
WANT HELP OVERCOME THOSE
CHALLENGES AND LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
DO SO.
I RESPECT THE ASK AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE EMOTIONS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY.
KILEY KNOWS KALRA. OVER I'M
MCCARTY STEINORTH.
THURMOND.
THURMOND I WEBER. WEBER AYE.
FOR THE WOMAN FOR ONE OF THOSE
OUT.
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
WE'RE GONNA START WITH A FILE
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN EP TWENTY
SEVEN AFFORD TO BE THE FIRST OF
I BELIEVE UP FOR BILLS THAT WILL
BE HEARING FROM MATCH YOUR
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BY STRENGTHENING THE
CALIFORNIA NETWORK OF FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OH FOR HELPS
PARENTS AND STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES GAIN ACCESS TO
CRITICAL PROGRAMS AND RESOURCES
WITHOUT HAVING TO RESORT TO
LITIGATION.
GETTING SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES FOR CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES CAN BE A LONG AND
COMPLEX PROCESS THAT REQUIRES
PARENTS.
TO CONNECT WITH MANY DIFFERENT
PROVIDERS.
AS THEY WORK THROUGH ALL OF THIS
PARENTS ARE TOLD THEY HAVE TO
GET SERVICES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE EARLY
INTERVENTION IS CRITICAL FOR
THEIR CHILDREN'S LONG TERM
SUCCESS.
WELL SUPPORT THIS JOURNEY CAN BE
OVERWHELMING.
AMONG THE MANY SERVICES THEY
PROVIDE FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTERS HELP PARENTS UNDERSTAND
THEIR CHILDREN'S DISABILITIES.
CONNECT THEM WITH PROVIDERS AND
SERVICES AND WALK THEM THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF GETTING
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PROGRAMS THE EYEPIECE COMPLETED.
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS ALSO
HELP RESOLVE DISAGREEMENTS
BETWEEN PARENTS AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BEFORE DISPUTES
ESCALATE TO THE POINT OF A JUDGE
REQUIRED. DENIED A JUDGE BEING
REQUIRED TO INTERVENE.
IT HELPS STOP LITIGATION.
WHEN FAMILY APPARENT CENTERS
WERE CREATED THE LEGISLATURE
INTENDED FOR THERE TO BE THIRTY
TO CENTERS BUT OVER THE PAST
SIXTEEN YEARS ONLY FOURTEEN HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISHED.
THIS MEANS THAT MANY FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA LACK ACCESS TO FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN OF FOUR WILL
HELP US BRING IMPORTANT SERVICES
THAT FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTERS
PROVIDE A MORE FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL ARE MAUREEN
O'LEARY BIT.
BURN ES
FORMER CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE WIDE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TASK FORCE.
AND JUST SANA HOPE I SAID THAT
RIGHT IF NOT CORRECT ME JUST ANA
TRAN. FROM THE FAMILY SUIT. A
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER IN
YUBA CITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON OR EVENING COULD YOU
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY TAROT
DONALD THANK YOU FOR THE SPELL.
I AM MARINO WARY BURN US THE
RETIRED CO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE SPECIAL
EDUCATION TASK FORCE I RETIRED
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
SOMEPLACE HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA. I AM HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN OH
FOR.
OUR TASK FORCE MADE MANY
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING
SEVERAL ABOUT WAYS TO SUPPORT
FAMILIES IN THE VERY COMPLEX
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROCESS
REQUIRED IN LAW.
SPECIFIC TO THIS BILL OUR
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO QUOTE
FULLY FUND FAMILY EMPOWERMENT
CENTER STATEWIDE HAS ALREADY
LEGISLATED IN S. B. FIVE ELEVEN
SO THAT EACH OF THE THIRTY TWO
S. B. C. REGION'S HOUSE A
CENTER.
A RATIONALE FOR THIS WAS THAT
NPC'S PROVIDE PARENTS SUPPORT.
HELP THEM NAVIGATE THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM OFFER TRAINING
ON BOTH I F. S. P. PLANS FOR
BIRTH TO THREE. AND AYE EP'S FOR
CHILDREN AGED THREE TO TWENTY
TWO.
INFORM THEM OF THEIR PARENTS
RIGHTS AND THEY GIVE INFORMATION
ON SERVICES AND COLLABORATIVE
RESOURCES.
THE EXISTING NPCS ARE DESIGNED
TO OPERATE AS PARTNERS WITH THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION SYSTEM. TO
HELP PARENTS GAIN THE SKILLS
THEY NEED TO BE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE SYSTEM IN AND
FORMED AN INSTRUCTIVE WAY.
THEREBY SUPPORTING THEIR CHILD
AND ASSISTING EDUCATORS AND
KNOWING THEIR CHILD AND THE
CHILD'S NEEDS.
PARENT ENGAGEMENT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE
EDUCATIONAL PROCESS AND THE FEC
SUPPORT EFFECTIVE PARENT
ENGAGEMENT.
ONE PART OF OUR RECOMMENDATION%
ALSO INCLUDED THAT THERE BE A
DATA COLLECTION ELEMENT REQUIRED
TO SPORTS ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS AND SUPPORTS
OFFERED AND THAT IS IN THIS
BILL.
OUR TASK FORCE MEMBERS INCLUDED
MANY PARENTS AND STAKEHOLDERS
CONCERNED ABOUT IMPROVED SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES AND RESULTS
FROM ANY RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MIGHT MAKE. WE HAD RECOGNIZE
THAT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
PROCESS HAS BECOME AS REFERENCED
IN TOO MANY CASES. LITIGIOUS
RATHER THAN COLLABORATIVE AND WE
FELT THAT THE WORK OF THE FCC'S
WOULD BENEFIT EVERYONE ON THE
PROCESS NOT JUST FAMILIES. BUT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THE SCHOOL
SITES ANSEL POSE WITH WHICH
FAMILIES WORK.
THIS IS WHAT IS DONE ARE FEW
CURRENT FTC'S NOW BY FOSTERING
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN FAMILIES AND STAFF. BY
HELPING PARENTS RESOLVE THEIR
CONCERNS OR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
HAVING TO RESORT TO LITIGIOUS
MEASURES. AND SUPPORTING THE
ROLE AS PARTNER IN THE PROCESS
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT BENEFIT
THE CHILD. THE GOAL IS A BETTER
MORE EFFECTIVE IN INFORMED
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE SYSTEM
SO THAT EACH CHILD'S NEEDS CAN
BE BEST ADDRESSED IN A
COLLABORATIVE LEARNING PROCESS.
HI GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT AND ALSO
AS A REPRIEVE STATE.
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS.
MY NAME IS JUST ON A TRIED AND I
HAVE TWO SONS AND TWENTY YEAR
OLD AND A NINE YEAR OLD. BOTH IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION I AM ALSO A
RESOURCE PARENT FOR FAMILY SOUP
FAMILY RESEARCH SECTARIAN BUS
AB.
TO SHOW YOU HOW IMPORTANT FAMILY
APARTMENTS TEXTURES ARE I WANT
TO SHARE WITH YOU MY FAMILY'S
JOURNEY FROM DIAGNOSIS TO WHERE
THEY ARE NOW.
MY OLDEST SON WAS DIAGNOSED LATE
AT THREE YEARS OLD. THAT MAY
SOUND NOT LATE T. YOU. HOWEVER.
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE BECAUSE
OF EARLY INTERVENTION HAS SO
MANY BENEFITS.
OUR PEDIATRICIAN AT THAT TIME
KEPT TELLING ME THAT HE WAS A
LATE BLOOMER. BUT I KNEW THAT
THERE WAS A LOT MORE GOING ON.
AFTER MUCH PUSHING I FINALLY GOT
A REFERRAL TO SEE A NEUROLOGIST
WHICH HELP IS THE CUT DISCOVERY.
THAT HE HAS FRAGILE X. SYNDROME
WHICH IS A CHROMOSOME DISORDER
AND AND HE ALSO HAS AUTISM.
WE HAD A DIAGNOSIS OF BUT THERE
WAS NO RESOURCES FOR PARENT TO
PARENT SUPPORT. NO ONE GUIDED ME
AT THAT TIME. I'VE FIRST FELT
ALONE IN THE WORLD THAT I KNEW
NOTHING ABOUT.
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW THAT A
DIAGNOSIS DOES NOT MEAN
EVERYTHING WILL FALL INTO PLACE.
A DIAGNOSIS IS ONLY THE
BEGINNING OF A LONG DIFFICULT
AND CONFUSING JOURNEY. TOWARDS
GETTING THIS SERVICE AS A CHILD
NEEDS.
SERVICES THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR.
MY STEINORTH BUT THEY WERE IN IT
IS FOR EVERY OTHER CHILD. FIRST
OUT TORIES GETTING.
TWO DIFFERENT SYSTEMS A MEDICAL
SYSTEM A SYSTEM FOR HOME
TREATMENT IS SYSTEM FOR
EDUCATION.
FOR ME WITHOUT SUPPORT IT TOOK
MANY REFERRALS ASKING QUESTIONS
DOING MY OWN RESEARCH. MAKING
MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS AND
CONTACTING SPECIALIST TO FIGURE
IT ALL OUT.
AFTER WONDER HOW MUCH MORE MY
SON COULD HAVE LEARNING THOSE
FIRST FEW YEARS IF WE BEGUN. A
GUIDED.
THROUGH A FAMILY PARM CENTER.
MY OLDEST SON WHO LOST THREE
YEARS OF EARLY INTERVENTION BY
WITH MY YOUNGEST SON WHO HAD THE
SUPPORT EXPERIENCE A FAMILY
SOUP.
ANY MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE MY
YOUNGEST SON.
STARTED INTERVENTION.
WHEN HE WAS TO.
TALKING.
I HAVE SEEN MY OWN FAMILY THE
BENEFITS OF EARLY INTERVENTION
AND THE BENEFITS.
TURN
TODAY FAMILY SOUP SUPPORTERS.
OUR WHOLE FAMILY WITH PROGRAMS
FOR PARENTS ASSEMBLY IN CHILDREN
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITY. WE
FEEL BEYOND BLESS TO US FAMILY
SERVICE MY EXTENDED FAMILY.
THEY DURING AS A PARENT OF THE
CHILD ESPECIALLY NEVER AND THIS
AND THAT BRINGS LOTS OF
CHALLENGES BUT WITH SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE WE CAN MAKE SURE OUR
KIDS ARE SET UP TO SUCCEED.
LARRY SUCCESS I RESPECTFULLY
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS AB
TWENTY SEVEN OH FOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH OTHER
ROW WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THEN ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF
THE SELF BUT MINISTRY YEARS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
YEAH I DAVE LAWRENCE ICAC MEMBER
ARE SELF LOVE FREMONT NEWARK
UNION CITY.
I'M IN SUPPORT I'M A GRANDFATHER
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S A DAUNTING
TASK IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO GET
THROUGH.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A SUPPORT
GROUP.
EVELYN ABU HASSEN DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
TRUTH ANDERSON NAY ARKIN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLYMAN KILEY
I AM A PARENT AND A CONSTITUENTS
I AM.
IN VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND I AM ESPECIALLY
APPRECIATE BETTER REQUIRES
NOTIFICATION TO PARENTS OF THE
SERVICE.
ACCOUNTABILITY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INCREASED SUPPORT IP'S AND
REPORTING ON ISSUES THAT ARE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
HOW MUCH TOSS IT BACK BLACK SILK
DIRECTOR FOR NAPA COUNTY SELF
BUT?
SUPPORT.
VERONICA CODES TO HIM COUNTY
SUBDIRECTOR SUPPORT.
AND DIDN'T PELLETIER DIRECTOR
FOR SAN MATEO COUNTY SILVA WE
SUPPORT.
YOU HAVE TO ACOSTA OF REASON
INVEST SOCIAL EDUCATION
COALITION AND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN MEMBERS AND SUPPORT.
ANDREW ON B. SOLANO COUNTY
SPECIAL EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN
AREA AND PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
THE BILL DISABILITIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CINDY CHANDLER FAMILY SOUP
FORMER MEMBER OF THE STATEWIDE
TASK FORCE AND PARENT STRONG IN
DURING SUPPORT. WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
KELLY YOUNG HAVE PARENT OF A
YOUNG WOMAN IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND WITH A DISABILITY AND ALSO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ONE LINE
FAMILY RESOURCE CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. NOT AN FEC STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE LAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS THANK YOU.
CHRIS HICKEY I'M A PARENT AND I
ALSO WORK AT FAMILY SOUP AND
FAMILY EMPOWERMENT CENTER AND
THE EARLY START DIRECTOR AND I
HOPE OTHER FAMILIES OUT THANK
YOU JUST ON.
SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MISTER DONALD DUCK CLOSE.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS BILL MAKES A VERY
POSITIVE CHANGES PARTICULARLY
WHEN IT COMES TO DATA COLLECTION
AND OUTCOME MEASUREMENT I AM
PLEASED TO SUPPORT IT THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. O'DONNELL
GUY O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE
KILEY AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE
MCCARTY STEINORTH. THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE WEBER WEBER AYE. BY
BOTH.
THE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO ALL THE
WITNESSES AND NEXT UP WE HAVE A
BE TWO SEVEN THREE FIVE.
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN RESULT
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THEM
AS NOTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
FIVE PROHIBITS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS.
ENGLISH LEARNERS SOME BEING
EXCLUDED FROM THE CORE
CURRICULUM COURSES OF OUR MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL.
RESEARCH OVER MANY DECADES SHOWS
THAT ENGLISH LEARNERS EXPERIENCE
LIMITS ON THEIR OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN.
ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE LESS LIKELY
THAN NON ENGLISH LEARNERS TO BE
ENROLLED IN CORE COURSES IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
MATHEMATICS SOCIAL STUDIES AND
SCIENCE.
EVEN ONE CONTROLLING FOR PRIOR
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT.
IN SOME CASES ENGLISH LEARNERS
ARE PLACED IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT COURSES INSTEAD OF
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS COURSES.
IN OTHER CASES ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE PLACED IN
REMEDIAL COURSES.
DO NOT PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
FULL CURRICULUM.
SOME STUDENTS ARE ACTUALLY
TRAPPED.
TOLL THAT THEY CANNOT TAKE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS COURSES
UNTIL THEY'RE RECLASSIFIED BUT
ABLE TO RECLASSIFY DUE TO A LACK
OF PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS.
THIS IS NOT A RARE OCCURRENCE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SURE IN FACT THE
NUMBER ONE COMPLIANCE FINING IN
THE CD'S MONITORING OF DISTRICTS
REGARDING ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS ENGLISH LEARNERS IS
ACCESS TO THE CORE. CURRICULUM.
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS THE DENIAL
OF ENGLISH LEARNERS EQUAL
PARTICIPATION IN THE CORE
CURRICULUM OF SCHOOLS.
BUT IT ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO
WITHHOLD CORE CURRICULUM COURSES
IF THEY CHOOSE TO FOCUS FIRST.
ON ENGLISH ACQUISITION.
ANY TEACHER WILL TELL YOU THAT
BY THE TIME THE STUDENTS ARE
FINALLY ALLOWED TO TAKE CORE
COURSES
THEY'RE SIMPLY TOO FAR BEHIND TO
CATCH UP THEY WILL GRADUATE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE MESA
CLEAR THAT ENGLISH LEARNER
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE CORE
CURRICULUM. IN OUR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL ISN'T IS A NECESSARY
STEP FOR ENSURING THAT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN AND
SUCCEED.
CALIFORNIA EDUCATES ONE OF THREE
ENGLISH LEARNERS IN THE UNITED
STATES ONE IN THREE IS IN THIS
STATE.
EACH ONE DESERVES AN EDUCATION
WORTHY OF THEIR ATTENTION.
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I'VE.
WITH ME TODAY I OF MARTHA SIR GO
CITY AS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF%
BILINGUAL EDUCATORS AND I HAVE
AS WELL GARCIA LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARTHA
SARAH GOES THE DS AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
GATHER AND WE ARE THE SPONSORS
OF THE BILL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE IS A
STRAIGHT FORWARD BILL. IT
PROPOSES TO SOLVE A PROBLEM
FACED BY MANY ENGLISH LEARNERS
THAT OF UNEQUAL ACCESS TO THE
CORE. ACADEMIC SUBJECTS SUCH AS
SCIENCE AND HISTORIES OF SOCIAL.
HISTORY AND SOCIAL SCIENCE.
DUE TO THEIR EMAIL STATUS
FROM MARK OUR MEMBERSHIP WE KNOW
THIS IS HAPPENING.
DUE TO THEIR STATUS THE SPEND
THE MAJORITY OF THEIR TIME
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME IN EITHER IN
ENGLISH LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT OF
ANY LA OR IN MATH.
OFTENTIMES THEY'RE PLACED IN
INTERVENTION CLASSES THAT ARE
NOT DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THEIR
LANGUAGE OR ACADEMIC NEEDS.
AS A RESULT A SIZEABLE GAP IN
INSTRUCTION OCCURS.
LEADING TO ENGLISH LEARNERS
BURNING A FEW CREDITS FOR
GRADUATION AND BEING PREVENTED
FROM BEING RECLASSIFIED.
MUCH RESEARCH EXISTS CONFIRMING
THIS PATTERN OF EXCLUSION FROM
MORE ACADEMIC CLASSES AS RISK AS
REFLECTED IN THE COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS ON PAGE SIX.
IN ONE TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
STUDY IN A LARGE SCHOOL DISTRICT
FORTY SIX PERCENT OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS WORD NOT ENROLLED IN AT
LEAST ONE CORE CURRICULUM. AREA
COMPARED TO FIVE PERCENT OF NON
ENGLISH LEARNERS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY FIVE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
PROHIBITING AN ENGLISH LEARNER
STUDENT FROM BEING DENIED
ENROLLMENT.
IN A CORE CURRICULUM COURSE.
AND COURSES REQUIRED FOR HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION EXCEPT FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN NEWCOMER PROGRAMS.
LET'S ENSURE OUR ENGLISH
LEARNERS HAVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN IN OUR SCHOOLS PLEASE
VOTE YES ON AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
ISABEL GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
WERE URGING YOUR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS SPELL AS SO ELOQUENTLY
THE PROBLEM HAS BEEN LAID OUT
WITH.
THERE ARE CHAIRMAN AND THE
SPONSORS AND CT BELIEVES THAT
ALL STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO ALL EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING A RIGOROUS AND
RELEVANT COLLEGE AND CAREER. UP
CURRICULUM THAT PREPARES THEM
FOR SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE AND
ALL ENGLISH LEARNERS SHOULD TO
SIR TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
QUIRK. COURSES THAT EVERY OTHER
STUDENTS IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
HAS
ON I AS AN ENGLISH LAWYER. AND
YOU KNOW THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR STUDENTS TO HAVE THE JOY OF
LEARNING AND TO BE MOTIVATED TO
AND FEEL THAT THEY'RE NOT BEING
LEFT BEHIND.
ENGLISH LEARNERS SHOULD NOT BE
RELEGATED TO REMEDIAL COURSES
INTO NIGHT ACCESS TO THE CORE
CURRICULUM.
.
FOR JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE
LINGUISTICALLY DIFFERENT.
ON THE SO UP WITH ALL THE
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED
IN EVERYTHING. WE FEEL THIS BILL
IS ESSENTIAL TO GUARANTEEING
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
CORPORATE COMMAND THE ADVANCED
COURSES THEY NEED TO SUCCEED SO
WE URGE YOUR STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LATINO
SUPERINTENDENTS AND
ADMINISTRATORS. AS WELL AS COULD
TEACH ALL OVER TWO THOUSAND ESL
TEACHERS WERE IN SPORTS.
GOOD EVENING JESSICA SOCCER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SCIENCE TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
SUE BANG ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TOM TARA LOOKS AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
MY FATHER DOESN'T ON AS AN ALLY
FALLING DEFERRED ARE A TERM PART
OF THE BILL OF FOR ACT
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS THINKING.
JEFF BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT.
LEIGH ANGELA READ ON BEHALF OF
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND THE SAME BURGUNDY
NOW COUNTY DISTRICT ADVOCATES
FOR BETTER SCHOOLS.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I WE ALREADY HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND AMSTERDAM OBJECT BECAUSE
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE PLEASE.
THIS IS A.
A VERY GOOD PRO EQUITY MEASURE.
AND I I. BELIEVE IT'S WORTHY OF
SUPPORT THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS UP WAS
CALL THE ROLL. O'DONNELL.
I O'DONNELL AYE KILEY AYE KILEY
AYE KALRA. KALRA AYE MCCARTY
STEINORTH THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER. WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
EXTRA DOLLARS NEXT MAIL IS A. B.
TWO SEVEN SIX THREE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE.
MY LAST ONE.
NONE OF US ONE MORE AFTER THIS.
IT'S VOTE FOR IT CRY I'M HERE WE
GO.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS A BE TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY THREE. REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A
STANDARDIZED PROTOCOL TO HELP
TEACHERS EVALUATE STUDENTS
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY. FOR USE AND
RE CLASSIFICATION DECISIONS.
CURRENT LAW ESTABLISHES FOUR
CRITERIA FOR THE CAN BECAUSE OF
CREATION OF ENGLISH LEARNERS AS
FULLY FOR OPPRESSION.
ONE OF THESE CRITERIA THE
TEACHERS EVALUATION ENGLISH
LEARNERS PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH.
WELL THIS EVALUATION HIGHLY
CONSEQUENTIAL FOR STUDENTS THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED NO TOOLS
LEADER NOT NO TOOLS OR GUIDANCE
TO TEACHERS ON HOW TO MAKE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AS A RESULT THESE EVALUATIONS
VARY WIDELY FROM SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND EVEN FROM CLASSROOM TO
CLASSROOM.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT FACTORS
UNRELATED TO ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
SUCH AS BEHAVIOR ATTENDANCE AND
HOMEWORK COMPLETION ARE
FREQUENTLY INCLUDED AND HOLD
BACK STUDENTS FROM ACROSS A
FINE.
IS NOT GOOD.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THESE
FACTORS AS A
THESE FACTORS A KEY REASON WHY
SOME ENGLISH LEARNERS WHO TEST
PROFICIENT ON BOTH ENGLISH.
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT AN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS ASSESSMENTS ARE
NOT RECLASSIFIED.
WE NEED A BETTER STANDARD.
THE FEDERAL EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT SO REQUIRES THAT
STATES ADOPT STANDARDIZE RE
CLASSIFICATION PROCEDURES THAT
ARE REVISED A SUPPLANT COMMITS
TO DEVELOPING THIS PROTOCOL.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE WILL
MEET TEACHERS NEED FOR A
STANDARDIZED FOR STANDARDIZED
STANDARDS ALIGNED PROTOCOL FOR
MEASURING THEIR STUDENT'S
PROFICIENCY IN ENGLISH.
EVENTUALLY MAKING RE
CLASSIFICATION MORE CONSISTENT
AND FAIR PROCESS FOR ALL WITH ME
IN SUPPORT I HAVE SHE LOANING
CREWS GONZALEZ BOARD PRED WARD
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE ZOO SO
UNIFIED.
SCHOOL DISTRICT REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER. AND SUE
BANG.
FROM.
SUPERINTENDENT TOM PRODUCTIONS
OFFICE.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MISTER CHAIR
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS MONEY
MACHINE RUNNING CHRIS GONZALEZ.
AND I'M HERE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA ITS TOGETHER BUT I'M
ALSO SPEAKING AS A SIXTEEN YEAR
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER.
I AM PLEASED TO SPEAK TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
THREE.
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS REQUEST WE
CLASSIFICATION IS A CRITICAL
MILESTONE REPRESENTING THE
CULMINATION OF YEARS OF WORK IN
DEVELOPING LINGERS THE ENGLISH
SKILLS NECESSARY TO PARTICIPATE
IN SCHOOL LIKE OTHER CHILDREN.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT AN
ABSENCE OF STATE GUIDANCE THE
INPUT THAT TEACHERS PROVIDE IN
THE REQUEST OF THE HAITIAN
PROCESS IS INCONSISTENT.
AND OFTEN INVOLVES FACTORS
IRRELEVANT TO THEIR ENGLISH AN
ACADEMIC PROFICIENCY.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE FOUND
IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WE TOOK A VERY
HARD LOOK AT OUR WE
CLASSIFICATION PROCESS. AND
FOUND THAT SOME SCHOOLS WERE
USING FACTORS THAT WERE JUST
SYSTEM EXPLAINED BY BY
ASSEMBLYMAN O'DONNELL.
AFFECTED LIKE ATTNDANCE
BEHAVIOR AND HOMER COMPLETION
WERE SOMETIMES OVERRIDING THE
STUDENT'S PERFORMANCE ON
STANDARDIZED TESTS.
IN OTHER SCHOOLS WE FOUND THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
THEY MAY HAVE HAD MUCH HIGHER
CLASSIFICATION RATES.
BUT THOSE STUDENTS RISK WERE
STRUGGLING MORE ONCE THEY
RECLASSIFIED.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAD ADOPTED BOARD
POLICY MISUNDERSTANDING R.
HIGHLY CONSEQUENTIAL AFFECTS ON
THE STUDENTS.
WE THEN REVAMPS OUR PROCESS SO
THAT WITH GREATER CONSISTENCY
AND HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES I HAVE LAID OUT. AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY THREE DIRECTS
DEVELOPMENT OF VALIDATED HIGH
QUALITY CONCERT CONSTRUCT
RELEVANT LANGUAGE USE
OBSERVATION PROTOCOL FOR
TEACHERS USED.
IT WILL ALSO MOVE THE STATE
TOWARD THE MORE CONSISTENT. AND
FAIR CLASSIFICATION SYSTEM ENEMY
EVEN SERVE TO YOU TO BE USED AS
A USEFUL FORMATIVE MEASURE SO
THAT TEACHERS CAN MORE
ACCURATELY TRACK THEIR STUDENTS
PROGRESS IN ENGLISH.
THE STATE'S NEW ENGLISH LEARNER
ROAD SETS OUT THE STATE SAYS
THAT THE STATE'S VISION FOR
ENGLISH LEARNERS. THAT THEY I
QUOTE MEANINGFUL ACCESS AND
PARTICIPATE IN A TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY EDUCATION.
THAT RESULTS IN THE RETAINING
HIGH LEVELS OF ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY MASTERY OF GRADE
LEVEL STANDARDS AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP
PROFICIENCY IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES.
TO REALIZE HIS VISION THE STATE
NEEDS EVERY CLASSIFICATION
SYSTEM THAT IS CONSISTENT FAIR
AND SAID STUDENTS ON A PATH TO
SUCCESS. I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL ON A HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
GOOD EVENING SUE BANG ON BEHALF
OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TOM TAREQ
SEND IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
AS A TOMORROW DON'T MENTION
FEDERAL LAW UNDER EVER SINCE THE
SEATS ACT REQUIRES STATES TO
IMPLEMENT A STANDARD I
STATEWIDE.
CRITERIA FOR THE CLASSIFICATION
OF ENGLISH LEARNERS
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW
CALIFORNIA THE CALVET PART OF
EDUCATION WILL NEED TO DEVELOP.
THIS OBSERVATION PROTOCOL TO
ALL.
I'M.
WE HAVE SUBMITTED A BUDGET
REQUEST TO USE FEDERAL CARRYOVER
FUNDS TO DEVELOP THIS
OBSERVATION PROTOCOL SO A. B.
M..
TRUTH ON SIX THREE IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S WORK TO A
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL LAW WE URGE
YOUR SON SUPPORTING EITHER THINK
YOU.
THREE OF OTHER WITNESSES OF
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON MARK THAT ARE PRESENT
WOULD BE HEALTH ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR THE
BILL THINK IT'S TIME EFFORT ALL
THE WORK OVER THE PAST TWELVE
MONTHS.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS OR A
STRONG SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON WE HAVE THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTIN'S MORE.
MARTHA ZERO GOES IDEAS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR BILINGUAL EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NOT TO TRY TO SUSPEND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M SURE DONALD AT CLOSE.
AB AS FERNANDO.
THIS RELY CLASSIFICATION PROCESS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND I
THINK THIS BILL IS GOING TO BE A
VALUABLE RESOURCE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ALSO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL LAW SOME VERY HAPPY
SUPPORTED THE MOTION IS. DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY ARE
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
STEINORTH. THURMOND AREA.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER I. THE BILL IS OUT.
AND.
FINALLY WEHAVE EVEN THE THIRTY
ONE THE SIXTY SEVEN ITEM THIRTY
FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS THIS BILL CONTINUES THE
WORK OF THE CHARTER AUTHORIZED
OR REGIONAL SUPPORT NETWORK
KNOWN AS CARS NET. BY PROVIDING
UP TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
STATE FUNDING OVER FIVE YEARS.
THIS FUNDING WILL ALLOW CARS NET
TO CONTINUE THE MODEL THEY
STARTED WITH TRAINEES OF
CONFERENCES FOR CHARTER
AUTHORIZES AUTHORIZES TO IMPROVE
THEIR PRACTICE.
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZES HAVE
VERY FEW RESOURCES FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT HERE FOR
THEIR THE CHARTER AUTHORIZING
NETWORK AND OVERSIGHT. WORK.
FEW CHARTER AUTHORIZES HAVE
STAFF THAT IS SOLELY FOCUSED ON
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZING AND
OVERSIGHT.
AND MOST OF AUTHORIZED HERS AND
MOST AUTHORIZES ARE SO SMALL
THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE ANY
DEDICATED. CHARTER SCHOOL STAFF.
THESE AUTHORIZES HAVE RELIED ON
THE ASSISTANCE OF CARS NET FOR
THE PAST THREE YEARS WHILE THE
PROGRAM WAS FUNDED BY A FEDERAL
GRAND.
THE FEDERAL GRANT FUNDING
EXPIRES THIS YEAR AND WITHOUT
STATE RESOURCES THE CAR'S NOT
EXPERT CARS NOT EXPERTISE WILL
BE LOST IN AUTHORIZES WILL NOT
HAVE A RESOURCE FOR BEST
PRACTICES. AND TOOLS FOR
AUTHORIZING OVERSIGHT.
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THE BILL DIRECTS CARS NET TO
FOCUS ON RECRUITING AND
PROVIDING FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
TO DISTRICTS THAT HAVE NOT
PARTICIPATED IN TRAININGS AND
CONFERENCES IN THE PAST.
THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES AN
EVALUATION SO WE CAN MEASURE
CARS NOT SUCCESS IN THE FUTURE
AND I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND I HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE
TODAY.
AND GET AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM INTERESTED POLICY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES AT THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. RESPONSIBLE ALONGSIDE
MY TEAM FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE CARS NET FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS.
I WISH TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL FOR HIS AUTHORING
THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
THE WORK OF CARS NET. IT HAS
ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WITH THE SUPPORT AND
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED TO BE
WELL INFORMED ABOUT SOUND
AUTHORIZING PRACTICES AND TO
OVERSEE THE ACADEMIC GOVERNANCE
AND FISCAL OPERATIONS. OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WE'VE SUPPORT HUNDREDS OF SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS SUPERINTENDENTS
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENTS AND
CHARTER AUTHORIZING STAFF WITH
THE RESEARCH BASED BEST
PRACTICES THROUGH VARIOUS
COMPONENTS.
INCLUDING COMPREHENSIVE
TRAININGS FOR NEW AND
EXPERIENCED AUTHORIZED HERS. AND
ALSO VETERANS WHO ARE READY TO
TAKE MORE ADVANCED TASKS
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS OUR CARS NOT
BOOT CAMP IN MASTER CLASSES.
FOR USE OF EPICENTER WHICH IS A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED WEB BASED
CHARTER OVERSIGHT TOOL ADAPTED
TO CALIFORNIA'S LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
A WEBSITE WITH DOWNLOADABLE
OVERSIGHT RESOURCES.
AND AN ANNUAL CONFERENCE FOR
DISTRICT A COUNTY OFFICE CHARTER
AUTHORIZING STAFF AND BOARD
MEMBERS.
FINALLY ARE REGIONAL SUPPORT
NETWORKS TO ADDRESS HOT TOPIC
ISSUES
OF CONCERN THROUGH MEETINGS
TRAININGS AND TELECONFERENCES.
CARSON ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
REGIONAL SUPPORT NETWORK LED BY
EXPERIENCED AUTHORIZE OURS HAS
BEEN A GREAT STRENGTH OF OUR
PROGRAM.
WITHOUT RIEF BACKGROUND I WILL
NOT HUNDRED OVER TO
SUPERINTENDENT MONROE. AND
ENCOURAGE YOU TO PASS A B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
TO CONTINUE THE IMPROVEMENT OF
CHARTER AUTHORIZING IN
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TIME KAREN MONROE ARMY ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS.
AND I TOO WISH TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL FIRST
LEADERSHIP AND OFFERING. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
FUTURE FUNDING OF CARS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO SUBSTANTIALLY BUILT
UPON THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
STARTED TO THROUGH THE PILOT.
BECAUSE THIS GRANT WILL ENSURE
HIGH QUALITY CHARTER SCHOOL
AUTHORIZING IN THE STATE IT WILL
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF REGIONAL
NETWORK LEADS FROM SIX TO
ELEVEN.
BUT COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
AND IT WILL FURTHER THE REGIONAL
NETWORK LEADS.
AND DEVELOP FISCAL QUALITY
ACADEMIC.
I AM GOVERNMENT'S AUTHORIZING
OVERSIGHT AND MONITORING TOOLS.
IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
ALLEYWAYS TO ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN ARE SERVED BY TURNED
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE SERVED BY
CHARTER SCHOOLS RECEIVE.
HEIGHTENED THE HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF ELEAZAR
ONLY OVERSEE ONE OR TWO CHARTERS
AND. REALLY NEED SUPPORT IN
NAVIGATING THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE PETITION REVIEW PROCESS AND
CHARTER OVERSIGHT.
EASY WAYS CORE BELIEFS AND
STARTING CARS NOW DOWN WISHING
TO CONTINUE THIS WORK ARE
THREEFOLD.
OUR FIRST CORE BELIEF IS THAT
EFFECTIVE AUTHORIZES SHOULD A
ONLY APPROVED APPLICATIONS FOR
NEW CHARTERS THAT ARE LIKELY TO
SUCCEED.
B. IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS PROBLEMS
AND OPERATIONS AND FINANCE
THROUGH CONSISTENT MONITORING.
SEE HOLD SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
IMPROVING STUDENT OUTCOMES
THROUGH A RIGOROUS RENEWAL
PROCESS.
OUR SECOND CORE BELIEF IS THAT
THE IMPROVEMENT OF AUTHORIZING
PRACTICE IMPROVES THE ABILITY OF
AUTHORIZES TO EFFECTIVELY ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS SERVED BY THE
SCHOOLS ARE RECEIVING A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION.
OUR THIRD CORE BELIEF IS THAT A
RIGOROUS AND WELL MANAGED
PETITION PROCESS AND CONSISTENT
OVERSIGHT PRACTICES. ARE KEY NOT
ONLY FOR ENSURING POSITIVE
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES.
BUT FOR FISCALLY SOUND FOR
FISCAL SOUND GOVERNANCE AND
OPERATIONS OF CHARTER SCHOOLS
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY TO
CALIFORNIA'S TAXPAYERS AND FOR
THE BENEFIT OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN.
I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PASS A B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY SEVEN
TO CONTINUE THE IMPROVEMENT OF
CHARTER AUTHORIZING IN
CALIFORNIA THINK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CASBAH IN SUPPORT.
THE INJURY TO BE HALF OF THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS.
IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I WILL BRING IT BACK AT THE
COMMITTEE I AM.
MR O'DONNELL I I I CERTAINLY.
AGREE THE CARS THAT HAS DONE A
REALLY GOOD AND IMPORTANT WORK.
AND.
AND MORE ATTENTION TO IMPROVING
THAT THE QUALITY AND AND.
EXPERTISE BEHIND CHARTER
AUTHORIZING IS IS WELCOME I DO
HAVE A FEW OUT QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH AND I GUESS
MY CONCERN WOULD BE THAT IT'S A
PRETTY RAPID SCALE UP IN A WAY
THAT MAYBE IS NOT IS FIRMLY
ANCHORED TO.
WHITE CARS AND HAS DONE SO FAR
SO YOU COULD HELP ADDRESS A FEW
THOSE CONCERNS THAT MIGHT BE.
HELPFUL.
DO YOU OUT HOW HOW EXACTLY ARE
WE GOING TO BE MEASURING.
THE THE WORK THAT TIME THAT IS
GOING TO BE STARTED UMBER THE
EXPANSION.
UNDER THE UNDER THIS BILL I'M
LIKE SPECIFICALLY WHAT I KIND OF
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE'RE SEEKING.
THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA START
SEEING FROM CHARTER SCHOOL
AUTHORIZES WHO WERE ASSISTED IN
HOW ARE WE GOING TO MEASURE
THOSE OUT.
VERY WELL THANK YOU JUST
JUMBOTRON OF THE SECRETARY JUST
TO UNDERSTAND THIS PROGRAM IS
ALREADY IN EXISTENCE IS UP AND
RUNNING HAS BEEN FOR SOME TIME
SO THEY HAVE DEVELOPED A LEVEL
OF EXPERTISE. NOW THEY WISH TO
EXPAND ON THAT.
AND I WAS JUST GOING TO BUILD ON
THAT VERY POINT SO WE FOR YEARS
THIS IS ACTUALLY.
WOULD BE THE NEXT STEP IN THE
PROGRESSION OF THE GRANT THAT WE
HAVE RUN FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS SO. HAVE HAD A TRACK
RECORD OF ASSISTING.
DISTRICTS OR AUTHORIZES WITH
SIX OR FEWER WE ACTUALLY OF.
PROVIDED TECHNICALS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ELEAZAR WHO HAVE
OF. A LARGER PORTFOLIO AS WELL
BUT THE GRANT THE FEDERAL GRANTS
THAT INITIATED THIS PROGRAM WAS
FOCUS ON.
SMALLER AUTHORIZES WHO TEND TO
BE THE ONES WHO NEED THE
SUPPORTS THEY DON'T HAVE
DESIGNATED STAFF. OUGHT TO FOCUS
ON OF LEARNING AND IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROCESSES AT A HIGH
QUALITY. AYE IN A HIGH QUALITY
WAY.
I'M GONNA LET MISS CAPELLAS
TALK ABOUT OUR MEASUREMENT TOOLS
SOME OF THE DATA THAT THEY'RE
GATHERING STATEWIDE ABOUT HOW
CHARTER AUTHORIZES ARE USING THE
TOOLS THE CARDS THAT PROVIDES.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
DONE THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS IS
TO UTILIZE AN EXTERNAL EVALUATOR
TO LOOK AT EACH ONE OF OUR
TRAININGS. AND CONFERENCES TO
MEASURE THE LEARNING BOTH BUT
FOR THE TRAINING OCCURRED AND
AFTER SO THAT WE CAN. ACTUALLY
SEE THE LEVEL OF GROWTH IN.
THE AUTHOR RISERS EXPERTISE.
THAT IS JUST ONE WAY THAT WE
WILL BE MEASURING THIS GOING
FORWARD AS WELL.
AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE
AUTHORIZATION PROCESS THAT'S A
DIFFERENT QUESTION. OTHERS ABOUT
THOSE WHO AUTHORIZED AND WHAT
CAN THEY DO WHAT CAN'T THEY DO
WHAT SHOULD THEY DO WHAT SHOULD
THEY DO.
BECAUSE I'M NOT QUITE SEE THE
DISTINCTION SO THAT AUTHORIZING.
PROCESS IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
AUTHORIZING PROCESS ABOUT
ASSISTING THOSE WHO ARE GOING
GAVE IN THISPROCESS AND IT DID
IT THERE ARE THOSE WHO OPPOSE
THE CURRENT AUTHORIZING PROCESS.
THIS BILL DOES NOT SPEAK TO
THAT.
AND I THINK THAT IS BECAUSE THAT
HAS SORT OF SPECIFIC OBJECTIVES
AND REPORTING ON EVERY YEAR BUT
THIS BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE
ANYTHING TELL THE LEN COMES IN
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS THAT
RIGHT.
THAT'S AYE THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
WRITTEN INTO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL BUT WHAT I CAN ON A LEAD MS
CAPELLA SPEAK TO THIS BUT WHAT
OUR OBJECTIVES HAVE BEEN IN THE
PAST AND HOW WE MEASURE THEM WE
WILL CONTINUE. DOING THAT WE
ACTUALLY.
.
JUST ANECDOTALLY THE FEEDBACK
THAT I'VE GOTTEN FROM OTHER
SUPERINTENDENTS OR OTHERS WHO
ARE.
CHARGED WITH AUTHORIZED THING
IS THAT.
BUT FOR SOME APART FOR FROM
CARS NOT APART FROM THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT THEY
RECEIVE THROUGH THIS PARTICULAR
GRANT.
THEY HAVE NO OTHER GODS ARE
EMPLOYED. OTHER THAN TO SIT DOWN
AND READ STATUTE ABOUT WHAT IS
REQUIRED SO.
REALLY ON THE GROUND THIS IT'S
BEEN VERY HELPFUL TO THEM AND I
WAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
ALLUDED TO US WE ARE NEEDS ARE
WE WE ARE AGNOSTIC.
IN THE PROCESS OF WHETHER YOU
ARE CHOOSING TO OR NOT TO
AUTHORIZE A CHARTER WE WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW THE LAW AND BE
ABLE TO REVIEW PETITIONS.
WITH.
USING GOOD PROCESSES AND TOOLS.
I WOULD YOU YOU KNOW MINISTER
DOLLARS A MORE ASSERTIVE ACT
FREQUENT.
.
MEASUREMENT DIDN'T AND
REPORTING ON WHAT'S ON HOW THIS
IS WORKING OUT UP UNTIL THIS LA
A REPORT WHICH CURRENTLY ISN'T
SETTLED TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION ANSWER.
CHINA.
AND IF YOU KNOW THE ANSWER YOU
CAN SHOOT IT OUT ANSWERED A.
QUESTION YOU WANT TO CONFIRM.
YEAH LISTEN WERE OPEN ANYTHING
DO THE STRENGTH IN THE BILL
STRENGTHENED METRICS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE EFFORT PRESSURE.
I THINK THAT IS THE SIZE.
I JUST I JUST WANTED TO. GO NO
GO AHEAD IF YOU NOT BEEN SET BUT
YOU THINK YOU KNOW I'VE GOT JUST
ONE MORE QUESTION.
SO I KNOW THAT ALSO PART OF A
CAR'S THAT'S BEEN DOING IS NOT
PROVIDING KIND OF CALIFORNIA'S.
TECHNOLOGY APPS AUTHORIZES IN A
WAY THAT'S BEEN REALLY VALUABLE
AND LITTLE OR NO COST I'M AND I
DON'T NECESSARILY SEE THAT
REFLECTED IN. IN IN THIS BILL IS
IS IT THE INTENTION TO MAKE THAT
AND TO EXPAND THE PRACTICE UNDER
THE SPELL ARE YOU TALK ABOUT
EPICENTER ENDS IN IN PARTICULAR
SO YES.
EPICENTER IS A SOFTWARE
PLATFORM.
THAT WE HAVE OFFERED A TO THE
DISTRICTS TO BE ABLE TO TRACK.
THEY ARE.
THE PROCESS AND TRACK THE
OVERSIGHT.
THE ELEMENTS OF THE OVERSIGHT
PROCESS THAT THEY ARE CHARGED
WITH AS.
AUTHORIZING ELEAZAR SO.
I'M NOT REALLY SURE OF HOW I'M
AND I'M NOT REALLY SURE IF WE
SPECIFIED HOW THAT. COST
STRUCTURE WOULD BE.
.
ABSORBED.
IN THE FUTURE.
BUT
IT'S DEFINITELY A TOOL THAT WE
USE.
TO HELP AUTHORIZES NOW. DO YOU
MISTER PALACES OR ANYTHING THAT
YOU WOULD ADD TO THAT.
NO OTHER THEN YEAH IT WASN'T
CALLED OUT SPECIFICALLY BUT IT
IS DEFINITELY A TOOL THAT WE
USE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CONDUCTING ALL OVERSIGHT
MONITORING IN AN EFFICIENT
MANNER.
I THINK YOU GOT TO EVER.
JUST GOING TO SIMPLY SAY I
APPRECIATE WHAT WHAT.
YOU YOU SAID AND I AND I AM
PLEASED TO KNOW THAT I I. I
CONTINUE TO SAY THAT THE NUMBER
ONE CHALLENGE WE FACE IS
AUTHORIZING. AND WE GET GOOD
AUTHORIZATIONS AND GOOD
AGREEMENTS AND UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN CHARTERS IN DISTRICTS
THAT OF AUTHORIZES A WE HAVE
BETTER SUCCESS IN TERMS OF
OUTCOME. OF AND LARGE DISTRICTS
CAN'T DO HAVE THE CAPACITY TO.
TO DO THAT THOUGH I KNOW SAN
DIEGO HAD A SPECIAL OFFICE
A PERSON DID AUTHORIZATIONS AND
SO.
THEY HAVE THE CHANCE TO BE IN
WORK WITH AUTHORIZED OR MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND CHANGES IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. AND SMALL
DISHES DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE RESOURCES SO THEY REALLY
NEED TO BECAUSE IF IF YOU KNOW
IF THE. THAT THE WHOLE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN CHARLES AND
DISTRICTS AUTHORIZES AUTHORIZES
NEED TO BE MORE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE FOR THE DISTRICTS AT THE
AUTHORIZING AND UNDERSTAND WHAT
AGREEMENTS THEY HAVE. WITHOUT
WITH THE CHARTERS AND SO ON ALSO
I'M PLEASED TO KNOW THAT IT'S
THERE THAT YOU ARE THAT YOU'VE
GOT IT WILL BE CONTINUING AND
THAT WE SHOULD OBVIOUSLY TAKE UP
THE SLACK OF OF FUNDING IT AT
THIS POINT. BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT AND AS CHARLES GROW
WHAT IT'S GOING TO EVEN BE MORE
IMPORTANT THEY HAVE SOME
TRAINING IN INFORMATION AND
GUIDANCE THROUGH THIS PROCESS.
US I THINK IT'S GREAT I I I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAD MOTION BUT
I OF. LIEU THE BILL.
THERE'S A.
HOW WE HAVE MOTION A SECOND IS
TO PASS?
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KILEY. KILEY NOT VOTING KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
STEINORTH. THURMOND. THURMOND
AYE WEBER WEBER AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT.
I BELIEVE THAT AS OUR FINAL ITEM
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF.
BILLS TO REVISIT FOR VOTING
PURPOSES SO AYE WILL RELINQUISH.
THE GAVEL TO MISTER O'DONNELL.
YEAH.
CLEARLY.
SO. OTHER ONLY TWO BILLS ON
BOTH.
ACADEMY TO ADD ONS.
WE CAN GET THERE ARE THERE ARE
TWO BILLS ON CALL.
IT AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE MY
MISTER THURMAN.
.
THE VOTERS.
THREE ZERO.
IF THE.
THE.
SIR HERE PLEASE CALL THE
REMAINING.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AMENDMENTS TO HELP.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH IS.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT WITH.
SEVEN VOTES AT.
AND THAT'S SIX SIX MONTHS CARE.
OTHER WE HAVE ONE MORE I'M SORRY
ONE MORE. ONE MORE IS.
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN. AND
IT'S A TWENTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT
BY MISS EGGMAN.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THAT'S DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
O'DONNELL AYE O'DONNELL AYE.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
OF HE THAT WENT OUT TO LIVE
AMONG.
THERE WAS OUT FIVE VOTES YET
FIVE VOTES THAT BILL IS OUT WITH
THAT WE WILL DO AT ARMS.
.
THEN THIS MEETING. IS
ADJOURNMENT BEFORE WE ADJOURN WE
SHOULD THANK THE STAFF HERE FOR
IF YOU'RE BAD IF YOUR BILL
PASSED THANK THEM. AND IF IT
DIDN'T THANK THEM BECAUSE THEY
SAVE YOU FROM YOURSELF. MADE THE
JOURNEY.
YEAH.
BUT MCCARTY WELL WHEN WE COME
ALL THE TIME
WERE YOU ONE OF THE.
ONE OF.
YOU ARE HERE SO YOU GOVERNOR'S
YEAH EXACTLY JUST GO* COLLAR
OKAY.
TITUS.
THIS AND SEVENTEEN NINETY. FOUR.
I AND.
AND